foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to round three of the
Tata steel chess tournament 2022 my name
is Fiona style Anthony and I'm delighted
to be joined once again by Grandmaster
Robert has Robert how are you today
I'm doing great another round from
Viking Zay how could I not be great
there's been fighting chess Galore so
we're in store for another great one I
think yes and well let's have a look
first of all uh at the results we had
yesterday for those of you who might
have missed the action the big game of
the day of course was Magnus Carlson
Victory uh over Anish giri actually the
first time that Magnus beat Anish here
in Vikings thus finally leveling the
score Anish famously beat him here all
the way back in 2011 and ever since
Magnus was chasing that first classical
vacancy win against Anish he got it
yesterday Robert
yeah that was a huge Victory and it was
a resounding one because it involved an
exchange sacrifice beautiful tactics a
niche wasn't up for the task and we
can't forget about that game between
report and Von Forest it was a long
battle and unfortunately for Jordan the
reigning Champion he was not able to
withstand the pressure he made a mistake
nearing the time control yes and if
you've missed that game you can check
out our rapid recap on our YouTube
channel where we go through the main
points of that game the other decisive
result was a Richard report overcoming
Jordan van Ferris after Jordan blundered
late into the the end game so those were
the two decisive results and out of the
drawers I think Robert's
sepenko had to stand out
yeah Mama Jared has been playing such
electric chess thus far his two draws
don't speak to the exciting chess he's
been playing we'll see how he fares in
round three today
absolutely so let's look at the
standings after two rounds uh we have
three uh players in the joint leading
world champion Magnus Carlson Jan
krishnoff do that and visit Gujarati and
Robert I suggest we go straight to
today's pairings because I think there's
one game that allies are gonna be on
you know for sure because we have seven
Great pairings every single day but I
think I know which one you're talking
about except this one between yes a
Panko and cardiacin right the old
Russian Clash of course or could it be
on Michigan
no the game that I was talking about
here it is younger stuff do that against
world champion Magnus Carlson not only
uh two of the co-leaders of the
tournament but also the leading world
champion against the winner of last
year's World Cup and of course Janu
shotuda has qualified to the candidates
uh where he will try and become magnus's
next Challenger
and we know that Magnus likes a new feat
and he lost to Young chest of Judah in
the World Cup revenge is undoubtedly on
his mind here in vikon Zay but Magnus
does have the black pieces so when
you're looking for a certain result but
you have the second move in the game I'm
not sure if that's comfortable territory
for Magnus Carlson yeah I think a very
interesting uh match up here today I'm
very excited to see what happens of
course a lot of other great clashes uh
the American clash between Fabiano
caruana and Sam shankland also we'll see
how does Anish bounce back against
Muhammad yarov who had two exciting
draws so plenty of action to look
forward to and you two at home can get
involved Robert how do they do it
well they shouldn't forget to vote
voting is a right it's a you know Duty
some might say and you can get involved
by voting on the results of these games
here go to chess.com events navigate to
the tournament select a game click vote
and select your winner you could win a
piece of the one thousand dollar prize
best voters or free Diamond memberships
voting ends after the 10th move of each
game so don't miss out and remember to
vote on all the games Fiona I mean I
think we can go vote as well and then
we'll be back and ready for the round
right absolutely don't go anywhere we'll
be back in just a few minutes and we'll
see all the players coming the start of
the game plenty to look forward to stay
tuned
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
welcome back we're just two minutes away
from the start of round three here at
the Tata steel chest tournament and here
we see the two Russian players andreasi
Panko and kariakin ready to do battle
also Jordan then for Waste has just
arrived for his Clash against
pragnananda
and while Duda Robert we're not
surprised Magnus is very often the lands
to arrive in the playing Hall
he is indeed they say Save The Best For
Last and he's the best chess player in
the world so he has every right to come
in last but here we see all the players
there's the Challenger section as well
so there should be 28 players filling up
these seats absolutely and this one is
another game I'm very looking forward to
Anish giri who I last year went
undefeated uh during the Saturday
a tough loss against Magnus and Shakira
he has shown that he is not shying away
from any craziness and there the the all
too familiar imagine these pandemic
times of Rapport arriving and the
players wanting to go for a handshake
and changing it to a fist bump at the
last second
I think they're just playing rock paper
scissors Fiona you know they they want
us to think it's about the handshake no
no no they're just playing rosham bull
having a little bit of fun and we see
Mom and jar getting ready to start the
game
a funny image I mean it's not even two
o'clock yet but uh clearly raring to go
yeah he seems quite eager and if his
play has been any indication he's having
himself a good old time G4 on move three
yesterday the clocks have been pressed
Anish gets to make the first move but
we'll see what surprises Mama jar has
for us today
and well the clocks have been started we
see that Duda um is actually waiting for
Magnus uh I think there was a video
right
from the world rapid and Blitz wasn't it
Magnus himself who waited was it for
dude there was someone else but uh we'll
see and there is Magnus we just see him
walking onto the stage we get a proper
handshake and uh Magnus starting the
clock and we'll see what opening does do
that go for it's only four
and you are correct it was Duda versus
Magnus at the world's uh Blitz where he
waited for him which was very polite I
could have been the rapid but either way
uh it was these two players so a ton of
mutual respect between the two uh dude
against the white pieces in this game he
starts with E4 will we see one of these
rosalimo Sicilians from Magnus he of
course plays E4 E5 as black he used that
against yonda palmistry so I'm wondering
if they're just these phases that Magnus
goes through how he decides on his first
turn but he is so versatile as a player
that I wouldn't be surprised by any
first move at least one that's
reasonable I would be surprised by one
opening move and that's one C6 the
karaoke because that's exactly the
opening that Magnus used in his game
against Duda which was the streak uh the
no loss streak Ending game from Norway
chess a couple of years ago
yeah so unhappy memories but sometimes
you need to fight through it right if
you fall off your bike and you're trying
to learn you got to get right back on it
so we could see all pawns no hope in a
Carroll gun
and no Magnus says we'll take it more
solidly one E5 we haven't seen so much
uh E4 E5 action so far in the tournament
Robert
no we haven't really it's actually
interesting we've seen a lot of offbeat
openings we've seen some catalones but
yeah E4 E5 the traditional Spanish
that's not something that we have had
thus far but today's a new day a new
opening may be the theme of the day and
of course we're still early here in
Vikings I don't mean to rhyme I'm not Dr
Seuss but it just so happened that it
worked out I think maybe we had only one
right in the grand Alias the first round
Grand delius Jordan or was it the other
way Jordan with the with the white
dresses and but yeah very few Ray
Lopez's
um so far and well we'll see uh which
line
um Magnus goes for
I think you know of course I never want
to go away from Magnus against Judo but
I want to bring our attention to another
game very quickly because it's not an
opening we see every day so speaking of
how often things happen I'm going to
click on this game between van forest
and prognananda because Fiona look at
this opening here Bishop C4 on move
three in a sicilian right it's like once
shopping one move short of expectations
but it's not a tactic because usually
the bishop lands on B5 and threatens to
take the Knight we've seen this many
times including the 2018 World Chess
Championship instead the Bishops on C4
is that really what Jordan did is it a
surprise against his young opponent I
think uh yes clearly Jordan wanting to
to take uh his young opponent onto not
novel territory because I'm sure
pregnant and that has seen the move
before but um rarer territory shall we
say Bishop C4 is not a move that we see
often at all on the highest level but
here then he's shown us last year
already always came very well prepared
with some fresh interesting uh opening
ideas and so much so that even world
champion Magnus Carlson
his attention was drawn and he recruited
Jordan onto his world championship team
yeah he is a great player of course but
also amazing in preparation he used it
to his Advantage last year but there are
some pluses of making a bit of an
atypical move because the most logical
reply in my opinion is a move like E6
shutting down the bishop on the diagonal
but if you don't play cecilians with the
move E6 say you're used to playing
dragon type of positions being carrying
the bishop then E6 takes you out of your
element so I do like it from the
perspective that now prognanda has to
think what does this guy want from me
there are many moves D6 makes sense E6
makes sense even G6 right but now you
have to make a choice and then figure
out what is Jordan planning so I do like
this from psychological perspective
Fiona absolutely agreed and I think it's
always interesting to to see games that
leave the beaten path quite soon and we
get to see some fresh ideas and fresh
positions
Robert shall we go to the bird's eye
view and get some kind of idea of what
is happening on all the other all the
other words in these early stages
you know this has quickly become my
favorite scene to look at so we have
seven games a bunch of options to choose
from and the top left we have Duda
against Carlson it might you know you
could replace judah's name with
napomnishi because that opening looks
very familiar from their world
championship bout no surprise that Duda
would have studied those games next to
that dubov and vidit we're in the Talon
game still early stages carwana Shanklin
oh that's in a Berlin is Maxine Buster
lagrav here no he's not the world Blitz
Champion is not here but his influence
and the influence of many of the Great
predecessors in the Berlin that's uh on
the board and actually let me ask you if
you know while we stay in this view so
when you see the Berlin and you see
Shanklin maybe testing carwana in these
queenless lines what do you think his
mentality is because Fabiano he's had
two draws pretty solid start not exactly
what he wanted but on shanklin's end he
lost the game and then couldn't convert
an advantage yesterday so what do you
think he's looking for from the black
side of this Berlin yeah I'm curious I I
think it means that shankland is very
confident in his analysis I have to say
the Berlin opening one of the ones that
I'm probably least familiar with in the
entire Chess World I've never played
them on either side I had I never had
any interest in an early Queen swab
never looked at this end game even once
but I would say a brave decision to to
challenge Fabiano here I mean he is so
well versed but yeah so I'm showing
confidence and I think what he wants is
to keep it solid
and we will see what what is your
impression of the opening Choice what do
you make of it yeah Sam is extremely
well prepared but so is Fabiano and he
has a lot of experience and he decided
to go into the end game in the Berlin
the Queens are off so actually I'll
bring that board up so we can talk a
little bit about it because the first
critical moment in this game comes right
here after Knight F6 because the ante
Berlin would move the move D3 here
that's becoming increasingly popular as
these top level players seek to avoid
preparation or at least the really deep
lines because then there's no Queen
trade your Pawn is defended but as we
see in the main line coming up here D4
you don't want to take on D4 that opens
up the e-file your king is still in the
center so the Knight Retreats we see a
swap and then a capture on E5 off go the
queens and Fiona you know even if you
don't play the Berlin yourself of course
you're the very experienced commentator
we've seen this opening like seven
million times even if this opening has
only been played you know three million
times we have seen it way too much of it
uh for most of our likings but it is a
fascinating end game and Shanklin starts
with the move King to E8 in this
position here there are many options
King 8 being the most popular moves like
Bishop to D7 you could push your H Pawn
uh the move Bishop D7 may say I might
move my king towards the queen side and
set it back towards the center but King
E8 does make perfect sense it protects
F7 in advance it allows black to
continue playing uh here on the king
side and Bishop F4
we see Bishop E7 Rook ad1 Bishop E6 and
B3 so we're we're not in New Territory
both players have seen this before
they're playing quickly and there have
been many games in this line and I would
say the the big principles in this
position black has the bishop pair but
the compromise Pawn structure so I think
people tend to struggle with this
Dynamic with well I don't like my Pawn
structure we're in an end game but Fiona
how does the bishop pair compensate for
the double pawns here
well the bishop pair
um I guess black is often looking for
the position to open up for those
Bishops to get even more scope uh we
already seated the bishop on E6 looking
down at the words H3 we see that upon
has been pushed uh to age five so very
often black will be looking to open up
the position to use the maximum power of
the bishop here
that's true and black can do that on
both sides right there's sometimes where
black should play A5 A4 but I think
Fabiano chose a wise setup against this
bishop on E6 because the last thing
Bishops want is to be staring into a
pawn chain like this and the B3 Pawn
limits the scope so Shanklin is thinking
here I believe B3 is a bit of a rare
move there's moves like Knight to G5 and
after Knight to G5
if we go down theoretical lines here
there's this funny move Rook H6 and I
played the Berlin from Black's
perspective mainly and Rook H6 if you're
not familiar with this opening you're
not playing that move because you're
walking into discoveries but a move like
Rook H6 once the Knight captures on E6
The Rook takes back and that Rook is
actually quite nice there because the
bishop uh is well placed on E7 the
Knight on F5 is looking good and this E5
Pawn can be seen as a strength because
it limits Black's Mobility but at the
same time in certain end games it's a
pawn that's gone too far it's
overextended and can be attacked so
instead of these kind of funkier
variations we saw B3 played and now
Shanklin the one taken out of his
preparation uh perhaps because we see
him on screen Fiona does that look like
a thrill chess player
it doesn't but then you very rarely I
feel like some you see him looking
thrilled more after Victory
um well yesterday we saw him of course
being quite disappointed uh after the
game against Niels grandelius he was
clearly the one in control he was he had
a big Advantage at some point
but today I don't know Robert I think
you're never gonna be too thrilled if
you're playing the Berlin against
Fabiano it's never going to be a fun day
at the office but I think yes I'm mostly
just looking to stay solid here and
Robert I've got an interesting question
uh in the chat I saw that then I thought
I was asking is it common to go for
quick draws against compatriots
I think unfortunately we see that as
sometimes
but speaking about this game here I
absolutely do not think we will see a
quick draw just because they are both
from the U.S Fabiano is of course
looking to win the tournament here in
tata steel he is playing with the white
pieces Sam is one of the the lower rated
players of the field so I think uh we
will absolutely not see an early draw
here what do you think Robert
yeah I think those draws are typically
reserved for good friends no matter what
country they are from we see that
karyakan and mamajarov historically have
often made relatively quick draws now
Fabiano and Shanklin I'm sure have a ton
of mutual respect but from what I know
of they're not like best friends they
don't work together that's always an
awkward scenario when a second plays the
person that they help prepare so when we
see dubov against Carlson because
they've helped that player come up with
their openings and fine-tune them so
it's not a comfortable experience but
just being from the same country I don't
think that's particularly meaningful uh
for the most part they're professionals
they have to score victories in
important moments and if you're just
saying hey I'm playing my friend but
wait I also need that Victory that's not
a good scenario to be in so these
players uh they're very accustomed to
playing people over and over again even
if they are friends even if they are
compatriots so no I do not think we will
see anything except the battle in this
game even if the results is eventually a
draw it will be a fight and Sam Shanklin
he's looking like he's having an
internal battle right now because he
doesn't know what to do and that's the
beauty of taking someone out of their
preparation not with an exciting move B3
is just a move but then you have to ask
what has changed in the position of
course I said in Knight G5 there was
Rook H6 Rook Hicks not possible now but
in the future will Knight G5 be played
by white and then will Rook H6 still be
the correct move you may ask what has
changed it looks like nothing but you
need to figure that out and Sam says
Rook to d8 putting a rook to the open
file rather than playing a move like H4
which is one that I was going to suggest
or even A5 on the opposite flank Rook d8
of course fighting for the open file you
can't really complain about that choice
yeah I think this here will be a big
prep very often this is what we see in
the the Berlin end game because as you
said as it has been played so so many
times the players are so well versed and
very often it comes down to these tiny
nuances uh where is the new move the new
idea coming from uh so we'll see I think
we'll come back here Robert I hope you
don't mind taking me taking you away
from this exciting Berlin end game and
maybe we can quickly again go to the
bird's eye view for one second but we
were just talking about a duboff and I
was thinking maybe we could go there
because I think one of the reasons that
we have been seeing uh less Berlin end
games is because the Italian game the
Joko piano has come more into fashion in
the last couple of years and that's what
we have in this duboff visit game yeah
it's a great transition to make so we
will look at the opening stage here
because as Fiona pointed out we see
Bishop C4 the Italian game and after
Knight F6 D3 so we were talking about
how D3 can protect the E4 Pawn in these
anti-berlin positions but this is the
start of the Italian Bishop C5 C3 this
is a flexible Choice by white perhaps
there's a B4 there's a D4 in the future
challenging the bishop on C5 but black
continues with D6 opening up the light
score bishop and now Fiona this choice
of Bishop G5 H6 Bishop H4 we see this
quite often in these Italians and the
big question that is asked is Will black
play G5 a very middle Choice making it
more dangerous to Castle kingside even
though black still can in many positions
but will vid it say I'm ready for this
I'm gonna play G5 or does he think I'm
playing Daniel dubal that guy is as
creative as they get he's clearly
looking for something in this opening
Maybe I should refrain from these kind
of Pawn pushes
yeah I'm very curious I I'm not sure
maybe you will know this uh Robert if uh
duboff often plays the Italian game or
if the the real Lopez is more his
Preferred Choice because I think the
question is often I did with it expected
if he expected it it's much much more
pleasant of course to face this decision
if you have looked at it
with your computer with your second
before the game if you haven't looked at
it in a while it's more difficult to
make the decision over the board about
whether you want to go G5 or not
yeah and it's because actually after the
move D6 Bishop G5 is far from the most
common move so already he has caught
video in an unfamiliar position because
at this point time castling is what most
players play they say I'm just going to
get my king uh over to the king side
safe and sound there are the move Knight
to D2 because the Knight often reroutes
D2 F1 and then either G or E3 so if you
start with Knight D2 you can play Knight
F1 before castling and then having to
play rookie one as well so there are
plenty of options here B4 is another so
Bishop G5 not the most common move but
played here in this game and after H6
Bishop H4 he plays the move A5 so on the
other side of the board stopping any
sort of B4 pushes but leaving this pin
alive I think that's a good practical
Choice against dubov uh you asked about
dubov's openings generally speaking the
answer is he plays what he wants that's
what I've learned from dubo if he does
play play the Italian from the white
side but he is so look I mean look at
this look at that move Knight A3 I mean
I understand it right the Knight is
developing it's probably just trying to
drop back to C2 or it can hop into B5
because there's no A6 move so in a way
Knight A3 takes advantage of the fact
that black just pushed this Pawn because
there's a not an outpost but it takes
time for black to move the Knight and
then play C6 to kick it and from B5 then
you can play the move sorry I'm drawing
arrows and taking them away then you can
make the move d4 and it's all protected
from
both Knights and the queen so what a
opening so far yeah and it's certainly a
on slightly uncomfortable spot to find
yourself in when you're Vivid here
because we look at the clock the players
start with an hour of 40 on the clock so
Daniel duboff after it moves he's up
three minutes so he's played every move
uh instantly yesterday in his game
against kayak and dubov actually
finished with more time on the clock
than he started with so duboff you
already mentioned it most judgments we
know so creative
um so well prepared well prepared as
well
so always a tough spot to find yourself
on the receiving end of your opponent
playing some
um not so common moves and blitzing them
out like that
in Knight A3 more common here is the
move Pawn to A4 for white and these
positions usually go something like A4
um I think G5 first makes sense that way
there's no sacrifices Bishop G3 castles
castles King G7 they have seen this type
of position with young just of Duda
playing a number of times these maybe
it's not this exact position but it is
similar to this white brings the Knight
into D2 and so on and playing A4 stops
black from doing it but due to uh do
ball do this place disposition dubov is
playing the game here and Knight A3 is
the choice and I think most of our
viewers would say I was literally just
gonna ask you that right like Bishop
takes A3 obviously is the move and after
Pawn takes A3 we see a compromised Pawn
structure here from White's perspective
now there is a bit of good news this
Pawn is up on A5 which means the B5
square is kind of whites for the taking
as it was in some of the other positions
we were looking at and the B file being
open could be beneficial for white and
there is the two Bishops Advantage so
that's what I think white is looking to
really use
it's not a clear position I think that
who has really benefited it's both sides
have benefited in their own ways I mean
once a piece goes to the B file black
can play B6 shut it all down so it's not
like you're going to actually get
pressure along the semi-open line but
still having the bishop pair is nice if
you want to break this pin and make this
move G5 that's always weakening on your
king side and white will try to make D4
happen at some point in the near future
and we see a visit deep in thought it's
actually I mean the meme was like I know
you're not the biggest fan of all the
chat memes Robert but it's so funny to
me how vitted one of it is thinking and
default thinking processes that did not
like this
um emote and yeah um he has a lot to
figure out here I think we'll come back
to this game uh in a little bit
and I don't know if you want to jump
elsewhere if you want to have a look at
the bird's eye view first I'll let you
choose Robert
uh yeah I love the bird's eye view so we
can stay here for a second uh the Jordan
Von Forest gaming is prognanda that
looks like it's at the local club and
you have no idea what the player's
ratings are uh because that's not an
opening you see every day black is up a
pawn and white moved that Bishop twice
we see the bishop on B5 and a black Pawn
on e4 that's the top right hand side of
your screen everybody and we saw Bishop
C4 on the third move so we can actually
maybe bring that game up just before we
go there Robert I also wanted to point
out the game between Nils grendelius and
Richard report uh in a while we can go
there as well because we see a problem
already on G4
um so that's also an interesting game
which uh which is catching my eye from
the bird's eye view now that's a good
catch by you because I was so focused on
this pain in the top right I didn't look
the bottom right and that's going to be
a sharp battle between two very
adventurous players Niels grendelius and
rehard report so I think we'll start top
right just because we're only looking at
it for a second then we'll go right to
Grand delius report and of course we
will get to Duda Carlson don't you worry
we know that's going to be a very
important game for the standings but I
always want to bring up three moves ago
white played the bishop C4 here that's
what Jordan did E6 a principal reply
shutting down The Bishop's diagonal with
this Pawn chain and then playing for D5
so castles D5 and most players would
immediately capture on D5 Jordan Von
Forest is not most players he says I'm
gonna play Bishop to B5 so I'll move
that same minor piece twice and I
allowed you to take control in the
center and after d takes E4 Knight to E5
Fiona we see the point there is a pinned
Knight on C6 attack twice you can ruin
Black's Pawn structure but what it
obscure opening line and I guess my
question for you is do you like what
Jordan has done do you think he's
playing tricky chess or is he just
trying to catch his young less
experienced opponent off guard and try
to take this one
in general
um I'm a fan of of the players going for
these more offbeat lines I think as a
chess fan as a chess commentator we
commentate on on so many berlins and
these positional Joko pianos with tiny
nuances so I think it's always a brush a
brush or fresh air a breath of fresh air
um to see uh to see players like Jordan
players like rap World players like
duboff coming up with new ideas even as
early you know as move three and four uh
it makes our job harder of course as
commentators when we have so many new
people watching us in the chat and every
day we've been in this spot you know
because we will tell you and your
coaches will tell you develop your
pieces get your king into safety control
the center so it's it's hard from that
point of view to explain explain what
the players are doing but from the fan
perspective I really like seeing these
kind of offbeat openings
yeah I love it and it does make our job
harder because normally we can be like
oh well Magnus played this against five
different opponents and we can cite all
this research and just from our prior
knowledge of the game this is New
Territory and it's new territory for us
it's definitely new territory for
pragueananda but the one person it's not
new territory for is Jordan Von Forest
he has worked on this at home and you
may wonder why is Prague on the thinking
at this moment a knight was captured of
course he's gonna capture the night back
but let's wait a second let's take our
time Bishop D7 is sometimes a way to
meet this Knight capture we will pin the
Knight to the bishop he did capture back
on C6 quickly show you why Bishop D7
isn't ideal Knight takes A7 a wonderful
move protecting the bishop and if black
takes on A7 white will then trade
Bishops and say I have evened up the
material now your Pawn structure is
worse than mine and your Rook is weirdly
on A7 so that was not an option for
black I'm sorry Robert I just have to
laugh that the bishop is back on C4
yeah
it went back to C4 and it's just moving
the same piece way too many times but
we'll get into why it makes sense just
after it quickly this A6 Knight D4 check
to me makes sense after ab5 Knight B5
again now we have material equality and
black has this E4 Pawn that sticks out
there's a knight coming to C3 that E4
Pawn will quickly be attacked not that
easy to defend so that is why
prognananda
I decided to take back on C6 which makes
perfect sense we see Bishop C4 and
that's why you had a good laugh here
because that Bishop went C4 B5 back to
C4 and black is up a pawn but the thing
about this position is double isolated
pawns double Pawns in the center and so
white will make moves like Knight C3
bring a piece to the E file like Queen
to E2 and go out for the pawn and if
you're gonna try to save that pawn you
didn't make the move F5 which is so
weakening uh for example Bishop D6 Pawn
H3 I don't want to lose my palm but
check you play Knight to F6 let's say I
play Knight C3 and then Queen E2 and I
simply win the pawn by force you can't
defend it so if you really want to save
that pawn you have to make a move at
some point F5 but that weakens your
opponent on E6 and I will play D3 be
upon down open up the E file and try to
just you know crash through so there's
going to be risky decisions that have to
be made by prognanda in this line and
Jordan is the one who's prepared here
this actually is really dangerous for
Prague yeah I think actually today both
our Indian participants in the the
Masters group pregnant and visit both
being put to the test straight out of
the opening opening by two members of
Team Magnus and I think both of them
will have to go deep into the tank
because this is a position where it's
not about coming up with your next move
it is about how do I want to set up
long-term do I want to to try and hold
on to my Pawn on on e4 will I give it
back if I give it back what's the best
way to do so
um so a very interesting battle ahead
here and we see the close-up of pregnant
and that they're deep and false with the
eyes sort of darting around the world
and he's way down on the clock already
so Jordan in his prep he is put probably
not to the the test here and the
youngster he'll need to come up with
something pretty quickly because only
move eight the position will remain
sharp for quite a deal of time and look
at Jordan arms crossed he's feeling good
about how this opening has gone this far
and Robert actually very interesting
Insight from one of my dear twitch
viewers who's in the chat shout out to
frisky Frog who said and maybe we have
to double check it but he's usually
quite reliable he's saying he uh Jack
leeches and apparently Max warmadam had
this position uh in the Blitz game Max
warmadam who is Jordan's second born
last year so some very interesting uh
insights there
does that make Max magnus's Grand second
like you know if he's the second to
magnus's second is that a grand second
how does that work in chess I'm just
gonna take us back to the bird's eye
view and pretend I never said that
because asking questions that nobody
wants the answer to
so back to his words like
what's going on in the Carlson game
I think they are going down a path that
both of them are quite familiar with we
will get to that in a second do you want
to start with that should we have a
quick look at glendaleas first which way
do you want to go I did say we'd go to
the grendelius game so why don't we go
there I made a promise I'd like to keep
it it does look like a very interesting
battle yes a panko decided to strike in
the center with D4 so that might heat up
at some point but let's go to Nils and
uh rehard here because that's a sicilian
that promises to be a good game and we
are on move eight and report is thinking
so the last move Play Let's Go let me
just go through from the beginning
see how we got here in the Sicilian D4
the Knight came to C6 Knight C3 and
queen C7 so this move is very popular
uh from Black's perspective it's quite
flexible oftentimes we think of the song
we need to play A6 but a knight coming
to B5 will be kicked by A6 in the near
future so it's not too big of a concern
a G4 played by NEOS and what can we say
Fiona everybody is inspired by Shakura
mamajarv right
those those guys had a thing or two did
it with it as well we know we see that
players in general in the last few years
have been taking a lot more liberties
with their g-pawns with their H pawns
um and yeah here
G4 well immediately Neil's wanting to
play on the king side maybe Robert maybe
you can try and explain what's the idea
behind the move like G4 which right now
it doesn't attack anything it doesn't
seem to be doing uh to have any concrete
threats so maybe you can explain what
are the ideas
yeah G4 looks like a bad move but it's
not it just looks that way because what
in the world is it doing you're throwing
your Pawn up there
um just to show everybody what's more
typical Bishop E3 or Bishop to E2 played
tens and tens of thousands of times it's
a very common position here but instead
the move G4 is played and that does
prevent Knight F6 because if you played
Knight F6 I quickly played G5 and guess
what your knight is going
what I assumed back to G8 but I guess
not maybe there's some kind of Knight
takes D4 that allows the Knight to go
forward I I thought G5 I mean that looks
reasonable to Me Maybe Knight B5 first
makes more sense and then we can play a
move like G5 that way there's no nitrate
because the point is the queen covers
these squares so that Knight is not
exactly happy on F6 because it has to
drop back to G so that's the correct
move order but the point still stands a
G5 forces the Knight back and that is
the issue for black so instead of
playing Knight F6 H6 was played that way
black can go Knight F6 but we call this
Pawn a hook and it's a hook because when
white tries to play G5 it will open up
lines because it attacks a pawn so in
the game we saw Bishop E3 and I have six
and F3 and if black dares to Castle
kingside G5 will happen and lines are
opening up whether black likes it or not
so Fiona I really like the direction
this game game is going it's going to be
difficult for black to decide what to do
with the King because there's that pawn
H6 so you played H6 to allow the night
out but then you kind of regret playing
it because you can't really cast a
chainsaw with ease yeah I think it's
always an interesting question in these
positions where we see early uh kingside
Pawn pushes of where does the king go
you're talking about the black king do
you think the white king will go
queenside
I think that yes the white king is gonna
you know Queen D2 castle queenside
adventure over there and at some point
black has to make the move A6 because
you don't want to allow Knight B5 when
you're not looking carefully because
that's going to be a big problem hitting
the queen and the dark squares we see
that this Pawn structure D7 E6 F7 that
leaves the dark scores vulnerable
because pawns right they capture
diagonally and they protect the same
color that they're on so the D6 Square
could be a problem for black to deal
with and that's why A6 is the way to
play and maybe even B5 to follow up so
uh I just find these positions a bit
easier to play from White's point of
view the ideas register a little more
clearly to me that said report is such
an experienced player and he loves
tactical battles but I do prefer niels's
position at this early stage yeah it's
certainly an exciting battle ahead here
between two very creative players we see
Richard has just made another move so A6
trying to stop any nights coming to B5
which makes a lot of sense Robert I
suggest we take our first quick break of
the day and when we come back we'll look
at the Magnus Carson versus dude I will
do that versus Magnus Carson Clash so
don't go anywhere and we'll be right
back
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the third round of the
status deal chess tournament and Robert
we're back with the bird's life you may
be a quick Overlook before we finally
dive into this uh do that Carlson game
yeah honestly we have some great starts
to the games here we saw dubov against
vidit that Knight A3 move which seemed
to be a novelty and was captured by
vidit we have a Berlin end game between
carwana and Shanklin Avon Forest has
surprised us all by moving his Bishop
three times in the early stages and look
at that he didn't even play H3 he put
his King on H1 giving up the H2 Pawn to
try to trap the bishop but what a game
so far between those two players Von
forest and prognanda I mean we haven't
even looked at giri mamajaro but that
looks like it's shaping up for a fun one
as well and then Jessa panko against
cardiac and the countrymen uh D4 has
been played but no reaction really by
karyakin seems like a solid Affair in
that one and we'd like the Sicilian
between grandilis and report so I think
Fiona were in store for a great day
we've already had five decisive games in
the first 14 match-ups and the two
rounds so I think we'll have more today
to yeah and actually although I know you
you don't like predictions for it so I'm
not going to torture you on every game
but I like our little prediction of how
many decisive games which is a quick and
painless one yesterday I was way off the
mic I predicted for you predicted three
close but no cigar how many today
oh great question I'm looking at the
games I will go with
I think two
I think we'll get two okay and I want to
outdo you again so I'll go with with
three
okay it's funny because I was going to
say three initially and then I was like
if I say three Fiona won't say three so
here let me Reserve that number so
considerate robbery
uh well I do think that we have um the
types of games that are likely to end
decisively so I just very combative
Spirits for the players at least in the
early move so let's uh go to the game
between Duda and Carlson we promised
everybody the World Chess Championship
with the black pieces Against the World
Cup champion with the white pieces we
have to remember that Duda knocked out
Carlson from the World Cup that was
pretty uh amazing a grand achievement
from the Polish number one and in this
game Fiona I don't know if you want to
should we go back to the star you think
or should we just I think it might be
interesting especially since you were
one of the main commentators at the uh
for the world championship match between
the promenashi and Carson maybe you can
tell us a little bit about the
similarities and maybe we can find where
did we deviate it if at all
okay well we had E4 E5 throughout the
match between nepo and Carlson
um John upanishi he chose E4 a bunch and
Magnus did not put the Sicilian he did
in 2018 against five on a carwana so we
had a Spanish and Knight F6 castles all
of this is Mainline stuff Bishop E7 Rook
E1 and this B5 Rook B8 business that
happens here uh The Rook needs to slide
off the a file because with the Rook on
A1 a takes B5 was a huge threat just to
turn a go you give white a free move you
lose a pawn now in this position black
and shoes Bishop to B7 or B4 both of
which are more popular than the Rook V8
move but now it in my head I think I
have recency biased like rookie is the
move even though these other two moves
are more popular it's kind of funny how
that works Fiona we're like Magnus play
something so we just kind of assumed
that's what should be done even if other
moves have been played for a long long
time and I really think theory is also
so heavily influenced by World
Championship matches so I think there is
the reasons element you mentioned and
then these moves that are played by the
top players in the world backed by top
computer analysis analyzes backed by top
teams and they pick up in fashion uh so
quickly and get rapidly replicated a lot
in no time
exactly so I mean in the early game of
the match between
um Jan and Magnus at this point in time
A4 was not played in fact H3 was the
choice and then Magnus made this move
Knight to A5 so it was a very
interesting try it got a bit sharp but
Magnus was able to actually quite easily
make a draw it seemed after a little
while so in this game and as Jan
switched to in the match A4 is the
choice now as we mentioned A4 attacks
the B5 pawn and Magnus decides on Rook
to B8 getting his Rook off of the open
or the opening a file so this move
um it does make sense one of the times
Magnus uh played Bishop B7 as well so he
he chooses what he wants to do on a
given day he is kind of unpredictable
maybe that's the Jordan Von Forest
influence right
yeah absolutely and we're reminded it
reminds me always of that video that was
published after the match of magnus's
team of seconds I believe they had a
camp in Spain or somewhere before uh
before the match where Magnus himself
introduces every member of the team you
know Peter Heine Nielsen is the adult in
the room and then Jan he's the Marshall
guy I look up the video I don't want to
get things wrong but then Jordan was
introduced as The New Guy where they
still would have to to check if his
ideas were actually any good
I I think they are quite good but yeah
that video was really funny I like the
team spirit involved his clear Chemistry
Between the various seconds and well H3
D6 the seconds romance Carlson should
not be surprised to see this anymore it
was played in the World Chess
Championship and after C3 uh B4 was
still following game five from the world
championship D3 pawns takes C3 takes and
here H6 that is different from what
Magnus did in game five he chose the
move Pawn to D5 and
Pawn D5 loosens your protection of the
E5 Pawn because you have this chain here
and that makes this Pawn safe and sound
so I play D5 you're striking in the
center trying to open the board up a bit
but it is a logical move though he got
himself in some trouble in that game
where in this uh position here his
Bishop was kind of awkward on D6 and
later there was a moment where Jan could
have pressed forward by trying to push
his Pawn up the board so it's a bit
passive from Black's perspective so here
in this game today we saw H6 a sort of
waiting move Bishop E3 developing Rook
E8 Knight D2 and Bishop f8 so I would
say that this maneuver Fiona of rookie
Bishop f8 is probably kind of awkward to
many in the audience of what are you are
you really improving your pieces like
your Bishop's going back to its starting
square but this is such a common Spanish
decision to put the bishop on a fate and
try to go G6
so do you think uh now that we've seen
this maneuver it means black history
from the plan of going uh for D5 he's
not gonna be looking to strike in the
center anymore but try to bring the
bishop to G7
yeah I think he's just going to refrain
from doing that he knows that's the type
of game that Duda wants he can play
Bishop E6 at some point to trade off uh
those light Square Bishops and what's
happening here is that white has a bit
more mobility in terms of the pawn
pushers we talked about D5 but when you
make this move D5 you hurt your own Pawn
structure as black whereas the move d4
simply improves White's position as long
as you make sure that your E4 Pawn is
defended so uh black sits a little bit
more passively but it's nothing really
to speak up to complain about uh what
he's going to attempt D4 and Bot has to
be comfortable with a more cramped
position and we know that Magnus has
said during the World Championship in
those interviews he's like yeah it's a
little bit worse for black you just have
to be okay with that and it seems like
he is and you talk about uh White
wanting to to probably push D4 in the
center how soon maybe this is an
interesting question when do we know as
white that we we are ready for that push
the night from D2 for example do we want
that to stay there do we want to
maneuver it elsewhere maybe via F1 and
G3 when do we know we're ready for the
D4 push
such a good question that I honestly
don't have a complete answer to but I
will try my best a large part of it is
the E4 pawn and here there's a rook on
E8 and a knight on F6 so you have to be
very careful which is why I'd probably
lead with the move Queen to C2 just to
make sure that my Pawn is defended so
when I do push D4 I don't have to worry
about dropping a pawn that said I don't
think you can actually capture on e4 if
you play D4 right away because after
Pawn takes Pawn takes this is very
common 94 takes Rook E4 you see the
evaluation part about because Bishop D5
is a
move with a dual threat hitting your
rook and your knight and you can't
defend both white simply Scoops up
material so it is possible to play D4
but the downside of playing D4 is that
it is committal and we know chess
players there they worry about
commitment
um but I mean and I mean that anything
you want to to talk about no no I you
know I don't think we need to dive too
deep into this conversation but from a
chess perspective not from a life
perspective uh the issue is that now
there's this permanent tension and while
we like to maintain the tension in chess
very often that it leaves black with the
opportunity at some point to take on D4
and even taking immediately on D4
without following up with Knight takes
E4 because that's a bad move but the
fact that you then have to go and
protect this Pawn is going to be
annoying for example if black plays
Knight to B4 now I am threatening to
take your Pawn on e4 because there's no
Bishop B5 funny business we have to
remind everybody quickly that 94 wasn't
possible because Bishop D5 forked the
two pieces and with the Knight on B4
there's no Knight to attack and the D5
square is covered so in this variation
after Knight B4 this is why chess
players are afraid of commitment because
how do you defend this E4 Pawn there's
no Quincy tooth you'd lose your queen
and if you play Move like Queen B1
you're walking into another pin that
doesn't look very comfortable and this
is what I mean by you know trying to
wait until the right moment
well we'll see I'm sure do that uh he
seems like a man who handles his
commitment as well
we'll come back to this one and maybe go
back to the bird maybe you can go back
to the bird's eye view for a second I
saw a comment in the chat that we did we
see the position we can't see the clock
times but apparently visit already under
an hour clearly caught by surprise by
duboff
yeah I mean great choice by dubov even
if it's not so much of an objective
Advantage it is a practical one because
players fear duboff's preparation they
know how creative he is they know how
sharp the lines that he produces are and
when Magnus Carlson puts his full trust
in you to work with him and come up with
Catalan lines including yesterday's game
we don't know with 100 certainty that
that was a duboff concoction but Magnus
he was like that may have been left over
preparation and that's why he played so
quickly for the first dozen or so moves
and yeah I think vidit you know he
should be nervous he's not in the not
like this pose anymore so is that a good
thing or a bad thing if you're reading
this expression well it's a bad bad
thing for chat for sure
less meaning and he does look a little
less concerned to me but
who knows what that means we see him
there just dropping the Knight back we
can go to that in a second but I think
there's two games Robert if I'm not
mistaken that we haven't looked at in
depth yet that's kiwi my mediaov and
yesi panko karaoke
yeah we're never going to look at those
games I know people are going to be very
upset with us but we refuse uh we are
boycotting those games now we can of
course go to um those games why don't we
start with I'm not sure which one would
you wanna let's start with kirima media
of Kiri is the local hero after all I
think it's always interesting to see how
do these players bounce back after a
loss
um
of course a tough game we've talked
about it plenty so I need today with the
the white pieces and especially
interesting uh with Shakira you know
having played the way he's played the
last two days you never know uh what to
expect and the position certainly looks
interesting at first sight
yeah the black king is still in the
center which means there may be some
hope for G5 no not actually it's just a
joke because Mama jar played G4 on move
three yesterday I don't really like his
position right now uh we can go back and
see how we got here but if we just take
stock of the current situation black
often is trying to play the move C5 and
if you can make C5 work without any sort
of
issue without it backfiring then you
often have a decent position
but something about this position as it
currently sits it feels a little awkward
to me and when black tries to Castle
kingside you have to watch out for the
move E5 which opens up this bishop to
the H7 Pawn so if you're not careful
white can launch a very quick attack so
C5 is the movie one I think that it may
be in the cards for black uh though if
you do it before you Castle so let's say
I go just throw me kind of a throwaway
move Queen E2 C5 and try tape with this
Knight you do have to be really careful
because your king is still in the center
so when I play this bishop B5 check uh
your king now probably has to go to f8
because if you block with Bishop to C6
there it is yeah I was waiting for that
to happen takes and queen to B5 is
devastating now your Rook is pinned in
comes the Knight to E5 and you are
losing material so you need C5 to fully
equalize in many positions but you can't
rush that move and I think once again we
just see the importance if you're
watching this in a lot of games the
principles are being kicked a little bit
we see a lot of games that we've seen a
lot of games that are hard to understand
but I think there's a great example of
why it is so important in general to get
your king into safety as soon as
possible and Robert Maybe
can I go back to the start here because
we had a semi-slavan not opening I'm not
too familiar with but I was thinking I
didn't sophico who we are greeting if
she's watching us then some people
actually create some content on this
love here
see this is dangerous territory because
now we have to ask the question does a
niche listen to his wife's chess advice
so I don't know if you want to take that
one or if we should just pass on that
yeah it may be better better to pass
um but I believe you are correct and um
these kind of lines they're they're so
fascinating and uh you know first of all
hi sopico uh you know we want to say hi
I'm sure she is following anisha's game
whether she's watching the live
commentary you're probably better off
not watching I get it but would
definitely High just so people hope
you're doing well and you know these
these lines are fascinating because you
look at the initial setup we have the
pawn triangle here for black which means
that you're super solid and defended but
your Bishop on C8 isn't very happy and
your pawns block your pieces the Knight
of course can't go to C6 there's a pawn
there so white plays Bishop D3 and
castles very quickly and only after
a few turns at black decided to take on
C4 and then lash out with B5 because
your Bishop has no future on this
diagonal here you can't make the move E5
white has that covered so you play B5
and Bishop B7 which looks kind of funky
As you move your B Pawn all at the board
you have a backward C Pawn but you are
playing for this move C5
and the question is so after E4 and Rook
C8 we've already talked about the the
dangers of um
of keeping the king in the center so my
question is how does white fight now
that he still has a little bit of time
while the king is on the eighth how do
we fight as white against the C5 push
I really like the starting McQueeney too
and I I played it kind of on a whim but
now that I realize it works out that
move looks quite nice because the bishop
on D3 is perfectly placed aiming towards
the black king side so if you play Queen
E2 and Black's like I'm getting that
King out of the center immediately then
I believe E5 hitting the Knight Knight
goes to D5 that's the downside of
playing E5 as you hand that Knight a
nice Central Square and I'm looking for
ways to go after this King and if this
bishop were not here I might already
have the bishop takes H7 check Knight G5
and going for like a checkmating attack
immediately so Queen E4 naturally
threatens Checkmate black can stop it
with G6 maybe it's not the best that
white can do in this position but at
least your Bishop gets in you have your
pieces staring at Black's King another
option because I just said I want the G5
Square I'm wondering like I can make a
move like Knight C5 and hope that you
take it twice with your Bishop out you
will but essentially I'm hoping that you
go like this and there it is right the
evaluation goes up
here and Knight G5 check very
straightforward a brute force method of
going for a Checkmate your king is well
it's done
and the famous I believe the Greek gift
tactic which is very um useful to uh to
be familiar with for your own games if
you haven't seen this kind of motive
before look it up uh it happens quite
often in your games and always something
that that black has to look be on the
lookout for
and yeah actually it's funny because
Knight C5 was just a move to distract
you but now that I'm looking at it it
might just be a good idea for white like
your fisherman B7 is terrible because
you can't play C5 we just said and
showed why you can't take on C5 with
your bishop and so what do you actually
do here
yeah I mean I I really it's funny that
you you showed this move quite randomly
to to demonstrate the dangers in Black's
position and suddenly we turns out well
this might actually be very very good
move also look at the power of that
white Bishop pair with the bishop
looking down at age seven the other
Bishop ready to join the action any move
like H6 would always be very dangerous
we could even imagine some potential
sacrifices
um yeah with that you talked about it
earlier age six is a hook here it's a
looking quite precarious for uh for
black so yeah not so clear how does
black proceed and I love that you
highlighted this bishop on V7 which is
uh currently completely dead
um if I were black of course I would
like to to put some pressure on on C5 uh
try and get to that pond somehow I don't
know if Queen
A5 is an option or if I'm already in
trouble on the on the king side yeah
it's one of those things where you know
you need to get that pawn but if you
move your queen away from the king's uh
safety your danger levels are very high
that
I don't know I feel like this move is
risking a ton but I don't see an
immediate knockout I I you know I see
the eval bar saying White's doing great
it's one thing to know that White's
better it's nothing to prove it so I
think that Queen A5 it's not easy to
refute
and not easy to refute but at the same
time not really a move I want to make to
remove at the most powerful piece from
contributing to the defense of the the
king side so yeah I think still some
questions Here For Mama dear of uh to
answer and I'm curious to see if Anish
goes for for Queenie too or what he's
going to go for
it's all about figuring out the
assessment of those positions we were
just looking at right now because look
at that knees what do you think this
pose it looks like he's not even really
looking at the chessboard but rather uh
it looks like he's completely in his own
mind and very often this is a sign that
players are trying uh to remember things
uh going deep into the the memory vault
yeah I think he's trying to calculate
deeply and you know he's we close his
eyes because he sees the board in his
head he can visualize it and he's
looking for all sorts of tactical
sequences because he probably feels that
his position should be at least slightly
better right now but as we've been
discussing as soon as black plays C5
safely not with the king in the center
then Black's problems are a thing of the
past and he's trying to figure out okay
at this moment I know it's the time to
maximize the potential of my position
how do I do that I do like to move Queen
to E2 I was kind of throwing moves at
random and they just so happened to work
out but Anish doesn't have that luxury
because when our moves don't work out we
just take them back and find something
better if his moves don't work out well
then his Advantage is gone and now he's
kind of wasted the first move advantage
well we'll see what he comes up with we
will leave these guys for now once again
looking very relaxed there
um but let's go to to the Russian clash
between Sergey kariakin
um and I always get the colors wrong
somehow between nasty Panko and kariakin
which is the last game we haven't seen
and it's another Italian game so a
couple of them today
yeah the position right now not super
duper exciting but we can see how we got
here it wasn't a talent as you pointed
out and C3 D3 looks like the game
between dubov and Vivid and instead of
Bishop G5 which was the rarer choice
that dubo went with we see the typical
castle and H6 played so that no piece
can get to G5 and one of the mistakes
that players can make is it well my
opponent played H6 taking away G5 I'm
gonna play H3 taking away G4 and there's
one really important thing here is that
black has not castled and I'm not
suggesting that right now it's
necessarily the move that G5 that should
be played but there are positions like
this where black plays G5 G4 uses this
Pawn as a hook and then just crushes
white and in fact Vladimir krumnik did
something to that effect against Levon
oronian in the 20 it's a 2018 candidates
yeah I think it was the 2018 Kansas
where he like put his Rook on G8 played
G5 and just immediately went for an
attack and won an extremely nice game so
don't just play H3 with your hand you
need to think before you make certain
moves instead in this game we saw rookie
one castles and then H3 timing is
everything you need to make sure the
opponent's not going to benefit from
your move and that's why yeah Andre
played it now A6 A4 no B5 for you and
then A5 that's a funny move Fiona all
right A6 and then A5 how do we explain
that decision by cardiacin like so many
other moves we released we struggle to
explain I think in general
um
I find that the Italian game there have
been so many developments uh lately
um that I've I'm really struggling to to
keep up
um and and remember the different
because the Italian game is something
that I've played with both colors mostly
from the black side
um but obviously my opening preparation
was nowhere near that of those players
and with Theory moving so fast I think
that these days the Italian
opening is so so so complex there's so
many tiny nuances when do you put the
pawn to Asics when do you put it to A5
uh when do you go D5 when do you not
when do you bring the bishop back from
C5 to A7 and the same from the white
side so
um I always struggled to to understand
and also how much of it is prep how much
did the players come with come up with
over the board I I guess in this
particular case here I guess A5 is to
stop B4 Robert
yeah but it's just so weird because you
could have played A5 immediately yeah to
stop B4 so there must be something about
inducing the move A4 which is why
cardiacin
played a slow A5
so yeah let's let's continue from where
we see that the sapenco now decides to
strike in the center with uh D4 the
bishop is dropped back
and uh it's the white does the same very
often that Bishop we're going to see it
on the next move doesn't stay on this
diagonal but rather reroutes to C2 to
support the center
yeah I tend to like these positions at
least slightly from the white side which
is kind of funny because I always have
them from the black side
where white has more space the E4 Pawn
is well defended E5 similarly is well
defended but it just feels like white
has a bit more flexibility this Knight
on B1 goes to D2 where it can either go
to C4 or to F1 now in this particular
position you need to be careful about
your D4 Pawn hanging because they're one
two three pieces attacking and if you
move the Knight to D2 you block one of
your Defenders so Knight A3 to C4
becomes an option you can lead with
Bishop to E3 because Bishop E3
protects D4 but then you have to watch
out did I blunder my E4 Pawn after e
takes D4
can I take back with anything but the
bishop I'm not sure you can because
after C takes D4 here not only can you
consider Knight E4 but this Knight B4
move again is really annoying where you
attack this bishop and really just try
to go straight for this E4 Pawn so we
love playing D4 in the Italian but we
when we commit to it we have to note our
E4 Pawn becomes vulnerable and this is a
clear example of that absolutely a very
maneuvering game here between the two
Russian players which is yet to Spring
to live we'll come back here and to all
the other games of round three after a
short break during which our producer
Bigfoot is going to check in with the
Challengers and show some highlights
from yesterday so you don't want to miss
that and we will see you in just a few
foreign
[Music]
yes welcome everybody this is the
checkup with the challengers every day
we're gonna look in in the Challenger
section see if there are some
interesting games ongoing because we all
know that the winner of the Challenger
section will be competing in the master
section the year after so every day
we're gonna have a quick look and today
we have Aryan aragassi versus max
verbadan they both have half a point in
their first match this is the second
round we're gonna see like what they did
they actually have an interesting
position this is still Theory after
Knight to D7 you might think that after
the move A5 right here this night it's
kind of a bit trapped there's no way to
go to A4 C4 D5 or go back so this looks
like a fantastic move and we had to move
Bishop to A6
hitting that Rook getting this Rook to
C8 hitting this bishop the bishop the
queen on C2 and being very much of a
nuisance this is still fairy and after
taking on B6 Rook to C8 the theory is
actually go Queen to D1 because after
queen of D1 there's actually a very
interesting position a very interesting
variation that we're going to have a
look at really one
you're gonna take on F1 we're gonna
throw in a quick to B7
bond to B7 hitting this Rook making sure
that this Pawn is a little bit of a
nuisance Rook to C7
and as we take this bishop back we
actually have a very enticing with it
this is really cool Bishop takes on C2
now you cannot take here with the queen
because then you will lose this bishop
and black is actually up material
so you have to take with the King and
now the the killer move right here
Knight to E5 it doesn't look like we're
doing anything it looks like we're you
know being being chill putting up a
night of the in the center so what does
it threaten after let's say a weird move
let's say H3 we take here on C1
Queen takes
and bada bing bada boom your queen is
mine with a nice Fork there so there's
actually only one move
that we have right here it's going back
to your little cave King to G1 and after
a trades on C1 Knight D3 this queen is
looking at D4 these pieces aren't
developed at all this one's stuck behind
their own pieces and after let's say we
get a queen
bring the D4 check King to H1 Knight to
F2 and we have a repetition we can also
go in from time to time you go to H3 it
doesn't really matter I'm following the
engine line right now but this is a
repetition so this is the way black will
go on there have been games I've been
going this way but
Max was thinking he was thinking and
ultimately he decided to play the move
Rook takes H6
you actually spent an hour on this move
obviously he saw this threat he was
calculating about it he has very deep
thoughts but after Bishop takes F2
uh we'll just go for the game King takes
C2 Rook takes C2 you lose your queen on
C2 but you get a very nice pass Pawn
this is what he was calculating but
after Knight B6 the move that he
probably missed
is after a queen C8 Rook takes B6
Queen C5 check
and we are winning that Rook back and
unfortunately Max had to resign not a
few moves later because this Pawn also
fell and these moves aren't uh developed
yet so very nice gamer are in Hindi
movies Theory Max spent an hour on that
move Rook takes A6 but unfortunately it
wasn't the case uh didn't plan out the
Hat he actually tweeted about it he says
sometimes the brain doesn't function or
the head doesn't function I know someone
didn't function by him today but we hope
he pounces back he's a Dutch player I'm
a Dutch guy so if you gotta root for
your own country but Aryan with a point
and a half out of two he joins the
leaders if I'm correct and we'll be back
soon tomorrow to see which Challenger
we're going to check in
[Music]
thank you so much for producing big for
the insights into the challenges group
and and Maxwell Madden indeed with a day
off yesterday but um hopefully he will
bounce back and Robert we are going to
focus of course on our masters group and
we can just bring back the bird's eye
view which uh we both love so much and
gives us a good overview of um
what's happening throughout the playing
Hall
yeah it's fantastic we get to see from
board to board I mean the dubov game it
looks like a pawn has been gambited in
the center I see video just went Knight
takes E4 so we'll definitely have to
dive into that but before we do I see
Gary played them with A3 so he played on
the flank rather than in the center we
were talking about Queen E2 instead he
chooses A3 a fascinating decision by him
uh Fiona the game between Niels and
report we promised that it would be
exciting it's Sicilian but they're just
not moving yeah which is not such a bad
thing because it means we are more
likely to get more action as the hours
um and go by so for now where do you
want to start Robert
such a difficult question to answer look
at Von Forest against prognanda it's a
new pawn that Jordan is down he has no F
Pawn but he's trying to go for some kind
of attack let us go
um
which one do we choose Fiona should we
should we go to the video game maybe
yeah I was that was gonna be my pick so
I'm glad I'm glad we agree
um let's start with duboff
um with it and then we can maybe go to
Jordan which I agree also looking very
interesting
so shall we go back a few moves and
first things first let's look at the
clock situation with it almost down an
hour already on the clock
yeah he has been caught by surprise but
he is such a strong player that of
course he can figure things out over the
board it was this decision first by
dubov to play Bishop G5 a rare choice
but it follows it up with H6 and doesn't
play G5 plays in the other wing and then
Knight A3 so vidit takes his time he
captures doubles and isolates White's
pawns and then you know we see this move
Knight B8 by vidit he does not like the
look of this pin and he says I'm going
to reroute my knight to D7 via B8 we see
this in some Spanish positions what do
you make of this Choice by bit facing
preparation over the board and then
choosing this move Knight B8
I mean it's surprising to me and it's
even more uh surprising because after
the whole maneuver of um defending the
Knight on F6 with the other night he
then chooses to go G5 which uh I'm a bit
confused as to why didn't he go G5 why
did he want to First bring the Knight to
D7 rather than going G5 immediately
I guess dubov provoked him he said I
just have to when he when Duba went D4
here that
loosens up the E4 pawn and we've talked
about this in several games today but
the E4 Pawn is under attack can't be
captured with that Knight being pinned
and for some reason G5 not the move that
he wants to play and there might be a
sacrifice on G5 or just the simple
Bishop G3 and now the E5 Pawn is under
attack so I put in the Knight on D7 he's
protecting the 996 but also protecting
that E5 Pawn in the event that the
bishop retreats to G3 and that's what
we're seeing in the game Knight D7 Rook
B1 which honestly Fiona invites Knight
takes E4 even more because now there's a
fork on C3 in addition to attacking the
bishop on G3 I'm in duboff he really
loves giving up material
um and he really as you said has invited
actively invited with it into playing
all these moves going G5 taking the pawn
on e4 and I'm curious now to see uh what
is his follow-up because I I think you
have to do something about that pawn on
C3 not that you can't afford to to lose
another Pawn which very often do both is
not afraid of But Here There is of
course a big fork threatened
I think what's going to happen is this
the f file is going to open up so Queen
C2 attacks the Knight and defends the C3
pawn and if Vida takes on G3 F takes G3
is played you don't like the look of
this bishop this Rook staring at the F7
Pawn sacrifices are going to be
everywhere you can't Castle because
Queen G6
Pawn is pinned win H6 with check win G5
win the game it's just a forcing
sequence that leads to Checkmate so this
is really dangerous stuff here for vidit
and we see that the evaluation bar is
still hovering around the middle which
honestly is not a great sign for black
because it while that indicates you can
find accurate choices that holds
everything together you don't have that
much time and you're playing someone who
is ambitious who loves sacrificing
material and just looks so much scarier
for black that pawn to me it's not
relevant but I would much rather have
the attack
let me ask you a question about a move
which I think is going to to hurt your
soul it hurts mine as well but how bad
is uh F5 trying to hold on to that night
in the center but of course I'm aware
that I'm opening up my own King even
further
it's a brave choice so I commend you for
suggesting it because that's the best
thing that commentators can do suggest
moves even when it hurts them because
that's the thought process we have to go
through if we eliminate all moves that
look bad we'll often Overlook the right
choice and F5 it's really not out of the
question it protects the Knight on e4
which can't be kicked by a pawn and you
eliminate your right to Castle kingside
but you probably didn't want to go there
anyway so I'm I'm honestly getting
behind this move a little bit more
though I think white can just take on E5
and if the pawn takes back I'm already
looking in just a simple rookie one type
of move waiting for your knight to move
or to sacrifice my Rook for your knight
just to open up the board later the move
Rook B5 can even be played going after
this E5 pawn and this Knight on D7 can't
move because there are two pieces
attacking E5 I think it's a really
dangerous scenario here for vivid King
stuck in the center absolutely and I I
seen the chat poga is asking so is
Castle queenside the only way for black
or would it be better walking into a
fortress I think it's a great question I
was thinking I mean even on the even if
I could cancel Queen side which I'm
still quite far
removed from it doesn't look that like
the king would be very safe on on C8
either because
um remember out in the opening that it
took the night on A3 which opened the B
file for white so I wouldn't feel safe
with the King on C8 with the White Queen
being able to come into B3 to A4
um
so yeah Queen side so that's the reason
actually I think it's a great question
because that's the reason why I'm
worried for visit because I am wondering
what is he gonna do with his King
especially now that lines are going to
open uh in the center
and taking that question and putting it
on the board I mean Knight B6 seems like
a good starting point because you're
defending F7 by putting pressure on one
of White's pieces if Rook takes B6 works
then black is just in such a difficult
situation I don't think it quite works
just because your attack isn't
blistering down the f file I mean Rook
takes B6 Pawn takes B6 and you're a
little slow to get to the F7 Pawn you
can't sacrifice all your pieces then you
have nothing to checkmate with although
that the hip-hop bar is like a yo-yo
it's going up and down trying to figure
things out and if you you know you don't
sacrifice material and you try to
continue playing for the initiative
maybe in Bishop B5 check because the
pawn can't push the Knight would be
loose there I still prefer White's
position but as the question uh asks and
indicates if that King can get to C8 I
mean black will be feeling at least
quite a bit better about his chances
yeah so we'll see if Vivid aims for that
for now it is uh Daniel to play we see
him there at the board one of the we
haven't seen him yesterday we didn't see
him thinking at all I think he more or
less made the draw out of his
preparation but today I think Daniel
will be more excited yesterday it was
just uh sort of for not the first ride
of the opening but quite an uneventful
game the gaming and shock if anything
was too eventful maybe his sacrifices
there were in quite a sound but today I
think Daniel for the first time can be
quite happy with what he got out of the
opening
I definitely agree with you uh look at
this position I look at the time it's
his style to play like this and he is
thinking and that's a good thing to do
at this moment because I'm just saying
Queen C2 it attacks the Knight it
protects the pawn avoids the fork but
maybe there is a better move that makes
Black's life more difficult uh you don't
want to take rookie one out of the
question I don't love that move because
I liked my Rook on the f file awaiting
Knight takes G3 F takes G3 but rookie
one could give up an exchange to break
open the center and go for the king
these types of moves do exist they are
possible and uh I wouldn't be totally
surprised if a move like that or indeed
good but it's many options here I think
we'll see dubo go
quite a long time before moving and he's
already spent some time considering his
options and it's going to be a wild game
as this one continues to heat up very
considerate of duboff to take some time
giving us the opportunity to return to
the birds live view and see what updates
we've had I'm particularly curious about
this event for race game against
fragnananda which has changed a lot and
we see a very funny Pond Center for
black with the double isolated pawns on
the c and e file so maybe we'll go there
next but what else is catching your
Robert well now that you mentioned I
can't look at anything except for those
double isolated pawns and two sets of
them C6 C5 E6 E5 that Bishop on D6 is
terrible
oh gosh of course it's not a winning
position for Jordan but when you think
about the opening he played this is the
type of scenario he wanted where I mean
um
oh gosh my stomach hurts
yeah it feels like if we have this Pawn
Center we would like in return to be up
more than just one Pawn because in the
long run I think at the very least
Jordan is always going to be able to
pick up one of these pawns because I
think they're just simply too weak but I
don't think that's probably what's on
Jordan's mind right now I think he'll
probably be looking for more
foreign
structure really is something and it
Constructor
I hope not because people that means
people are getting it right like if
there's a name for it it means it
happens regularly
this could be a name like the same way I
don't know I feel like the bathtub on
structure that's quite a recent one
right you don't read about the bathtub
in the history books you don't uh with
the bathtub that's cozy I like that
formation it's a bit of a Phalanx there
here how could anybody like this look at
those pawns I'm trying to come up with a
name while I'm talking it's difficult to
think about you know these parallel
pawns that are doubled and isolated and
I don't know
yeah it's really it's a tough one I see
that Sam Sam Copeland is in the chat
with us he's suggesting the Space
Invaders Pawn structure
yeah it's
it's bad it's not good however the
position isn't that bad for black even
if the pawn structure is not pleasant to
look at and the reason why is it's not
easy to win any of those pawns and with
those pawns sitting where they are they
block some of White's pieces
particularly along the e-file you play
rookie one you're not actually
threatening this Pawn the bishop covers
it and black will play the move Knight
to D5 if you keep your queen on F3 and
even if you don't keep your queen on F3
Knight D5 looks like a very reasonable
choice so
I really it pains me in this position
I'm going to continue to be honest with
people but it's objectively not that
terrible for black even if practically
it's incredibly uncomfortable and white
is objectively slightly better and I
liked the goal posts uh puns oh that's
good that's a good one and someone was
asking is it not the Irish Pond Center
no the Irish the Irish ponds uh they are
also painful to look at that's when we
have triple isolated pawns I believe
that's the the Irish Pond Center but
this one really we'll go with the the
gold pose for now
um and we see Jordan there thinking uh
Jordan who I'm sure will be very eager
after yesterday's last two bounce back
with the white pieces against the bottom
seat of the tournament but pregnant he's
had a great start to his event
he has he's been very tough he's shown
good kind of metal at the board he's
just been calm and able to even in some
slightly uncomfortable positions deal
with the pressure I think if I were
Jordan as I try to actually consider
moves rather than the structure I'd
probably move my Queen off the file I'm
not sure it's entirely necessary but I
don't see the harm he's just like we're
treating my queen to E2 this Knight D5
move I know is going to happen anyway
and I'll just move my knight to E4 so
I'm not afraid of Knight to D5 because I
love the E4 Square Knights should be in
front of isolated pawns and in
particular in from a double isolated
pawns and something that's really
important that even if it undoubles
pawns I I don't know if I would take on
F4 because you don't have to but
something like this is still going to be
pleasant for white because you have this
Knight on e4 and it's a dark Square
Bishop so you have an outpost and that
Knight can never be attacked I would
prefer to have that trade of Bishop for
night if I didn't undouble those pawns
there so you know maybe start with just
a queen G4 or something a little calmer
but the point remains that a knight on
e4 is just a really beautiful piece
absolutely and
um well one thing with it and the prank
haven't come today both of them are
getting very low on time but if we
switch the camera up again I don't know
if Prague is still there another thing
they had in common is they were both
sort of dancing behind the board
although now Prague is standing still
but just a second ago we could see him
like fitted a few days ago against some
shankland if you haven't seen it head to
the to the jazz.com I think it's on the
clips YouTube uh the the two players
bobbing away and Prague is back in
backhand movement waiting for yurden to
make his next move and Jurgen actually
decides to take on F6 wow
um if I am Prague I'm taking back with
the pawn because I don't like this
Poncho I don't know if you know this
piano but I don't like this pawn shop oh
I I hadn't I hadn't quite understood
that I don't think he made that clear
enough Robert
I think G takes F6 even if it exposes
the king a little bit it makes perfect
sense because the Rook defends the pawn
you can bring your Bishop back to E7 if
it needs another Defender white will
maintain and increase pressure uh but at
the very least it gives black some hope
because Rook takes F6 it's one of these
moves you play it and you're like I'm
going to have a miserable defensive task
you just bring the queen back you put
the Knight on e4 you can trade Rooks and
the Knight is obviously much better than
the bishop even though white would be
down a pawn if you go to an end game
with just Knight against Bishop white is
the one pressing for a win and black is
just hoping to survive so that would not
be
desirable and that's why G takes F6 was
played and at least we leave the point
of formation a little bit better than
when we came here
um so we'll come back to this one uh in
a short while but for now let's go back
one more time to the bird's eye view and
see what is happening elsewhere
well finally due to play D4 we've been
anticipating a move like that for a
while dubov has not moved so I don't
know if that's a very bad sign for him
because he gave him a pawn in the center
of the board and now he's thinking after
the sacrifice when you sacrifice
material I tend to think it's you want
to follow it up quickly because it was
an intentional sacrifice so Finn what do
you make of that at least generally
speaking that dubov's the one spending
time now
yeah it's uh it's surprising but didn't
he say in his interview uh something
about he didn't maybe reset it but
something about uh yeah just sacrificed
upon and spring think later I think what
he said what dubov said is just give up
some fun and and then start playing for
tricks but uh hopefully for him he has
something more than just tricks in mind
it's hard I think Robert is an
impossible task uh to ask me what's
going on in in Daniel dubov's mind when
he makes his move his decisions and so
I'm gonna take us away from there I'm
gonna quickly talk about the Nils
Cornelius game because we had talked
about that early G4 push and that pawn
is just as simply gone has just been
snapped off
well we love a good Sicilian and a lost
Pawn means an open file let's be
optimistic let's think about the bright
side of things there's no g-pawn which
which means that soon I wouldn't play it
right now but soon The Rook is coming to
G1 and putting pressure on Black's
position and I actually really like the
way this looks for whites let's go back
to see how we got here F3 was meant by
A6 Queen D2 and then Knight to E5 so the
Knight comes to E5 and Knight C4 is a
typical idea forking the queen and the
darks were Bishop in which case white
can capture on C4 which is what happened
in the game F4
Knight went to C4 so why is the I don't
think Knight takes G4
looks that appealing in fact it will
just it looks kind of kind of like the
game
so what is it here that
black hat is it this
like I'm helping because I have the
evaluation bar it's not a move that I
would have thought about I would have
just looked at Knight takes G4 but I see
the bar hovering and it's a sacrifice
but I don't even know if after Knight
takes E4 and white gets three minor
pieces for the queen what's going on
there that's a lot to calculate and
maybe we can quickly show that because
it's not a material imbalance we see
every day so we could have gotten
something like this where white would
have the two knights and a bishop for
the queen
yeah the E5 Falls that's another pawn
and Bishop to D3 something like this I
mean black is better at least at the
moment and I don't like the long-term
prospects though for black I mean these
are some really good minor pieces that
white has and in our minds when we
calculate a position like this I
wouldn't know how to assess it and even
with the evaluation bar off to the side
I'm still not sure that I would take
black despite what it says I also think
that Bishop B4 is such a difficult move
to to find in a spot like this if we go
back to the moment where Niels played uh
F4 I think Knight C4 is a natural move
it is the reason you came to E5 in the
first place and your ninth is being
attacked so I think that Knight C4 is
just very often a move you make pretty
much instantly uh and you don't think
about oh let me just make another move
which completely ignores that my my is
attacked and it's one of the reasons you
know the time limit exists is players
don't have forever to consider their
options and we do need to fight our
instincts sometimes in chess like we
have these instincts that are
essentially shortcuts to help us make
decisions more quickly but at the same
time our insects prevent us from even
thinking about moves like Bishop B4
sometimes because our Knights under
attack we played 95 to go Knight C4
Bishop before didn't even look that
appealing because I don't really want to
take the Knight and give up all the dark
squares but here Bishop B4 with this
crazy position even if the queen moves
let's say to D3 Knight takes C3 this
type of position you think is A3 working
here what's the deal in this Dynamic but
the pull point for everyone wondering is
that this Rook on A1 is lost so after
the check you lose the rook and you
deserve down too much material so yeah I
would not have found Bishop before I'm
completely gonna be honest like Bishop
before didn't cross my mind until I saw
the evaluation bar
tank downwards and Knight C4 is logical
Knight takes G4 is a move that
steals a pawn but it actually just kind
of transposes similar position to the
game where after takes Queen takes
you're going to play Knight G4 anyway
most likely and then as Queen comes to
G3 and white has a ton of activity for
the sacrifice pawn and if we see in the
game because that's where we are
um it's actually quite similar in nature
where Black's Knight likely will take
this bishop once White Castle's Queen
side or we get this Dynamic Fiona where
way ahead in development for white uh
clear initiative but black has the pawn
you've said you like pawns extra pawns
extra material you like Bishop pairs but
I have a sense that you're gonna take
white in this position you're you know
me too well Robert It's Too Well by now
because I also do love
um as well no some attacking chess I
love pushing my F Pawn I see a king
that's still in the center I would love
to maybe play some F5 soon if I got the
opportunity just try and open up at the
black king as much as I can and it's
it's not so obvious to me what's black
going to do first of all that Bishop on
ch right now I guess let's have that is
going to have to move at some point I
don't know if black is gonna want to
touch that deep on because if the d-pawn
goes to D6 or D5 either way we can
always take on D6 either straight away
or on passo and then the line that I
really don't want that e file opening in
front of my king I don't think so I
wonder is black going to play B5
which makes sense anyway because the
white king is on C1 so we can hope to
get some counter play against that and
also and maybe we can look to to develop
the bishop on B7
all correct and all unclear I mean once
you played Bishop B7 or preemptively
I'll put my Rook on G1 and go for the
semi-open line but black is up a pawn so
if the attack doesn't come swiftly or
black is able to make a move like D6
because Bishops need and love open space
then that would be good for black but
for the time being we see a rook on a
semi-open file near where the king of
the center is this Knight can hop into
E4 the Knight on D4 is well placed as
you said F5 is an option bringing the
Rook to the G file so white has a ton of
different potential moves here and black
is solid for now but underdeveloped and
that could be an issue for black going
forward yeah I'm really curious to see
how this game develops for now I saw a
couple of requests in the chat uh asking
us to check in with Duda and Carlson
which I think is our main clash of the
day we see from the bird's eye view and
you mentioned it already that do that
has finally gone for the central push
with D4 so maybe we can take a closer
look there
for sure we left off when Bishop f8 was
played dude did choose the move Queen C2
to remind everybody the problem with D4
too early is that in this situation the
move Knight to B4 just one more reminder
that Knight takes E4 is a blunder
because of Bishop D5 this is an
important tactic in the Spanish for
everyone to learn that Bishop D5 you
lose upon E4 but you attack two pieces
at the same time instead of taking on e4
Knight to B4 is the good decision
because the E4 Pawn is now under attack
and that's why you saw the arrow Queen
B1 as a way to defend it you don't
really want to play the move E5 because
while it is an advancing move heading
towards the black king you allow black
to play Move Like Knight to D5 and now
these Knights are hopping into the game
uh the bishop is blocked it would love
to put more pressure on F7 but these
Knights are protecting one another at
the E3 Bishop doesn't exactly look great
and then this light score Bishop for
black can join the party so it's overly
committal we had jokes about it earlier
instead Queen C2 was played and only
after the Bishops were traded Dean white
played D4 and watch out because that D5
square is where that pawn wants to go
yeah so what do we do here uh as black
to to stop B5 also in general I think
one of the questions when I stream or
when I commentate that I I get a lot is
I think uh people find it very hard to
decide how to deal with tensions in the
center at which point do we want to to
exchange at which point do we want to to
keep the tension and what what would you
say
such a good question because oftentimes
in these Spanish the Roy Lopez openings
you don't really want to take on D4
because if you just look at this
optically you have given white control
of the center but you see the bar to the
left hand side of the board going down
which means that it actually has helped
Black's cause and the reason why is that
when there's a pawn three squares away
from a knight we talk about this very
often I know I talk about it all the
time people probably sticker hearing it
upon three squares away from night
dominates that night and it takes away
the B4 square and the D4 Square from
this Knight's access so by taking on D4
in this type of position then the Knight
can hop into B4 where it attacks the
queen it means that the queen is going
to have trouble keeping this Pawn E4
defended there are no tactics with a
bishop on the white squares anymore and
he's like Queen B1 you've walked into
discoveries because there's a rook on B8
so I'll move like Knight D5 now we're in
the future is going to be quite a
nuisance to deal with so I actually
would and at this point
be open to the move Pawn takes D4 but
look at this while I want two Pawns in
the center it's advantageous to have
Pawns in the center when there are many
pieces on the board because pawns
restrict pieces for the moment I'll take
with my knight because I am forcing the
action here both your pieces are under
attack the only way to save them is by
taking and now I can take with my Pawn
not allowing you to pester my queen I
have exactly what I've wanted two Pawns
in the center black only has one white
is more advanced has more space and with
more space means that the enemies pieces
are limited in scope particularly this
bishop on f8 Fiona this would be like
the ideal position from the white side
in this game yes so we'll see what
Magnus decides to do we will come back
to this game and all the others all
seven games are still on the way we're
almost two hours into the round we'll
take a short break but we'll be back
with all the action very soon
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
some interesting insights from shankland
he has had a shave I love Robert what
he's saying about Jess would be boring
if the best ones always won we saw it
here last year with a big Underdog
Victory by Jordan van fleis and well Sam
he's here to fight it out to fight for
first place as well and Robert today a
tough test with the black pieces against
Fabiano caruana and I have to give Sam
Shanklin credit he's always like up
there with the best interview he is he's
so I mean he so enthused he's always
willing to answer the questions so I
have to give him credit for that and in
this game uh well he's got his move
through the talking and he has a bit of
a tough position I mean Fabiano caruana
is obviously such a strong player but
the way I look at this position with
those double Berlin pawns on the queen
side it means that black isn't going to
get a past Pawn on that so the board
despite having a four on three Advantage
let's cut the board in half white has
four king side pawns black has three so
that's where White's advantages and
blacks doesn't have the same Advantage
because those pawns are doubled it's
hard to create a pass pawn and the king
in the center The Rook on G8 is kind of
awkwardly placed so I think at least the
moment this position is better for white
what really will tell the tale of this
game is will white be able to push those
Pawns in the king so will there be a G4
push at some Point even now I mean if we
see a trade upon here white will follow
up with F3 and we start to like the look
of all of White's pieces concentrated on
the king side that said it's a long ways
away from me I have a question big
Advantage if in this position if I put
my knight I know it doesn't like to be
on the rim but if I jump into H4
yeah and I
okay
I was hoping you wouldn't hit me
immediately
um
sorry go ahead no you go ahead I was
gonna say I think actually what you're
doing is completely reasonable because
that's if the Knight went back it would
still go to G6 so like you're going in
the same direction no matter what and I
think that I have to as white play F3
because the G4 Pawn is uh under attack
so we're getting back to familiar or
expected territory I should say
and then well you are more familiar you
said you played the Berlin uh as black
as well how how is black do you try and
uh fight against the pawn majority on
the on the king side
I wish I had the answer I wish I could
solve the Berlin I mean we see Maxine
Russia lagrav play these positions time
and time and time again uh from the
white side he believes in the Berlin and
it's because of this three on two now
previous is four or three advantage of
the king side and trying to get those
pawns mobilized and black does have some
play here this Knight needs to find
better footing maybe it will go you know
f8 to E6 at some point I just I prefer
to have the white side of these
positions
and the Robert actually when why just
when we came back from the break and we
watched the same video I saw a lot of
positive comments in the chat about how
great Sam was and his voice and I
thought oh I'm surprised turns out that
was all sarcasm because we played the
interview muted and blame Bigfoot but
we'll watch it we'll watch it again
right now and after that we'll come back
to the birds live overview
I remember coming here uh first time was
2015 I was playing the B section I had a
fantastic result I made plus five but
way you was an absolute Terminator
I played him with white in round one and
it was a draw and it was just I never
had a chance again if I had known that
he was going to go nuts maybe I would
have uh pushed a little harder
I remember at first it was chorus chess
before it was taught us deal and I
always remembered this was like the the
most important Tournament of the year
the biggest best one
Tata steel trust him and you know they
call it the Wimbledon of trust and I
think they've earned that name uh it's
just the best tour in the world
obviously you know with Magnus in the
field and I'm in the bottom half uh the
odds are against me but you know if the
best player always won chess would be a
very boring game I'm just going to play
my best and if the points come that way
they will
so I use technology for opening
preparation for sure but that's more or
less the only thing I use it for I think
I'm more scared in terms of the future
of trust of computers just processing
faster and then if they've become a
little bit stronger I worry that one day
chess can be weakly solved
luckily I still think that day is very
very far away and I think it will be
after I'm retired many many years in the
future
it was a very memorable tournament for
me both with positive and negative
attributes last time but I'm really
looking forward to playing again this
year foreign
so good to hear from Sam Shanklin again
um and if you want to find those
portrait videos they get uploaded
throughout the tournament you can find
them uh on the official YouTube channel
of the Tata steel chess tournament and
Robert we're back in the bird's eye view
we were saying during the break today is
really a hugely exciting game where does
UI go first
I just note that Fabiano was smart and
he played F3 he's trying to time his G4
break perfectly but let's stay away from
that game we were just looking at it it
will probably get interesting in the
next few moves do Bob against vidit we
see the center opening up the F5 move
that you suggested Fiona was played by
vidit so that one is definitely exciting
I mean all across these games the
grendelius report game the B5 move just
happened Anish Kiri I think that's a
game we could probably take a good look
at because we haven't tuned in a while
and it seems like he's up a pawn and he
has a promising position at this point
with Mama Jarvis King still in the
center yeah so let's go there and after
that we can check in uh which do buff
and with it so we left this off not too
long ago but the position has really
exploded into life
yeah I mean A3 was the choice that move
caught me off guard uh I wonder after B
takes A3 was he simply going to take
back or was he no I don't think that
works let's say B4 because if you take
there's some pressure down the B file
but when you do take black has A5 to
follow it up with I don't think that
black has solved all of the problems but
I was going for tactics that don't
actually work out so I'm going to take
the move back so Mama Jordan was afraid
of something and went C5 but we talked
about why C5 is a dangerous move to play
with your king in the center after
Knight takes C5 Knight takes C5 Pawn
takes E5
Bishop takes a takes B4 go ahead take
that pawn on B4 there are tactics here
and black is going to be very unhappy
about them
yeah so uh shock wise they decided not
to take the pawn on before but instead
instead drop the bishop back at two B6
and
well Anish has picked up the pawn and
the black king is still in the center do
you think this is trouble
it really looks like it and black is one
move away from castling the extra Pawn
is doubled so we see that the B pawns
there are two of them and that's where
the extra Pawn is but it's not that
powerful so I do think that Anish needs
to work relatively quickly I like the
look of the move e5s attacking this
Knight and opening up this light Square
Bishop if the Knight jumps into D5 which
is exactly where it wants to go
attacking this Pawn on B4 I'm already
looking at Knight G5 let's go let's try
to Checkmate our opponent bring our
Queen out somewhere we still have checks
along the A4 to E8 diagonal so I'm all
in on the initiative here Knight can
come to E4 into D6 as well Fiona this
looks really scary for uh chakra
I mean I would be terrified here I I
don't see how Shakira is gonna be able
canceling uh going to be able to Castle
kingside in the near future
um but if we look at the camera right
now it's on give you it was on my media
it was a second ago he still looks like
nice and relaxed but maybe those
appearances are deceiving because I
think Anish clearly in the driver's seat
we see the two players there
and I also Anish from his body language
you can tell I think that he senses
today is my chance to get my first win
here
it is there's a king in the center he
knows that he needs to push forward and
he should be confident and Mom and jarov
he does look very calm which is
surprising to me uh maybe he doesn't
think that his position is that bad he
is used to having crazy positions with
immense complications but I'm not liking
the look of that King in the center I
think foundationally black's position is
quite solid everything is defended so if
you can trade Queens for example black
is not just fine black will be better
but why wouldn't each trade Queens
there's a king in the center there's an
attack brewing and so I do think we'll
see an E5 Knight G5 type of jump from
Anish yeah and I think I would love to
be playing this from the white side
instead there is a question in the chat
from rink I never know if it's ring to
or ring Ed but uh if we go back to the
to the position we had on the board that
you showed after Knight G5 he's
wondering does the crazy move Knight E3
work
aha cutting off the Bishop from this
Knight so it's a great idea it's a nice
tactic of interposing on the diagonal
the problem is while you're attacking my
queen I will get rid of your knight
first you will take back because now my
Bishop defends the Knight and you're
thinking all right if white takes on E3
then I take on G5 a white isn't
obligated to take on E3 just yet I will
throw in Bishop B5 check I will trade
queens and then and only then will I
take your bishop and I will end up a
piece ahead so a really nice tactical
idea unfortunately from the perspective
of Mama jarv it doesn't work out in this
position because I'm removing the piece
that's attacking my knight on G5 and
just to finish off the variation let's
trade Bishops let's trade queens and
then well I have a fork on F7 but I'll
just take your bishop and B up a full
piece and once again we see that the
reason this a nice tactical idea didn't
work is again because the king is still
in the center and exposed to all these
different checks and tactics so really a
lot of problems to solve here for
tracking my media of
um oh and meanwhile Anish has actually
is kind of Bishop B5 check
wow he's
I think forcing the king to make a move
because Bishop C6 doesn't seem that
appealing from my perspective as there's
oh I think there's a
just a pin and then 95 we talked about
this earlier and
yeah that's not going to be good for
black the king and the center that's the
if Mama Jordan was castled he'd be okay
in almost all of these lines and he's
not Castle so he has to pay the price
for that yeah so Bishop C6 is just
simply not an option uh which means that
uh Shakir Mahmoud looks like he's gonna
have to move that King
f8 I mean you don't want to go to E7
that's walking into Danger on this
diagonal here so king of f8 and then if
I'm
a niche whoa
that bar is freaking out I mean
but
but 97 be a move
yeah 97 unfortunately like 95 and
everything is a problem here's a king of
fate
so at first it somehow really likes
White's position and then it comes back
down to earth like not so fast the more
depth I get the more I see that black is
doing okay here but even with like Queen
E2 now that the king is stuck in the
center Maybe
I mean this Pawn E4 is a problem though
Fiona that's the thing it's like you
have to be willing as white to probably
give up this Pawn because the look of E4
I don't believe in the queen trade I
think that black is totally fine if the
Queens come off the board so I I'm
guessing Anish is ready to sacrifice
that Pawn One the good news is you are a
pawn up even if it is a double double B
Pawn uh so yeah I think a niche uh in
good shape here but we're only on move
16 uh and each down to under 40 minutes
so at some point white will have to
speed up but yeah I believe Anish uh
definitely here in charge shall we go
Robert to the game between duboff and
with it
okay well we have a view of all seven
and I will focus our attention on the
game between dubo and F5 was played your
suggestion I don't think that Vida could
hear you but he still listened I think
if he could hear me he probably wouldn't
have gone
five it complicates matters in a way
that makes it easier for black to play
because it's harder for white to play
that sounds convoluted I know but the
thing is if you allow one side to have
all these easy moves and you're thinking
five minutes with every turn we're on
move 15. did it has 32 minutes he has 25
moves to make and 32 minutes that's not
a lot of time and this is really complex
it I think is much better for white but
the very least he's caused dubov to go
into his time and start thinking every
single move
yeah so if we go back to that moment
where F5 was played I think was one of
the first moments when duboff really
started going into the tank to both one
of the fastest players I think in this
tournament
um and he decided to take on E5 which I
guess makes sense because we talked
about this in different games today when
the opponent's king is in the center we
want to open uh as many lines as
possible against the enemy King exactly
just that and after D5 rookie one watch
out Rook takes E4 might be White's next
move if black past the turn wouldn't be
surprised to see that so how do you
avoid that Knight takes G3 but in this
position after H takes we talked about F
takes when The Rook was on F1 barreling
down the file now we want to take
towards the center and shield our King
more there's a problem F5 is hanging you
can't move your knight because E5 is
hanging in E4 doesn't actually threaten
anything because your queen and your
king here makes means that pawn is pins
it was like G4 and let's rip open
everything it's an exciting position but
more exciting for dubo than it is for a
video for sure
um yeah I think do and do both putting
on the pressure here and not easy for
for Reddit if we go back to the position
we have on the board after work he won
so we don't really want to take on G3
but
do we have uh do we have any
alternatives
we can move the knight from D7 because
then we dropped E5
um
there has to be another move somewhere
here
I'm just struggling to see it Fiona and
I think like this
that's what I was gonna say yeah I'm
getting into the twitch lingo you know
I'm trying to every day we break you
down a little more Robert that's right
my life is getting worse for it but at
least people can enjoy hearing me say
not like this
yeah
but yeah I mean we we are joking uh but
but for with it uh this is a very
serious
[Music]
um
a very serious moment here because it's
also we already on that territory where
every uh slight misstep it doesn't have
to be a big mistake but a slight misstep
here can uh immediately be game over
I mean he looks really unhappy vidit is
like trying to dig deep into his
calculations and find something that
allows him at least some comfort and
it's not going to be easy as kings in
the center he hasn't castled he's
lacking in development and I do think
one line is we just went down this path
but one thing that maybe just maybe can
keep video in this game is that making
this room Knight C5
you protect E4 another time you protect
F5 with your Bishop
I don't like the look of this position
it still is
great for dubov here but the very least
you make White's follow-ups more
difficult if you take on F5 the bishop
recaptures and you can actually see the
evaluation bar saying whoa black is
holding his own right now because E4 is
so well defended by all these pieces and
the Knight on C5 actually looks quite
nice here defended by the queen so
there's much more Harmony in Black's
position if those trades were to occur
yeah so maybe some hope here for dubuff
but uh for a visit but once again it's
the situation it's a very very thin line
uh to walk and as the time takes down a
few people in the chat were asking what
move are we on uh we're only on move 16
which means that widget still has to
make 25 moves reminder about the time
control it is one of the longest time
controls there is on the circuit well
the longest I believe 100 minutes for
the first 40 moves then an extra 50
minutes for the next 20 and finally an
extra 15 minutes after move 60 with a 30
second increment from move one and
Robert here a quick look into the
standings after two rounds
yes we have three players in the joint
lead Magnus Carlson the world champion
the interest of Judah the World Cup
champion and video Gujarati the champion
of the people's hearts so one half of
the two was the top of the leaderboard
that can all change in a moment Duda is
playing against Carlson and vidit as
we've been showing is in a tough spot
against duboff who would like to
LeapFrog him in the standings
yeah and well we're back into bird's eye
uh view things have changed a little bit
actually in the game between two of our
leaders Duda and Carlson shall we go
there and and update that briefly
let's do it uh there well things are
happening all across the boards they're
nearing that point and they're not quite
in you know near the time Patrol yet but
they're like I don't want to have two
minutes left to make 10 moves so the
action is speeding up a bit here we see
that there's some clarity in the
position there's a backward Pawn on C7
the queen on C2 is happy to be where it
is there's a rook on A4 Queen Knight all
defending this one Pawn on e4 but that's
because
Magnus put his pieces in a formation to
put maximum pressure there and Fiona I
have to say this bishop 108 looks
excellent the best piece on the board
for sure attacking a lot really has so
much room to work with but besides that
piece there really are no issues with
White's positions excuse me with Black's
position so I I can see some of the
merits in magnus's choices well talking
about that Bishop where uh would you
like that Bishop if you could put it
anywhere on the board where would you
like it to be
oh great question right here
B4 I want to get rid of this Knight
is very important unfortunately Robert
bad news that isn't going to happen
okay well uh my second choice for that
Bishop is can I put it here on H7 change
the color move like a knight for one
turn and that way I can put pressure on
the diagonal but obviously we're just
joking around but it goes to show that
improving a single piece can make all
the difference in chess and white is
slightly better here but it's a nagging
Advantage you see magnus's face he's not
happy and I'm sure you know if he does
do an interview after the game just like
we heard in the world championships like
well I didn't really like my position it
felt uncomfortable but it wasn't that
bad objectively so that's the thing
about Magnus he's the best player in the
world but one of the things he does so
well is even when he's feeling this
emotional discomfort he can ground
himself in the reality of the board the
objectivity and say I know I'm worse but
realistically it can't be that terrible
for me so let's find the good moves yeah
and I love the close-up we're seeing
here of Magnus Carson who will have as
some work to do and I agree with you
that Magnus is so good in defending
these positions but I think uh also Duda
lately has really really impressed me uh
with how he deals with the small
advantages and Duda always so calm
um so yeah I think a very interesting
battle here will Duda be able to pile up
more and more pressure against Magnus
who is clearly not looking as
comfortable as we see him looking
sometimes
you're right and you asked what I would
do with that Bishop on f8 let's talk
about some of whites pieces this Knight
on D2 I would love to get to C6 and not
just because of the fork I'm not trying
to win material uh but that's a square
that white has under his control so if I
could bring my knight to F3 to D4 to C6
that would be ideal but that's what
Max's last couple moves were about we
left off after D4
the trade happened Knight takes D4 very
important to trade off the night so then
I could go to B4 after the pawn takes
and then he went Queen E8 immediate
pressure on the E4 Pawn after D5 The
Rook dropped back to E7 and then he
brought his Rook to A4 which is why he
went D5 would just find that move right
uh bringing the Rook to the fourth rank
where it now protects the pawn the pawn
wasn't D4 it would not defend so we
understand the last few moves that have
been played here and now it's about
going forward one thing I would like to
see from Magnus is can he make this move
C6 at some point because that's his real
weakness in the position if D5 and C6
are traded off you no longer have a
backwards Pawn you're trading off
White's great Pawn on D5 that's
restricting Black's pieces and then I
think that there's no issue whatsoever
for Magnus however if C6 doesn't work
and he's unable to get it in then he's
going to be left with this problem this
eyesore on C7 and that's no fun yeah and
bracket in the chat is white Magnus
actually reached out it looked like he
was about to make a move and then sunk
back into deep thought and I think
you're absolutely right I think Magnus
has been investing some time here
because he is trying to figure out can
he make C6 work here
um well we'll have to come back to to
find out we will leave him to it for now
it looks like he's not gonna make a move
right now anyway so we're back in the
birds live view and really today such an
exciting game Jordan went for race
against pragnananda
and they are down to just the heavy
pieces Robert and do you think that the
the goal post pawns are still a big
problem for Prague
some might say the goal posts have
shifted and oh he is covering all of his
bases The Rook on F5 covers the e-pawn
The Rook on B4 trying to trade off for
that Rook on e4 so I really like how the
teenager from India is playing this game
prognanda is an excellent player but
he's inexperienced relative to the rest
of the field so I I think he's doing a
great job right now Jordan has
everything he could have asked for it's
why he played the way he did but I think
that Prague is really playing some
excellent chess he's impressing me quite
a lot in the first three games I mean I
I have to contextualize that I know we
know how great he is how much talent he
possesses but oftentimes people think oh
that person is the future and I like to
say like why not now I mean prognananda
is really really strong he can be
anybody in this field and his rating may
be only in quotes 2612 and that's much
longer lower than his colleagues his
competitors here but I mean he is so
strong and I'm really glad to see him
performing well at the start of this
event I completely agree and we talked
about it yesterday pregnant and only 16
years old which means that when the
pandemic started hitting he was only 14
so he has been deprived for a couple of
years of getting invites to to a lot of
tournaments and playing as much as he
would have liked then I wouldn't be
surprised to see him and make a big
rating jump if not here than in the near
future but playing here making his debut
in the Masters is such a great
opportunity for him and maybe just a
very quick look at the actual position
on the board Craig's last move was Rook
F5 defending the pawn on E5 and Robert
how do you think that Jordan can
continue
to pile up some pressure here to ask
some pressure some questions of pride
well you've heard as has everyone how
much I disliked the isolated pawns
particularly double isolated pawns
however they're very well defended
because you can't triple on the e-file
and just win the E5 Pawn as black will
exchange Rooks but then I started
thinking what's the consequence of the
exchange let's say queen E2 happens it's
clear I have three pieces attacking your
Pawn you don't want me to win that pawn
and so you'll take on e4 but what if I
take with my Pawn rather than my queen
and by doing that I try to put a rook on
D1 and take advantage of the only fully
open file in Rook endings and here's a
queen and Rook position I don't want to
call it quite an ending because the king
is not that safe on G8 but in this type
of position controlling the open file is
often more important than having
equal material so having a pawn deficit
but let's say this Rook I don't know
goes to F7 and I play Rook D1 and you
move your queen to E7 and I have the
open file and now I can start poking and
prodding all over the place if your
queen leaves in comes my Rook to D6 so
maybe I play Queen H5 and I just start
attacking you from all directions not a
checkmating attack but trying to
collapse your weak Pawn so that is what
I might go for if I'm Jordan I'm sure
there's something that Prague can do to
deal with it but this is the type of
position where Jordan has the ability to
transfer his Advantage he can go from uh
these terrible pawns for black to
shutting down his attack of those pawns
immediately by putting his own Pawn on
e4 in order to take advantage of an open
file I think this could be a really big
moment for Jordan yes and we see Jordan
there on the camera uh considering his
options I think I completely agree with
you he is going to continue here he has
a little bit of pressure he will look
for ways to increase that and also for
pregnant under he'll have to watch out
on the clock only 19 minutes left still
18 moves to go so that's one of the
Intriguing games we have going on but
all the others are also still underway
we will come back to them after just a
short break so don't go anywhere and
we'll see you in a moment
[Music]
we place artificial intelligence into
the center of our Innovation program so
we can innovate faster than ever before
Advanced Data analyzing techniques are
not only fun to work with but it really
helps me to work on sustainability for
example reducing dust emissions this is
a really important topic for me
we have developed the digital tools to
accurately predict the performance of
our products in the processes of our
customers
quantifying the performance of our
products is key in making our customers
and US successful
we achieved world-class process
stability by using AI to forecast and
control the outcomes of over 2 000
simultaneous reactions
we use cameras instead of ice and
computers instead of human brains so in
the near future our factories can make
their own decisions
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
and we're going to dive straight back
into the game of Fabiano caruana against
some shankland uh Robert Sam is down to
only 17 minutes but that's maybe not his
only problem
yeah this position here is an issue for
black
um trying to verify on the clock
situation I'm not sure if oh sorry no
that's no no that's uh what we see on
screen here but uh it looks like he
might have more time I'm not sure but
either way he has a problem on the board
I would say because there's a king on E8
and a rook that's happy to see it there
so when you have positions like this a
rook in line with a king you want to
think what happens if the piece is clear
out and Knight F6 check would be
Checkmate if not for this Pawn on G7
that pawn will capture that Knight by
force and e e takes F6 all of a sudden
there's an issue down the line the
Knight is pinned to the king and all the
blacks pieces are kind of awkwardly
placed here so this looks like an
opportunity for Fabiano I'm not sure if
it leads to a huge Advantage but it does
look like it shatters Black's Pawn
structure and gives Fabiano an
opportunity to all alter the position in
a way that should be favorable for him
and I think if we look at Fabiano on the
camera he senses the opportunity he has
of course seen a knight F6 and now it's
a matter of doing uh the the heart the
calculating work
so let's
um shall we have a look at it one more
time Knight F6 G takes is first
mm-hmm
and he takes back with the PIN
and once again I guess we we don't
really have any options rather than to
to step out of the file yeah you don't
want to remain in that pin and now that
I'm actually thinking about this a
little more the engine the evaluation
bar can be a bit misleading because it's
not like the evaluation is that high for
white to begin with but one of the
things that could happen is if this
bishop trades for this Knight white will
be better that is a hundred percent the
case but opposite colored Bishops even
when one side is down a pawn or has this
much more structure those types of
positions can be held it's going to be a
tough defensive task but opposite
colored Bishops hold many drawing
possibilities so I'm wondering if this
maximizes five minutes winning chances
but in some way clarifies the position
that allows Sam to feel a little more
comfortable trying to rely on this
bishop takes G5 in the future
yeah so another point of consideration
for Fabiano when looking into Knight F6
how much of an edge do I have here how
much how many winning chances will the
opposite color Bishops
um how many drawing chances will the
opposite color Bishops give them so I
think we'll leave Fabiano to it but a
very interesting uh moment here and this
character of this position might change
very shortly for now let's quickly have
another look at the bird's eye view see
what's happening
elsewhere and we see Robert actually
almost all the games are jumping into
life
I really like what we're seeing from
this round some fighting chest all
across the board we were just talking
about in Fabiano caruana's position with
the Rook on E1 the King on E8 the same
Dynamic exists in that Dubai video game
we were looking at that earlier uh it
seems like they're going down variations
we predicted vidit I doubt he's
comfortable but at least he's playing
moves that make perfect sense and Jordan
Von Forrest who did allow The Rook trade
on e4 but he took with the Rook rather
than with the pawn so I I'm not positive
if his decision
um is any worse in fact it might just be
better than taking it with a pawn E4 he
will try to press this Advantage into a
win and of course yes a Pango cardiac
and the Russian Derby that one's still
locked up nothing has altered too much
there and then Geary that game no longer
has Queens on the board Fiona so I don't
even know what game to look at as much
also very interesting is Grand Alias
against Rapport where both players have
now castled a queen side but we see the
white king looking right and we're safe
than the black one that's sort of out in
the open uh on C8 uh but yeah I don't
even know where to start I will let you
choose Robert
uh all right I'll go to the Anish game
against Mama jar of just because we see
him on screen and because there are no
longer Queens in this game so if we go
back a couple moves because Bishop B5
check the king went to f8 and
Anisha side to trade and play Bishop E3
so this is the day of doubled pawns
because black could have captured on E3
but mama jarv is too strong just to buy
into how the position looks he is
calculating Bishop E3 Pawn takes E3
looks so bad for white at first glance
and then you remember whites have a pawn
and then you see oops A7 is hanging and
then F7 is a problem and The Rook has an
open file and Black's position is really
bad so it's not just about the pawn
structures about the activity of the
pieces and that is why Mama jarov
decided to take on e4 allowing an
exchange of Bishops but that actually
protects that a pawn in the process by
turning into a beep bomb how much of a
problem is it for uh for my media of
Robert that his King is on f8 and that
work on h8 at the moment isn't playing
at all
and you brought it to my attention now
that I think about it you can actually
make it even worse for Black by stopping
one square short of expectations let's
play favorite tactics that's been the
themes throughout the tournament it is I
love these types of moves because when
someone picks up the bishop you think as
their opponent they're gonna trade and
then go Bishop C5 check and you're like
oh
um wait I don't want to take because
that gives white a pass Pawn while
undoubling the pawns but I don't want to
play King G8 because then look at this
uncastled King that Rook should be
somewhere on C8 you ask how to where I
want my pieces I would like that Rook on
see it I can't get that and so this is
not a setup you want when white is so
active so if you trade on C5 now we have
this problem on A7 this Pawn on C5 is
excellent and white is definitely for
choice so I think Bishop C5 check Fiona
you led me to find a good move
yeah Bishop C5 certainly uh looks like
an interesting option it feels like a
nice Anish has a few a few moves here he
can consider but it's an interesting one
where uh if we go back a few moves uh I
didn't expect Anish to exchange Queens
but I think it's a great example of
showing how with the active piece play
um you don't have to try and keep the
Queens on the board you can keep your
initiative even after the Queens have
left
and it also shows why connecting your
Rooks is so important even though
there's no checkmating attack uh there
could be if
um Mom and jarva had taken on E3 rather
than on e4 we talked about a rook on the
seventh Rank and then lining up to the
F7 Pawn that's very dangerous for that
black king and in the game continuation
if we do see Bishop C5 check there's
such a problem for this King and thus
this rook and you don't want to take on
C5 but you might have to because King GA
looks so bad
hasn't stopped one short uh one square
short he has instead tried it on B6 and
after a takes the Knight has jumped
forward to E5
probably also good for white I just like
that tactic it would have changed the
nature of the position a bit but look at
this we're coming A7 still F7 is weak
Rook D5 looks like a nice move with a
fork of the pieces but you know what
that does it leaves the back Rank and so
a rook will come over to A8 with check
and that would be a problem for the king
and that rook in the corner so 95 is
also a good looking idea Robert do I
have time to get my king out of this uh
age Rank and try and connect the Rook do
I have time for a move like
G6 so there is Rook a seven two pressing
a threat
yeah Rook a seven is a threat but don't
stop one square short I know stopping
one square short is what I've been
talking about but G5 because after Rook
A7 now you slide the bishop back to G6
and defend this Pawn here I I still like
White's position
um the extra Pawn
for black like if we think about the
splitting the board in half black has a
four on three Pawn majority on the from
the e for the h file white has a two on
one
on the queen side but they're double
pawns which is not great however white
is farmer active the B6 Pawn is likely
to fall and so that does give white some
promise of an outer uh pass Pawn not a
flank pawns on on the a file on a rook
pass Pawn but as an outside pass Pawn
that can be used to distract Black's
pieces yeah so Anish still
in great shape here pressing against
let's come back here a bit later uh
maybe we can check in a city overview
make sure we don't miss anything
exploding into life because it feels
like we're already at that point in the
game where something dramatic could be
happening uh somewhere
do you want to do both
and visit let's first check out bun
Forest against Prague just because
things have changed a little bit there
and we did see Mama jar play G5 by the
way but here in the game between Von
forest and prognando there is a missing
g-pawn for white but it's also a missing
F Pawn so after the sequence it moves
Queenie to Rook takes E4 great lesson
for everybody just because someone takes
your piece doesn't mean you have to
recapture Queen G4 was check the king
slid to the corner and then Rook takes
E4 played he didn't go with Pawn takes
to get the Rook the D file he said let's
keep your pawns weak and under attack
and here prognanda went F3 which the
engine really doesn't like
honestly Fiona I understand it because
when your position the foundation of it
is really poor you want to create
threats activity for your pieces but as
we see what happened in the game after
GF queen f8 queen G3 was played by
Jordan This Pawn on E5 apparently more
important than this Pawn in F3 yeah so
uh let's have a look if black were to
capture on F3
the problem is we take on E5 with check
I think black cannot play King G8
because Rook G4 check would be a problem
so uh Queen F6 so Queen G7 I guess Queen
F6
yeah but they said even if we trade
Queens this is a losing end game
material is even but this is why we hate
double and particularly double isolated
pawns they're just so easy to attack and
you have to use your more powerful
forces to defend what you would like to
do is put this Pawn on B6 right and then
your pawns are safe and sound but as
soon as I go Rook C4 I defend my pawn
and attack yours and you'll have to use
your Rook to defend so I think white has
all the time in the world can start with
King G2 bring your King close to the
center and there's no way that black is
able to keep all these pawns they're all
isolated and weak and exposed and this
is a winning technically winning
position for white the Prague cannot
take uh on F3 so instead uh what what
are the options the pawn on E5 is a hit
can we try and defend it
I I guess I mean queen F6 is an idea to
defend but the problem is now you're not
threatening F3 because you don't want to
trade Queens as we were talking about so
Queen F6 uh there might even be uh a
good weighty move or just an aggressive
let's go Checkmate your king while I'm
at it then I can play King G2 and this
Pawn structure we oh gosh
oh gosh just the theme of the day and uh
we see Prague actually
I think this is the unhappiest I've seen
him in this event as so far he has a
little bit that look and just as we zoom
in on the camera at the face goes down I
think
[Music]
um
something we've we've all been there
Robert
um I think Prague is realizing now that
his position is really very difficult
and
um his decision to open up the position
with F3 maybe not the best idea
and it's something we're praising Magnus
Carlson for is his ability to show
restraint he when he doesn't like his
position he's cramped he still is able
to just sit and wait circuit kariakin
we've been talking about his ability to
that too in previous rounds so I think
with age and with experience you get
used to being in positions that aren't
very cozy which you're just worse and
you know that you're defending for a
long time but this moment here with F3 I
completely understand why he did that
it's the type of move that I would want
to play myself but as we see after the
capture and then Queen to G3 he's not
happy because his pawns are weaker and
he can't take the pawn he's going after
and yeah unfortunately for him this is
the position where Jordan has just all
the Time in the World to start
attacking the Pawns in increasing his
Advantage improving the location of his
pieces and I think that probably not was
going down in this game yeah and Jordan
looks like he's going to make that
interesting opening Choice uh pay off
and bounce straight back after his loss
yesterday to report uh so I think back
to the bird's eye view all seven games
still in progress we're into the third
hour here
I am still terribly concerned for with
it I have to say I see that white Rook
only one and we have our first result of
the day with Anish giri and remedyarov
but not sure what happened Robert
I'm guessing there was a draw offer
breathe breathe deep breaths deep
breaths
I'm gonna breathe don't worry everyone
I'll be all right I I'm guessing there
was a draw offer and a draw accepted and
the players split the point so
well do we have moves let's see because
we left it after G5
because I need to shop for a draft are
you okay seven
those kings look like they're in front
of one another right
he offered a draw
okay Robert let's move on swiftly
I mean I have a position in front of us
it actually is a position where I think
the worst is far behind black and a
niche is actually going to be quite
annoyed with himself and it's not about
the result itself it's about when you
get good positions against such strong
opposition you want to make them suffer
not that a niche is a mean guy it's just
that you want to sort of make your
opponent grovel to try to make them work
to level up the game it didn't seem like
Mama drove how to do that he actually
had quite a lot of time when the game
ended and he was able to find G5 Bishop
G6 and that was that so I I think that
Anish is going to be quite disappointed
with how he played and I'm going to be
disappointed the draw offers are still
allowed so whenever the next tournament
happens and organizers are getting
together
I don't need to say it so my time do I
ban the draw offer please and thank you
I'm sure they will hear you eventually
Robert
um okay for now well we're gonna move on
uh from here but yeah certainly a slight
disappointment for Anish let's go to to
do buff and visit
where Vivid is trying to hold things uh
together the king is still dangerously
uh in the center of the board Robert
let's quickly catch up with uh with what
we missed here
okay well the bishop was captured on G3
Pawn takes back E4 so we actually had
looked at this exact position and here
instead of taking on F5 Dubois decides
to put his Knight on D4 and the reason
he does this had vidit taken on G4 he
did not do this you see that there's a
problem with his E4 Pawn being loose
here so and the evaluation bar going up
and for good reason a move like Bishop
D5 just trying to win this Pawn the king
is in the center the Queen's in front of
it b7's under attack you don't want any
part of that position so vidit smartly
play the move rook f8 and now if your G
takes F5 he will for sure take back with
his Bishop here
Fiona for the moment he's holding
everything together
for the moment being the key the key
word uh I
I still think the position looks
terrifying but it has taken with the
bishop of course to keep an eye on the
pawn on e4 but we need to solve that
problem with the King on the eight I
think it brings us back to what we were
talking about very early on in the game
there was the question in the chat kind
of like king castle uh Queen side I
think that question will become relevant
again very soon how how safe is the King
on C8 my feeling is it doesn't look
super safe but I'd rather be pretty much
anywhere than on the 8 right now
yeah no you don't want to stay in the
center now I'm looking at tactics right
now I'm not sure if they work
um
I'm getting excited okay it's not my
game not my pieces but there's one
tactic I feel like we absolutely have to
dive into and it's the move Rook takes
B7 so there is no we're inside Castle in
here and it works it works the the
evaluation bar is oh okay
okay a little bit but the point of this
sacrifice is that if you take on B7 your
king is still in the center here and
very unhappy I am going not to take on
F5 because if I take on F5 and go Rook
takes E4 you block the pin with rookie
five and now I'm just down a rook and
I'm the one who's unhappy instead I will
toss in this move Bishop D5 check if you
go King to d8 I have Knight C6 with a
nasty Fork if you bring your Bishop back
then I take on e4 and you're pinned down
the center here right Bishop B7 Rook
takes E4 thank you very much you lose
your queen and your king is being hunted
so that leaves you with the one move
King F7 and after King F7 your Rook no
longer protects the bishop thank you for
your peace I'm happy to be down in
exchange if King will never be saved H6
under attack E4 falling the bishop on
the light squares I think you know how I
feel about this position Fiona and I
really like it for white
absolutely yeah so with it uh in big
danger here
um and Rook B7 I'm in dubov uh dubov is
thinking right now and do you think he
will he will capture on B7
with it is staring into our souls on the
camera
dubo for sure is going to see Rook takes
B7 he is a tactical wizard he plays
these openings where he sacrifices
material he has no issue giving up big
pieces for tiny pawns but where there's
a will there's a way and he is going to
try and break down vidis defenses and
Rook takes B7 is just the start is
stupid currently at the board I'd be
very curious to see uh what he is
looking like can we see if he's smelling
blood is he at the board let's find out
with the photographer Leonard oh it's in
the playing Hall they're trying to
capture some of the best moments of
today
uh and yeah duboff
Rook B7
could put video into really big trouble
especially with 12 minutes uh on the
clock
there he is Robert what do you make of
the visuals we get on Daniel
no he's gonna play rotating B7 because
castle and queen side is what did it
wants it's the only way he'll feel
remotely safe and if you take that pawn
away there's no chance for that King to
Castle and it's not the end of the game
right vidit will fight on that will just
turn the material back to being balanced
but it just looks so fun to play for
white and so miserable to play From
vida's perspective I mean you just are
going to be attacked and attacked and
attacked and if you can defend perfectly
there's a reason why Vita is a super
Grand Master one of the best best
players in the world but even the best
players in the world they fall victim to
pressure to attacks like this so Rook
takes B7 I think would be just a kind of
a knockout yeah and Robert I think we're
gonna go on a very short break but maybe
we can keep a Dube of as well as the
smaller void on on screen as so we don't
miss that moment and then we'll be back
uh with all the action here as we
approach the first time control and so
we'll see you very soon foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back and Robert Rook takes B7
has just appeared on the board
um I don't want to say I told you so but
I told everybody that Rook takes B7 and
dubov he is going to find that move I'm
more curious about how vid it will react
because he hasn't played a move yet and
he's quite in time trouble I'm very
worried about him his King's in the
center it's only move 21 this looks like
it's gone do Bob's way it's not business
day yeah I I mean although we see the
bar only saying plus 0.6 I think
to defend this you need to play
absolutely uh Flawless defensive moves
you need to find every single best move
in the position and that's going to be
tough for any human being but to do it
with seven minutes for 20 moves I think
is very close to Mission Impossible I
don't even know what move black should
play here we have the evaluation bar of
the starter screen I don't know what
move even looks acceptable Knight takes
B7 we were looking at and we know how
good that is for white the black king is
going to be in big trouble
you can legally Castle queenside I don't
think you should do that but just to
point out that you can still Castle this
way you'll just see the eval bar go yep
exactly do you agree with me Robert that
I think it is one of the rules in chess
that most player people are confused
about I've seen some quite strong
players not being certain if they can
Castle Queen side if the B file is is
attacked they only know it when they see
those tactics where the solution is the
castle Queen side with a rook on B7 or
on B2 so yeah I think that it is you
know it's so uncommon for it to happen
but you can still Castle Queen side
which shouldn't happen right now but is
important to keep in mind maybe there is
a position where vidit can hold off
dubov's attack for a little bit and then
Castle Queen side but I mean this looks
tragic for the king honey and you look
at its expression here Fiona from a
practical point of view I I think he
believes he's just dead lost
yeah it's always tough to to have the
camera on the players also pregnant and
early it looks actually today that it's
going to be a tough day for the two
Indian players in the field yesterday we
saw two Dutch participants lose I think
today
um both with it and pregnant in um in
big trouble end yeah I think one of the
problems here is as you pointed out it's
so hard to come up with a move at all
that keeps you in the game and these are
the moments where it feels like suddenly
time is passing twice as fast as it
usually does you only have five minutes
and the minutes just I take down at the
speed of light
that's right and I mean honestly no
matter how much time did it has I don't
really care I'm looking in this position
and I'm seeing that his King's in the
center he doesn't look very happy so uh
you know he just is facing a really
strong opponent who is particularly
creative on this day yeah and I saw a
comment in the chat that dubov is
creating another Symphony I mean he is
really a player you never know what
you're gonna get the first day he was
very lucky to get away with the draw
after getting a little bit maybe too
creative against my mediaov but today
again some some unusual
moves starting with Bishop G5 which is
quite rare in the Italian opening and
then this move Knight A3 which fitted
decided to capture and then Daniel got
exactly what he wanted some attacking
possibilities and he never let visit off
the hook
yeah this is uh I want to know what move
that it will play in this position if he
takes we're talking about those lines
earlier Bishop B5 checks such a powerful
move with the bishop under attack the E4
Pawn the pin along the E file this is
really really bad I'm seeing in the chat
a few people are writing that Rook F6 is
the only uh move here
so maybe we can take another look at
that and we see the close-up of its
clock
but he doesn't actually have no he's 20
something minutes so there's 20 minutes
removed from his clock so
um yeah that's not good no okay so with
it that's some good news at least for
all the Vivid fans as we mentioned it's
still a very difficult uh situation but
having 21 minutes rather than three is
at least something
yep so thank you for informing us that
if it does have time to calculate I
still don't know if he has enough
because you could give an hour to a
player and the wife's position looks so
promising but we'll see what happens
from here since maybe a few player a few
viewers have joined us since the break I
see there's the question what happens if
Avid captures The Rook so maybe we can
just show those lines uh one more time
okay uh let's do that so Rook takes B7
was the last move played there was a
pawn there and the point of this tactic
is the king is in the center and in
trouble so if you take the Rook on B7
Bishop B5 check
the king can move only it's two legal
squares King d8 runs into a knight C6
forking a king on d8 and the Queen on E7
the king coming to F7
won't fall victim to a night Fork but it
will allow white to capture this bishop
on F5 because the king is in the rook's
path so white goes down and you're not
really down anything but sacrifice is an
exchange a rook for a minor piece the
king is in trouble uh the bishop C4
check will be an option this Pawn on H6
is hanging if you play a move like Queen
E6 trying to guard everything the Knight
simply moves back now the Queen's under
attack I'm trying to open up this
diagonal E4 is falling I think you get
by my tone that Black's position is no
fun
absolutely so taking is not an option
we'll see what fitted comes up with for
now let's go back to the bird's eye view
and see what's been happening elsewhere
sounds good well we have all six
remaining games on screen here the
probably not in the game I mean Jordan
is now in an end game those really
unappealing let's put it that way pawns
for prognanda are on the board so this
should be Jordan's game a nice bounce
back game for him and all the other
games it looks like are about level well
the dude above game I don't care what
the engine says it's anything but level
and then the grandula scheme that looks
like it's starting to turn in uh reports
favor maybe we can go there we haven't
checked in with randelius and report in
quite a while and a very exciting
position on the board
sure let's do that so we have this
position here where
um Black's Queen is on A4 which is not a
square you see it on every day but
White's pieces are a little bit stuck I
mean there's pressure on e4 here there's
a great Rook on C8 going down to the C2
square and
this doesn't look very comfortable for
Niels I think his hopes of an attack
I don't think they're coming to fruition
Fiona should we I know we've missed
quite a few moves do you want to go back
to where we left off or just back a few
moves let's do it so we saw uh here Rook
G1 was played to attack the Knight the
Knight swaps for the bishop B5 you
suggested the idea and it was a
necessity from Black's perspective and
here King B1 was played it's the kind of
movie you play because you don't like
your King close to the center and you
protect this Pawn but I'm starting to
wonder if this is where Neil's lost the
thread because he needs an initiative he
can't just make Quiet Moves because then
Block's extra Pawn will make itself felt
and by playing King B1 we saw that
report castled and now Knight to E4 but
that looks like the culprit so I see the
bar going down so at this moment there
was a better option for Nils which is
strange because Knight E4 looks uh so
attractive a move at First Sight jumping
the Knight into that Outpost and trying
to control some of the the dark squares
but let's see what could be
um
what could be a better better idea for
white here
well the dark squares and I mean 94
looks so good
Maybe This Night move to open up these
dark squares and then open up the
default threatening to jump into a five
trying to get rid of that strong Bishop
on B7 and as well opening the D file as
you just out
even a move like that like I feel like
it makes sense
um but you mentioned how black at some
point wants to make a d-pawn move if you
can get away with it I'm wondering if
you can in this position because if I
play say D5 and you take on passant then
I'm able to take with my bishop and
there you see the eval bar is saying
okay I'm feeling this a little bit more
for black my Bishop is out I'm happy
about that so I could see why
Niels would not want to play this move
Knight to B3 because you are retreating
and then you allow D5 but for some
reason white is able to press from here
but Queen A7 it looks nice but this
black queen can always drop back to C7
yeah so let's have a look what went
wrong after Knight E4 which looks like
such a natural move Richard played King
B8 which is always a move I think you
want to make as black get the king out
of trouble and also prepare for The Rook
to join the game via C8 which it does
and now
Nails activating The Rook which wasn't
doing much any longer on the G file uh
doubling on the D file putting some
pressure already on that pawn on D7
another finally developing the last
piece Bishop E7 played by the Richard
report and that's the drawback Fiona of
Rook to D1 is that the Rook on G1 kept
the bishop at Bay because G7 would fall
and so I think this movie see that's
really where the evaluation bar goes in
Black's favor because after this move
Rook C3 the queen went to A4 and now
there's a rook trade being offered
trades help decide it's ahead material
generally speaking and black is up a
pawn and so Niels would Rook back to D3
so Black's pieces have improved while
White's pieces have just shuffled
yeah so the last few moves have really
not gone Niels grendelius's way and now
the question is uh we see the bar is
dropping into the the white Camp so what
is the continuation uh for black
I always wonder as well black has the
bishop pair white has the night pair is
there ever any case in which you want to
to give up at any concrete reasons if
you take only four then suddenly uh
White has to recapture with the queen
and that Queen is pinned to the Knight
can we can we take advantage of that
that pin in any way
uh you spotted it and I love how you
hand it to me on a silver platter the
night is pinned so you can just play
Rook takes C2 and unfortunately for why
B3 it disconnects the queen from The
Rook but it also connects it in a
different way if Queen takes A2
Checkmate so Rook takes C2 would be a
free Pawn there and that's you can't
afford to give up that pawn if your
white your king is now in grave danger
and black would just be crushing but
this is the first line right
black can currently take on e4
I think he will which uh which looks
crushing and it looks like Richard
reported as well on on the way to get a
second uh win here so we'll keep an eye
on that he still has plenty of time on
the clock but uh Bishop takes the E4
followed by Rook C2 is a forest line and
uh well we'll we'll see if Richard goes
for it but it looks like this might just
be winning for now let's check back in
with the bird's eye view maybe it's time
to to take another quick look at our
world champion Magnus Carlson who is
fighting in a slightly inferior position
against Duda last time we checked in
there
sure
um it looks like things have changed
quite a lot in this game between Duda
and Magnus so pawns have been traded
it's a new State of Affairs here where
White's D5 Pawn is
potentially vulnerable it's isolated but
white Black's King isn't exactly
thrilled where it is because you gave up
one of your most important pawns the
golden Pawn we call that F Pawn so as we
go back a few moves you see how we got
here it was this Choice by Magnus Rook
B2 the queen is needed to defend the
Rook here because the black Queen's
attacking so he went Rook B to a
distraction tactic and this trade Fiona
while you know it's a rook for a rook we
could see that White's pieces are the
ones that benefited most from that trade
yeah
absolutely and we still I mean one of
the first thing I'm seeing when when I
look at this position is the bishop on
f8 which we talked about last time we
came here that Bishop then not doing
anything uh still standing passively on
f8 and I think the question is is this
passive defense going to hold four
magnets we see a young question of
trying to take now the C file and F5 a
very committed decision by the world
champion
I I I like it I like the spirit of it he
says if I just sit and do nothing I'm
gonna be worse forever and we were
talking about when to show restraint and
when to lash out I don't think this is a
bad moment to do so Pawn takes F5 would
be a huge blunder because Knight F4 and
then Knight E2 is a monster Fork of all
of uh White's pieces that would not be
good somehow it's not completely losing
but it's obviously bad for white
um but that's why uh yes exactly so
that's why G3 was uh played and after
Pawn takes Knight takes Queen back to E8
which is extremely important defending
this Knight on G6 because there were
discoveries Knight F6 check in
particular to open up the diagonal and
get this Knight so Queenie a played
attacking the Knight on e4 protecting
the Knight on G6 and honestly the bishop
1 f8 isn't the happiest piece but it's
getting the job done defending Black's
King C7 is a weakness for The Rook on E7
covers it while being aggressive on the
e-file so maybe this looks promising for
white but in reality black is just doing
okay and I really like that liberating
shot by Magnus F5 which is a move I
don't know if Duda had uh anticipated it
I think it's a move that's very easy to
miss when you're white here you don't
expect black to move one of the Pawns in
front of his King especially not one
that opens up that diagonal upon that's
at first sight undefended so a nice shot
I think by by Magnus Carlsen just the
shot that he needed it would seem and
then we get to this position where Duda
is back on the clock but I think Magnus
is probably feeling much more
comfortable with the current position
than he was before and now that he was
able to break that pawn chain down
yeah so still
um maybe a small Edge for Duda but
plenty more work but a game where I
think uh Duda will still continue to
press Magnus is not completely safe just
yet and we see the Polish the Polish
fighter there on the on the camera let's
come back here in a short while
go back see maybe if fitted has made a
move let's have a quick look at the the
bird's eye view and with it actually
found Rook uh Rook F6 so kudos to him
wow
I mean that I mean vertex B7 was very
impressive by Duval and just the way
he's been playing has been great but
Rook F6 I mean that is
what a move and it might be the only
move it's just such a hard thing to do
it's like a rook lift you still need
your Rook to protect this bishop
but something about this Rook being on
F6 it does help out because now Knight
takes B7 as a threat remember the
problem everyone was that after Knight
B7 check on B5 King F7 The Rook doesn't
defend the bishop but if that Rook had
been on F6 to start with this tactic
never works out the king could have even
slid to f8 but has the F7 score with the
Rook protecting so Rook F6 is a
brilliant move by vidit protecting the
bishop and now really attacking the rook
and of course in typical do both style
he says please have my Rook my queen
will venture into the to the game over
here your king is still unsafe this has
been an awesome battle between two
fantastic players Run the game Robert if
it were you would you dare taking the
Rook on B7
so part of this question is how much I
trust dubov and it's important when
you're sitting at the board not to be
gushing over how strong your opponent is
you need to be skeptical every single
turn that while it may look like a good
move it may not be so let's put on our
calculation caps and I'll try to do this
a bit in our head I know it's going to
be difficult for our viewers but this is
what Vida is doing right now so Knight
takes B7 that is taking a rook at for a
night so the first question is should
duboff take back on B7 right away or
should he throw in the move Knight takes
F5 because that hits the queen on E7 the
Knight on B7 will still be under attack
and I can take it next move so these are
the things the players are thinking
about or is the queen just gonna take on
B7 hitting the rook in the corner still
putting pressure on this E4 Pawn there
is a lot to take in here and that's why
both players have been spending some
time but Fiona duboff continues to play
more quickly and even more so than the
position on the board his time advantage
which could play the role of being the
winning idea yes and we see that the
clocks have now been updated I think we
are looking at the correct clock times
we can see the 12 on with its clock and
the two in front of duboff's time at 12
minutes to go we're only on move 22 so
will it still has to make 19 moves 19
moves Robert in this position is a hell
of a lot of moves uh only after that
will he get an extra 50 minutes but
that's not where his focus is right now
I think the focus is to survive this
position until move 40
and it is just so scary I mean
of course you kind of feel like you have
to consider taking the rook and maybe it
is the best move but it's so scary
there's so many things to consider if
you don't take the Rook then what else
do you do no you have to I think you
have to and you're the point you're
making Fiona black has to be brave take
a deep breath in and take that Rook
take the work think later yeah and and I
think the lines will actually transpose
to one another so if Knight takes B7 I
know I'm making people do this and it's
a bit difficult I'll put on the board in
a second and once we trade here and the
queen lands on B7 The Rook will have to
come to d8 because it's under attack and
this Pawn is falling but because the
Rook is on F5 at that moment it'll come
to E5 so I'll put that all on the board
now that I drew a bunch of arrows we get
this situation where the Rook is under
attack let's move it here Rook takes E4
it's important to note the King has Luft
so there's no Checkmate on the back Rank
and after Rook E5 like oh rookie five
apparently somehow doesn't work because
Queen C6 check and this king is in
trouble all these pawns are hanging so
if you don't have Brooke here I oh my
gosh do you throw in this check not just
because you like giving checks but
because it frees up the d8 square for
the king that's Madness like this check
here and now King d8 so there's no
captures on H6
like that's a thing right with the
evaluation bar when you know you're okay
and then once we make a draw after Queen
A8 or what sorry maybe Queen eight I
mean I'm looking at Bishop
threatening Checkmate look this is so oh
my goodness okay look at this I just saw
this in my head Bishop B5 you're
threatening Checkmate right
if Queen D6 Queen E8 followed by Rook
takes E8 would be Checkmate but after
Queen E8 Rook takes E8 is check oh to
the king of H2 because Rook takes E8 is
Checkmate thanks to the bishop on B5 but
that you can't do it it's not letting me
because the king is in check that is how
games are saved this is an unbelievable
position
absolutely incredible stuff
and prove it it has 10 minutes on the
clock to figure out that he has taken
the Rook on B7 and so maybe we'll see
some of these lines unfold that's
absolutely unbelievable I saw someone in
the chat tell me which the 10 minutes he
is going to get with it well he will
still get 10 additional minutes for
minutes from the increment that is
absolutely true but that means that
visit has 20 minutes on the clock
basically for the remaining 90 moves
Robert that's an average of one minute
per move which isn't a lot for this
position I'm just in disbelief I mean if
we just go down there this variation one
more time and it's not forced right it's
not like Knight takes F5 has to be
played but from a distance it's so
difficult to see that Rook D1 check is
the saving idea but it makes perfect
sense because as we saw Queen C6 check
you can't block with the queen this Rook
is gone if you go Rook to D7 here Queen
G6 check still is the problem and if a
king d8 queen G8 check look at this
issue Queen E8 would force a trade of
Queens but if you take on E8 The Rook
comes back you're safe but the queen is
protected not there there on G8 the
bishop protector let me take your Rook
first your queen can't take because
there's a pin so white would end up a
piece of head oh this is such a
beautiful beautiful game full of Rich
tactics Fiona it may end in a draw but
this is why I say draws aren't the
problem I don't care about the result I
love the way this game is being played
if vidit holds he's a hero if this game
is a draw it still was a brilliant fight
but between two brilliant players I mean
I think this has to be the most exciting
game we've seen so far I know yesterday
we had some early G4 but the lines we
have seen here sometimes and I think a
lot of people who just gloss over the
game afterwards they miss all of these
beautiful tactical lines I think this
discovery check has got to be one of my
favorites and
yeah just simply stunning stuff here in
this game
I think we have to show it again Knight
takes F5 Rook takes F5 Rook takes E4
Rook D1 check needed to clear the square
for the king king goes out rookie five
only decision to be made because there's
a pin you don't want to lose your queen
so rookie five Queen is there another
check Queen ah check you will not play
Rook d8 I don't think because then your
king doesn't have an escape so after
Queen AA check the King has to go to D7
and then you're Fielding checks like
Bishop B5 check the king is still
running up the board King E6 I think is
King D6 there's Queen to C6 check made
so the king runs to E6 and after a move
like rookie five the king steps in the
center you win King of the Hill I don't
really know why this position is just
equal it still is completely wild to me
even Queen C8 check here where's that
King going is it going back this way is
it going here no I don't think King F6
Queen h8 check look oh my gosh I mean I
guess it's still equal because King F5
because of course this position is equal
right Fiona this is a dead draw no
questions asked oh my goodness oh my God
I mean this game it's the gift that
keeps on giving it's never we think
we're getting to the end of some crazy
lines and there's always more and the
players have so little time to figure
everything out I mean once again we are
seeing these lines here we are seeing
the zero zeros but the players imagine
having to figure out all these lines in
your head over the board you are not
allowed to put them on the board and
figure it out that way
I would you know what I don't think this
game is gonna drug end in a draw what do
you think Robert
I could see everyone blundering like I
mean it's not gonna blunder at this
point it's just such a complex position
and if a mistake happens it's not like
oh wait your queen was under attack you
left it there come on do better this is
so difficult to calculate even with the
eval bar off the side right the engine
says zeros it's an equal position but
it's not equal in terms of just being
rook and pawn against rook and pawn
let's make a draw shake hands this is so
difficult to see all through these
variations and do what was he's looking
he doesn't look pleased he actually just
glance at bit it and that was probably a
glance of did it well done I don't see a
way to break down your defenses here I
was just gonna say absolutely I mean
kudos to to visit and maybe I'm gonna
retract what the my what I just said a
second ago I do actually think that that
it has great chances of saving this game
the way he's defended so far has been
really impressive you get hit all right
Rook takes B7 you have to collect
yourself maybe you saw it coming maybe
you didn't you realize you cannot take
the work then you have to find what
according to our chat was the only move
Rook F6 ignoring The Rook on B7 but
trying to defend against all the
different threats that white has then
where it goes Rook V1 says take my Rook
if anyway if you don't take it I'm gonna
Crush you so if it goes ahead takes on
B7 then finds rook d8 and now well
Robert are we going actually to go down
these crazy lines
I think we are and I think perhaps do
Bob when he saw this position in his
head when he went Queen to B1 he thought
that this position might be winning and
now he's looking like oh wait a second
there's this Rook D1 check and that's
not to be critical of duboff's
calculation ability it is extremely
difficult and let's go back a few moves
and to show exactly why this is so
difficult there was a knight on D4 so
even if your Rook gets the d8 there's a
piece in the way there's a queen on B1
there's a rook on E1 so seeing that the
saving move is Rook to D1 with check
like think about that that seems
ridiculous and these players are
superstars they can work through all of
the most complex positions but it just
there's something there's a block there
you don't see it coming and now that we
get here we have Rook takes E4 on the
board the only move available is Rook D1
check so that part will be easy for a
video to see because he's gotten this
far Rook D1 check is the you need to
vacate the d8 square for The King The
King may still go on a journey it will
be a wild ride but Rook D1 is a
necessity right here right now what a
game and what a defense by visit really
incredible stuff we see world champion
Magnus Carlson uh his attention has also
been caught by the game standing there
keep it thing from behind with its
shoulder before returning to his own uh
game so yeah Rook D1 is the only move
here but I agree with you Robert I think
but it has found everything until here
and he will figure out he needs to free
up that square for the for his King
and did it thinking here and I'm
doubting that he's thinking about this
move so much as the follow-up sequence
because Rook D1 check that move will be
played I mean and there it is there it
is you know Rook D1 check but I actually
when I was quickly initially going
through the moves I was like oh rookie
five and then we saw the engine go up
and the players they're not just making
moves off handly they need to think and
so Rook D1 check is just step one of the
crazy positions we're about to see King
H2 is forced Rook E5 is forced if the
queen goes to a check King D7 is forced
after Bishop B5 check King E6 is force
you get the picture I'm just so excited
by this game because we don't get to see
this kind of tactical melee all the time
sometimes positions are locked up we get
Berlin end games but these players are
holding nothing back and again if this
game ends in the draw I am okay with it
I know people think of this point that
I'm against to draw I'm against the draw
offer in positions that have life in
them this game is I mean one of my
favorite games I've ever come to them I
mean it's so so exciting I think maybe a
draw would even be the fair result of
this game with Daniel playing such
flamboyant attacking chance but with it
defending perfectly uh until now uh
there's a question actually
um from our producer he's asking what
about Bishop F1 here
well I don't like taking my pieces out
of the attack but not that this is
necessarily a bad move but you're
retreating so Rook E5 now my king can
escape to the uh F7 Square because your
Bishop is no longer covering the
diagonal so I do think that this still
holds some serious attacking chances uh
from White's perspective but I don't
think black is so concerned about
getting checkmated so it you can tell by
the Eva bar it's not that bad for white
a black is slightly better but I just
don't like walking into a pin if I don't
need to and dubov came to the same
conclusion went King H2 Vivid played
Rook E5 and now while duboff has a few
options here uh most of them will chase
out the black king that will go on the
run but it looks like uh it looks like
the black king is always gonna find a
safe Square according to the engines
Robert what we are going to do we're
going to go on the final quick break
before for the first time controller
will leave this board for you guys to
follow it during the break and we'll be
back in just a few minutes just a few
minutes to calm down gather our thoughts
and we'll be back with this honor of the
game
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome back to an explosive
third round here at the Tata steel chess
tournament Robert we are looking at the
bird's eye view and uh although some
pieces have come off we still have some
absolutely fascinating games left
we most certainly do and I've been
scolded by our producer that I can't
just stay and talk about do buffers
video forever even though I want to it
has been a fantastic struggle between
two great players but we haven't given
much attention to yessa panko versus
cardiacin and that position actually is
very very interesting to me where
Black's Queen that's karyakan's Queen is
all the way on the rim over there and
white has this extra Pawn if we cut the
board in half from the e to the H file
so I think that White's position is
better yessa panko has his Rooks on the
Central files here he's got the extra
Pawn as mentioned from the e to the H
file that can even go up to E5 if
Black's not careful but you can't rush
that decision because E5 immediately
immediately allows excuse me Knight D5
and that's something we've talked about
in several games today right like this
E5 immediately the Knight comes to D5 so
as soon as a pawn leaves the opponent
will try to take advantage of that
square so instead of that E5 which
indeed looks tempting at First Sight but
seems premature Andrei went Knight F3
hitting the black queen which instantly
went to G3 well it went there instantly
because it didn't have much too much of
a choice
no it did not and the queen is actually
very annoying here because Bishop takes
H3 becomes a threat the F4 Pawn is in
some danger so I expect the move Knight
E5 to be there he goes and there he goes
it is a queen trade by force and after
the queen trade in here everything is
happening now once this queen trade
happens
we see a dynamic where this Knight on E5
is Happy The Rook on D1 can maybe land
on D6 the C6 Pawn is a bit of a Target
black should be okay with best play
Maybe Rook E7 or something like that is
required but it's just uncomfortable to
have this position from kariakin's point
of view because his pawns are weaker and
even though he's holding everything
together for the moment it could
collapse really with one inaccuracy as
you mentioned the other day though if
there is one man who's excellent oh and
sorry but we've had a result the clash
between the answers of Duda and Magnus
Carlson has ended in a draw and maybe we
can go there we'll watch the player uh
have the brief pro-game analysis and
maybe we can quickly go through the
final moves there
we saw a trade of Rooks and then a queen
trade was offered by Duda and Magnus
said no because if that Knight comes to
B5 you lose C7 so if it's Queen C8 and
it's a move we talked about a long time
ago Fiona and it was the final move that
was necessary from Magnus because that's
the move that led him to a draw C6 D
takes draw agreed I'm actually okay with
this one everybody because after Queen
takes C6 the Queens come off I can see
very clearly and also explain quite
easily why this game is completely even
it's a three on two majority from the
f2h files black has this d-pawn it's a
past Pawn if you will but it's not going
anywhere so both Kings will come towards
the center there's no way to make
progress the draw agreed I'm okay I'm
fine with it
that's great to hear and I was actually
laughing because I don't know if you
watched Magnus pull on his mask but
we're two years into a pandemic and
there's some excellent photos out there
one is by Eric Rosen from the World Cup
and another by Leonard Oates I think
from the world rapid and Blitz with
Magnus having the mask all over his face
and I don't know if anyone caught it but
once again like it seems like he puts it
all over the face and then pulls it down
and so an interesting an interesting
handling of that situation but back to
uh yesi Panko and kariakin
uh just for one final time to have a
quick look at that position where indeed
uh yes sir panko did play Knight E5 and
the Queens came off on E3
chess is frustrating because in moments
like this it looks like white is just so
much better every single piece more or
less looks better for white and yet the
uh engines like uh yeah half a pawn
better that's it that's all you get I
think from a practical point of view the
position is very promising for yesapanko
but kariakin as you were just mentioning
he really of anyone on this planet if I
want somebody to defend this position
he's very high up there and he did great
I mean a couple of days ago against
Fabiano caruana he was on the back foot
and did a tremendous job of that it is
not a fun position it is especially not
a fun position with only a six minutes
on the clock but he is the man for the
task so we'll come back here in a bit
for now let's go back to the bird's eye
view we have five games still going I
saw someone in the chat say report is
winning and oh my God look at that
evaluation bar it is the most leaning
bar we have so let's go there because I
think that game is about to be over
yeah there could be a handshake any
second in this one and the reason why is
the last move played by report it's
nothing spectacular he moved his Rook
from one side of the board to the other
and now he's threatening a Checkmate so
as we bring that up for you the queen is
coming to C3 you don't like this if
you're white seeing a bishop on A3
controlling the dark squares B2 is the
mating square and I actually don't see
any way for Niels to to deal with this
threat and queen E1 that takes away the
C3 Square so at least there's no
Checkmate immediately but if you know
you ready for this let me know when
you're ready you ready I don't think I'm
ready
played by Richard reported Luke H1 is on
the board today is tactics Extravaganza
and Rook H1 what a move if Niels takes
the queen on B4 Brooke takes D1 is
checkmate
and if instead Nils takes on H1 then
once again Queen C3 will lead to the
same checkmate
yeah that's a distraction tactic I've
ever seen one white problems are endless
there's a king on B1 a bishop on A3 back
rank checkmates just because you pushed
upon doesn't mean that your king will
find any space and a forward rank so
Brook H1 show that again instant replay
bam Rook H1 take that Rook I dare you in
comes the queen this round has been so
so fun not for news grandelius but for
me as a commentator hopefully for you as
well Fiona it's been such a fun round I
couldn't agree more I mean we've been
absolutely spoiled today I think we're
going to to stay here uh because we will
see a handshake within within moments
here there is simply no defense Rook H1
uh fantastic tactic by Richard report
was about to score his second
consecutive win Robert
impressive way to rebound after losing
the first game against Duda he is now
going to win his second straight game
and that's the thing about reporting he
can win against anybody he can also
sometimes have some inconsistent chess
and then struggle in certain games but I
I love the way he plays the game always
full of unique ideas as early as the
first few moves of the game and he found
Rook H3 Rook H1 to end this game it's
just amazing how all the focus was on
the queen side where the uh both kings
are and then the winning idea was
bringing that Rook all the way to the
king side to distract the enemy Queen
and deliver a Checkmate and I cannot
hear wait to hear from Richard report we
see Nils try Rook G1 but that's only
going to delay his fate because after
Rook takes G1 white is faced with the
exact same problems with C Richard take
the work really needs recapturing with
the queen and here it comes Queen C3 and
that white king is
done and we see the resignation by Niels
grendelius who could not stop the
Checkmate on B2 what a fantastic game by
Richard Robert
I mean seriously that was well done by
him there was some initial pressure he
had to deal with he did take a pawn for
his troubles and then he was able to
convert with what seemed like relative
ease and unfortunately for Nils
grendelius it doesn't seem like it's
been his tournament uh in round one he
lost that game in round two yesterday
against Sam Shanklin he was in trouble
and here in game three with the white
pieces he was on his back foot
throughout a report I mean that is such
a good showing by the Hungarian super
Grand Master he is an awesome awesome
chess player absolutely and needs
quandelius while he was one of our early
leaders here last year then the second
half didn't go so well for him let's
hope that Niels can bounce back he is of
course capable of beating any of these
guys so we hope that tomorrow there was
uh one final game before the first rest
day let's hope he can bounce back soon
we are back in the bird's eye view
Robert what do you think about that that
game between uh duboff and Village
I I love that game but I'm actually
going to choose a different game because
I see the eval bars go Sky High oh my
God Andre yesapanko and the reason why
is I think this is a blunder from afar
I'm pulling up the game here that
karjakin he made the move Rook to B8
maybe this was a commentator's curse
Fiona we said if anyone can handle the
pressure it is kayaking I think what's
about to happen is a very forcing
sequence Knight D7 Knight D7 Rook D7
free piece thank you very much not so
free rook takes B2 hitting your Bishop
outside pass Pawn with a rook behind it
we love those but here's the problem
Fiona Bishop D3 after A3 there's Bishop
C4 and after A2 I am going to take your
Pawn but first i'm gonna steal your F7
Pawn with check so no matter where your
king goes into the corner over to f8 I
will only then take your Pawn on A2 you
bring your second Rook into the game and
not lucky but good for white is that
Rook G3 exists protecting attacking
whites up one Pawn will win more and
that's the game if yesapanco finds the
sequence
and I think he will because if we go
back to the current position and this is
yet another yet another incredible game
we're witnessing here
um
I think
you don't really what are the
Alternatives what's the alternative to
defend upon on B2
you are always I think is right you're
always going to try and make Knight D7
work and in fact the line that we were
showing I think is not so hard could it
be that from a distance Sergey missed
that F7 would be hanging with Jack I'm
not sure but I think that's part of it
fairly certain that uh yeah sepengo will
figure this out
I think that's exactly it that in this
continuation here A3 A2 you think of
Bishop takes A2 but Bishop F7 check
first is the issue and you can try to
pin uh the bishop in one way or another
but the Rooks will just move to safety
and you're not actually getting what you
want for example after Rook to B3 here
uh I believe that the Rook can just move
because this Rook defends it right so
it's not going to happen for karyakin a
shocking mistake from someone of his
caliber but it is a a mistake from a
distance not just oh he didn't see his
Bishop was hanging of course he saw that
but what he I think is forgetting about
is the caption of seven which he goes
Robert sorry to interrupt you but just
as you're talking we had to close up of
the bishop on D7 which was captured by
Andrea sipanko we're going down this
line Rook takes B2 has just appeared on
the board
and well I think yesi panko he's not
going to miss his chance here
how do you find kuryakyn's poker face
because to me this looks like somebody
who knows he just made a mistake but I
also know for a fact he made a mistake
right yeah it's like my own Poker Face
in existence
oh yeah this is a situation where he's
not bluffing anybody Bishop D3 to C4 not
difficult to see right now I think
unfortunately for Sergey he was feeling
the pressure he knew his position was
worse and for Andre it's a gift that he
was able to earn by putting that
pressure on karyakin it was a big
mistake one that we don't see from a
2750 player very often but it's because
karyakin was just feeling that
discomfort move after move he black
space his position had no counter play
and that's where he ended up making the
last mistake it seems with Rook to B8
and here comes the bishop to C4 and we
talked about uh kariakin's face which is
sort of giving it all away but also
yesterday Panka I think he didn't need
that helping hand of seeing Carrie
Atkins face he spotted this he will spot
Bishop D3 I'm fairly certain we can see
his body language
this is a body language of a player who
smells he knows my opponent messed up I
have a chance here he is going to get
his first win I believe and what has
started has been for asapanko and maybe
we can keep kayaking on screen for a bit
but I have to bring up the board between
did it and dubov I mean look at this
game here and he oh
what
oh maybe this Rook just comes back in
time and goes to A1 but oh I mean maybe
maybe that's also a solution I was about
to change games here but A3 Rook to D1
A2 Rook to A1 and this also looks good
just be sufficient yeah but I need to
bring up this game here I I can't help
myself there is a king on F5 because we
saw all these checks
and here F3 was played and immediately
it's losing for white
right this is the game this is the game
and oh my God I think we have to go
there on camera as well so we have
Daniel and visit
oh my goodness Robert
yeah I mean this king is going to take
this pawn and unfortunately for dubov I
don't think he has enough checks the
king May in fact walk all the way to C1
Take a Walk on the Wild Side here hide
in enemy territory where it's actually
at its safest and the checks run out and
that means the game is videos
that I mean out of all the possible
scenarios that is not one I had
envisioned but that goes to show what
happens when you put on Resistance I
think especially when you play Someone
Like dubov uh someone like is likely
sometimes to overextend his hand take
too many risks want the full point too
much and that can backfire vidit has
held his nerve throughout and it looks
like he is going to score maybe the
first uh well no not the first black win
because that was reports just now today
looks like it's gonna be a good day for
the players with the black pieces wow
wow wow and I have to State this very
clearly that at this point in time we
see that the engine says it's zeros and
it's equal but that is I mean where what
is the move because Rook takes E5 Queen
takes E5 is check and check to the Queen
the corner that means the Queens come
off black wins so I'm actually not sure
what the move is at this point it's very
tricky but I know for certain it wasn't
this because as Village King comes to E4
White's King at the end of this game is
not going to go here when they put the
kings in the center it's going to be a
black king on E5 a white King on D4
signaling a victory for Village Gujarati
who started one after two against the
American players now with the black
pieces going two and a half into three
and I just want to say that when you
know this whole uh growth of the game of
chess online content creators there's
been many fans for many people and
sometimes there are people who mistake
popularity for strength there's no
mistaking this for Vida Gujarati he is
reaching his highest rating ever if he
is able to put nerves aside his King is
on e4 and win this game he will be
ascending towards that 27-40 territory
he is proving his worth as a player his
strength as a player and he's also a
fantastic person so that doesn't hurt
either absolutely seriously and I'm sure
he has that India number one spot uh in
in his sights he could be Discerning
vishiana and soon who's been holding
that spot for God knows how long forever
it feels like
um and with it well he's been given a
check from A8 but it's actually funny
this game started out with vivid's King
being in such a precarious situation and
suddenly look at dubrov's King on H2 as
soon as the checks run out that King in
H2 is gonna be in a world of hurt
I mean I'm drawing the arrows of where
that King has gone like that that's what
just happened in this game is the king
with Rook Bishop Queen staring at it the
king just walked up the board it will
continue King E3 Queen F3 check only
legal move King D2 and there goes that
King to C1 where it finds shelter at
long last and it's over there's nothing
that duboff can do about it this king is
reaching the other side and you don't
get to promote your peace but that will
promote Vida to two and a half out of
three and he will be the leader that
people are chasing
yes because the other well the other
co-leaders Drew their their game between
themselves so vivid uh it looks like a
couple more checks and he will take the
sole lead of the stata steel chest
tournaments of course only three rounds
in But Water started to the game for him
what a turnaround on the other hand
Daniel duboff it will be a devastating
loss for him
oh my goodness and I I just am realizing
I think where I mean I know when the
mistake happened but what the mistake
was and oh my gosh this game was just
full of tactics everywhere but if we go
back to the moment where he went F3 and
Ben Feingold would say never play F3 but
Queen C8 check King takes E4 that is not
possible here because Queen G4 check and
after the King goes to D5 only move
Queen C4 check not Queen takes D1 but
Queen C4 check King D6 Queen C6 is made
I've been thinking about the position
trying to figure out what it could have
been because I mean F3 seemed necessary
there didn't seem to be other options
this is it that was the moment Queen C8
Queen G4 Queen C4 Queen C6 that Queen
does a backward Zorro slicing through
the position and delivering a Checkmate
oh my brother Checkmate two extra books
for black but the king gets trapped on
these six I mean this game Robert I have
never seen as many
different tactical and checkmating
patterns in one game as this one but as
it happened the black king is safe it is
two squares away
I cannot believe it
oh my gosh I mean this game makes people
love and hate stress at the same time
right like you
full of beautiful tactical sequences and
that's why I always recommend you get a
notebook out you start looking through
the game moves you start writing your
notes your annotations what you think
could have or should have happened
because when we just see the engine off
the side and saying that move is correct
that move is correct that move is
correct we take for granted how
difficult those choices were that's why
we play the game that's why people sit
and think and spend 10 20 30 40 an hour
on the clock just for a single move
because of all of these possibilities
vidit for Rook F6 way back when to
survive that attack and to get his King
out here wide open but for the win I'm
seriously so impressed with Vida
guzrathi what a player he is and what a
performance he's having in the early
stages of Vikings a indeed and I see in
the chat drunken name is asking you to
please take a deep dive on this game
well I'm fairly certain uh this will be
our a rapid recap later for the game of
the day but Robert it will be a tough
job for us to pack into 10 minutes what
happened in this game
nobody's gonna hold me back I don't care
what time frame you give me this game is
wonderful and I'm just so excited by all
the great chess we've seen and we we've
talked about this a couple times
blunders inaccuracies how to phrase
certain things and this game I I'm I'd
be wrong to use the word blunder
anywhere I think that that it's defense
the wonderful defense that he showed in
this game has earned him the point that
he is going to obtain I mean seriously
to find Rook F6 to make duboff question
his entire attack in the way that he did
and look at the concentration on his
face right now he is locked in he knows
that the win is just a few moves away he
is not going to let this slip I mean
also Bishop C6 so I do both not giving a
check the King was going to hide but now
it is vivid's turn I was just saying a
minute ago that King on H2 and do both
he know those and that things have
gotten out of control and it will be
really a tough day for him he played
such an interesting game so many
exciting sacrifice ideas and
um yeah always sad to see him like this
but kudos to it it is his turn now
Robert so how do we proceed as black do
we start giving some checks of Our Own
I think you should and the reason why
the bishop came to C6 is because without
the bishop there this queen would come
to a square like D6 and there'd be a
check on the second rankings king would
be in trouble but after G3 the bishop
can slide back to G2 to defend the white
king which is now in danger I just don't
see how duboff can follow things up
let's say I play Queen E5 check you have
to play G3 because King H3 Rook 2 H1 is
a quick Checkmate so G3 has to be played
and I'm gonna try to find the best way
forward here I'm sure there are many
good moves like you could probably even
take pawns on C3 and start mopping
things up but I want to go for this King
and I'm looking across the board I would
like to get my queen in here maybe G4
Queen H5 Queen H3 just Checkmate you
this way that looks pretty promising as
well I mean that's actually how you
can't stop that how do you stop that I
mean if you give checks to the black
king the black king I guess will once
again uh either run to to C1
where it seems to to be safe
if you give a check from F2 I guess I
just go to C1 and oh you just want to
swap Queens yeah I mean King C1 might be
better I think objectively that is
probably the case but when a win is
clear let's just get the win right let's
get the Queens off I agreed why not
um and what was I saying I've lost the
the thread so if you don't give a check
on on A7
after G4 then you have to somehow cover
the square on H5
how do you do that Bishop E8 there will
be another Checkmate incoming here I
guess after Rook D2 G3 is going to fall
and so yeah this looks like it's uh
lights out
yeah no it's uh and even here if we
don't have Checkmate we can trade Queens
again so I can't complain for video here
there's just
too many many possibilities but I like
what he's doing he's spending his time
right now he knows he's has the winning
position that's not in doubt whatsoever
but you want to end the game now because
if the game continues let's say white
got to play these two moves G3 and
Bishop G2 now it's like okay White's
King is safer Black's King can always
hide down in C1 but now you have to
think you have to calculate let's just
end this game give no hope to our
opponent score that full point the
chances reminding us that we're only uh
still on move 35 we are only seven
minutes away from the first time control
and maybe we stay here with the camera
and very quickly just look around and
see if we've have time scrambles going
on elsewhere I think this is the big one
but it's just putting the finishing
touches on it
and let's check on the yester panko uh
game really quickly just see how this is
developed black has pushed pawns up the
board the white king venturing over to
the queen side over here it would be
kind of funny if somehow there was like
a fortress here I mean like I I don't
think there is because the king just
runs over and that will do something
about this Rook but if somehow kayaking
had seen all the way down and it wasn't
a depth issue it was on us you know but
I do think this is just winning for
white and of course Bishop D3 to C4
which we mentioned earlier was possible
so uh yes Banco has this one under
control awesome we need two moves to go
here until the time control so that's
not a problem what about Fabiano against
shankland I guess they made the time
control or they just made the time
control so we'll we'll come back here in
a second I said I suggest we stay with
duboff uh and with it
um because I I expect this one to be
over very very soon
there it is
there it is
what a game that's like really ending it
in style
you know I wouldn't be surprised after
that whole Knight B8 Knight D7 after
those moves maybe that was a mistake I'm
not sure but I wouldn't be surprised if
it had played a perfect game after that
moment funnily enough uh John Rambo is
just writing in a chat with it found all
the top engine moves
okay yeah thank you uh John you know I'm
sure your name is John you know just
like everyone the internet never lies
about their identity uh but I I think
that that was kind of clear actually
like when he found
every single move first taking on G3
playing E4 Knight C5 Rook f8 uh and then
Rook F6 later in the game I really feel
like he played a perfect game after the
opening stage
yeah I mean I'm seeing comments in the
chat with it it's Immortal I'm very
curious to hear from him after the game
and there we see the handshake duboff
stopping the clock uh in resignation and
wow Robert I think we have an early
candidate already it's only round three
but for game not only of the round but
of the tournament
early Canada for game of the year that
was so electric I mean throughout the
whole game it was duboff's position Rook
takes B7 don't forget he sacrificed a
rook and he sacrificed a pawn early in
the game he put his Knight on the rim
that was captured double pawned
everything about this game was special
and some would say it's unfortunate that
the game was spoiled by a mistake I
don't think it was spoiled I mean I
don't expect any result I don't expect
players to find perfect moves but this
game was so so entertaining you can't
ask for more as a chess fan and I right
now am a chess fan I know I'm
commentating I'm doing my best to give
you the best analysis I can but I am a
fan of both of these players they just
played their hearts out
I mean absolutely incredible stuff here
and we saw duboff after the handshake
and not too interested in a in a person
in discussing the ins and outs of this
game he will be very disappointed but
what a day it is full video and his
numerous uh fans I hope we will be
hearing for him I think we're gonna go
uh on a very quick break catch our
breath for a second and hopefully we'll
hear from Viv that and we'll catch up
with all the other games in just a
minute foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
apologies about that we're having some
slight issues but we'll have the
interview later we'll play it once it's
been recorded I was outside when Village
came out from
um from the playing Hall of course he's
delighted his feeling was Robert that he
was lost at some point in that middle
game
yeah I don't blame him for feeling that
way and that's when calculation
supersedes feelings because Vivid he
just proved it he didn't just allow
himself to resign he said I am going to
dig deep and make dubov show me why my
position should be bad and it turns out
that he played as accurate a game as you
could possibly ask for especially under
those circumstances I'm still in shock I
tip my proverbial cap off to vidit in
fact I shot him a message just saying I
was wowed the whole way through such
impressive stuff from him absolutely I
mean uh you could see the smile on his
face when he came out I think especially
when you get to play such a game from
what you feel is a losing position
you're on the back foot from the entire
game you have little time on the clock I
think just uh so so impressive and
Robert he is our new tournament leader
on Two and a Half out of three let's see
how is the chasing pack getting on we
see Sergey kariak in there on the camera
we have the the board as well does he
have any hopes of saving uh this time
came at peacetime
no
um hoping unfortunately isn't going to
get him anywhere and the reason why is
the power of the bishop Bishops are
great pieces and what white is going to
do is play E5 and Bishop to E4 and this
bishop will then guard G2 it also covers
the B1 Square which is extremely
important so the last move played was
King to D1 because had white star with
E5 I don't think it changes oh I was
obviously I don't think it changes okay
it didn't change much the the bar is
trying to figure things out but the
point is you want to play Bishop E4 so
you can trade Rooks playing Bishop D1
which we can do from the start tries to
offer a rook trade but the issue is not
Rook takes E2 even though that might be
fine it's Rook takes G2 and if you trade
on B2 you lose the game by Checkmate in
one that would be quite silly and if you
trade this way you now are in a position
where black has a fortress and probably
the best white has is a four-strom C2
Rook G1 check you have to block and then
Rook G2 back and you just have no moves
as white so the bishop coming to E4 is
really important to defend that G2 Pawn
while opening up an exchange of Rooks
yeah so I say panko we thought he was
gonna go the other way earlier by
bringing the bishop to C4 but it looks
like uh this is going to be good enough
for the full point we can show that one
more time uh so it was
he went one way just to go back the
other
very funny
yeah he he got this though he's got this
and let's see
um I'm happy
I think today I'm gonna win a little
prediction contest so I already have we
have two decisive uh results and I think
yes sir panko is gonna be the third one
no
we have too many too many decisive
results
um this is gonna be the third one you oh
then you're done probably let's check in
with Jordan we haven't been there in a
while
no we have not we'll bring up that game
as uh kayaking digs deep tries to find
something but Jordan he is he was able
to break through and his Pawn is on the
way to promoting The Rook can slide to
B3 that's really important because after
a takes a takes Rook B4 almost gets that
pawn but there's Rook to B3 and after
Rook takes C2 you don't rush your
decision to play B7 because then you
actually lose the pawn instead you play
Rook to B3 and it doesn't matter what
black does C4 The Rook comes up and you
are not stopping me from promoting my
pawn and actually after C3 uh B7 you
want to give a check the king moves oh I
try to cheat we promote and both sides
promote but when one side promotes first
you know you're just gonna get
checkmated and hear Queen G8 check will
lead to a very quick checkmate
and I think we can stay here because
we're actually seeing some of these
lines being out on the board as we speak
um pragnananda has just taken on C2
and well I expect a uridan as you just
showed us to put his own Rook behind his
Pawn
in this game I shouldn't shouldn't take
too much longer
no and perhaps there's a way to win with
King marching to C7 but Rook B3 is
pretty straightforward and I don't think
Jordan is really calculating for the
first time he's probably double triple
checking because you don't want to spoil
this and there he goes Rook B3 is on the
board and I think we could even see a
resignation here quite shortly maybe C4
will be tried
um but I think we can see also from from
prague's face he knows this one is over
yeah and maybe actually C4 I just put my
Rook on the first Rank and that way your
Pawn is never going to promote but
either way it's clear that this is going
in Jordan's favor
so it looks like there's two wins on the
near Horizon I don't know maybe if we
keep these players on the camera uh
while we move on
because Prague looks to me like he's
going through the motions and we we
might see a handshake here uh in a
second so maybe we'll keep him on the
camera and uh do you want to check check
in with Fabiano and Sam
let's go there sure and the last one who
played was F6 by Sam and it seems like
they were repeating moves for a second
here the Knight came to E7 and then to
F5 and the King went up and back and all
that good stuff but finally rookie one
was played and Sam plays the move F6 and
after a trade of Pawns this Knight is
very strong on E6 safe and sound I would
be a bit concerned about a bishop
rerouting to this diagonal but maybe Sam
has this worked out where he's like your
Bishop gets there my king slides back
it's not the end of the world I I am a
little nervous though yeah and Sam I
mean so far his choice of this Berlin
and game being rewarded Fabiano not
quite finding a way to break through
although I agree with you uh and Fabiana
has taken on F6 after the bishop
rewriting to the long diagonal uh there
will still be some things to watch out
for
and maybe back to Jordan and and Prague
sorry for a brief moment because I
thought I made a few quick moves I think
the game is coming coming to a
conclusion as Jordan has just pushed B7
and that pawn is going to be a queen uh
in the next couple of moves Rook e to
check
and I guess the the white king is going
to hide behind the black pond
yeah that pawn is promoting for white
and black spawn is not doing the same so
unfortunately for prognanda he probably
will play C2 The Rook will move
somewhere like G1 with check and then
he'll promote and that will be the game
yeah so Jordan I expected the king to go
to to D6 maybe it can also come back to
to D4
um but either way there is no stopping
and the B Pawn here
what would you play where would you go
I
I don't think it really matters at this
point and it looked like he dragged it
back yeah you did to D4
and now that's a look of I'm gonna
resign
from prognanda
I think so
uh and Pregnant who had a great start uh
he is gonna go down here again so you're
invent for ways to who played a really
interesting opening Choice pregnant and
they had these goal post puns and maybe
we can show them again in a minute but
uh Jordan just kept uh piling up the
pressure throughout the game and I think
pragnananda
cracked when he played this move F3 at
looking for active counter play but in
fact getting too many weaknesses
and you push C2
Rook G1 check and I think that's that
yeah there it is clock stop this
a great game from Jordan honestly I
think Jordan should only play in Vikings
a because if he does that he might be
the first player in 2900 I think he
elevates his game like no other when
he's on his home turf in the no ones I
mean he is uh very impressive here and I
always have to say Kudos bouncing back
from a lost trade away is not easy and
it's nice to see Jordan and Prague there
uh both discussing the games quite
intently
yeah it's a good learning experience for
pragma Nanda of course he didn't come
here just to learn he came here to score
some points but this game was a good
illustration of fantastic preparation by
Jordan he surprised Prague probably
Nanda he really played a very nice game
I think he should be happy with the way
he played and then he made this move F3
a sign that he was uncomfortable for a
long period of time and after that
Jordan was able to take that pawn secure
his advantage and then win the game
and maybe we can keep the players on the
camera while they discuss the game and
bring up the the bird's eye view so so
that we can see what has been happening
here so far so uh four games sorry five
games have ended uh the ran for is still
showing as uh ongoing but I think they
just hadn't put the kings in the middle
yet so we have three decisive results so
for visit in what has been just a Simply
Stunning game I I don't have the words
to do this game Justice beating dubov
with the black pieces a rapid beating
randelius with the black pieces and then
forest with the result they're just
showing up uh taking out pragnananda and
Robert what a day of Chess is it it has
been and it's not even over yet
I mean I feel like everybody is just so
tired in like that happy way like when
you eat a good meal you're tired you
have the itis you're sitting there like
wow that was delicious and now I'm ready
for a nap or for sleep and so we have
been treated to some delicious games
thus far three decisive ones two still
going it looks like Andrea sapenko is
going to score a victory and then that
will leave the All-American Derby
between karwana and Shanklin and that
one will probably go on for a decent
while yes and we see that you're in Van
forest and uh Prague are still sitting
at their board discussing
uh the game and I think it's great
especially in these pandemic times
usually in vacancy we had a lot of
Boards out in the back room and you
would see a lot of the players sit down
uh for a proper post mortem where they
can move uh the pieces unfortunately we
can't do that so much now but so nice to
see the players
staying at the board for a while to
discuss
for sure and it's probably not his first
event here and the Masters group in tots
of Steel uh you know this won't be as
last I have a feeling he is really
showing a good start he's a very
promising player and he'll only get
better from here so Jordan played a
great game showed some excellent opening
ideas and both players will have another
day another round tomorrow
indeed and on the camera we've switched
over to Fabiano who as he predicted uh
well he didn't drop back to Bishop we
were talking about D2 but the idea is
the same to bring the bishop onto to B2
and onto that lung diagonal which is a
threat right now in this position so the
question is how do we deal with it as
black
yeah I think
I was about to say something that I was
going to regret so let me say what I was
going to say and then walk it back I
would say oh I'm not sure it really
matters the point was getting the bishop
on the diagonal but it always matters so
I'm I mean this bishop on D2 coming to
C3 that covers the D2 Square in the
event of Rook d8 like we just saw so
maybe that is important in some
positions I think in terms of the
evaluation it's not too big of a deal
but the bishop did come to B2 with check
the king I think has to go back to F7
because oh and he did it if Knight to D4
you're walking into a pin and that will
allow white potentially to win a pawn
but the way that bar is going Fiona
there is definitely more and it's
probably just like a move like rookie
seven going for this material here I
think that's what would have put black
in big trouble and upon on C7 looking
very hard to defend also the black king
looking in like a quite a quite the
pickle so that's why Sam decided instead
of Knight D4 to go King F7 and another
quick move by Fabiano Rook E3 has been
played already
interesting because Knight H6 check
would have uh forced King to E7 because
that King needs to stay in line with
this knight uh and I guess he's saving
that check because the Knight on E6 in
the game position it can't go anywhere
because if that Knight were to move then
you have rookie seven would check that's
devastating so he's saving up Knight H6
check it is only a single check the king
would have gone to E7 and now we have to
see how Shanklin will respond
yes in this game
um
we fought a second ago when we came from
here that Fabi had a little something
maybe with the bishop coming onto the
long diagonal and also well we talked
about it from the start there is a pawn
majority on the king side where Fabiano
has two verses one on the other hand uh
there was only one pair of Bishops left
and they are uh opposite color Bishops
so Robert do you think there are really
some chances here still for Fabiano or
are we closer to equality
we're definitely close to equality but
black is going to have to prove it it
may have to prove it for a decent amount
of time these positions can be a bit
frustrating as the Knight on E6 is
perfectly placed and you have to just be
happy with that you say uh that night is
good I'm Gonna Keep it here it covers G5
it stops any sort of f4 ideas if you
know white wanted to try to Spring free
a pass Pawn we can't forget that the
pawn structure has been this way since
the opening the Berlin that black has
double pawns even those are three on two
for black on the queen side you're not
making a pass Pawn whereas white has a
two on one so if F4 were to happen then
perhaps we could get upon going but it
seems very far away at this point yeah I
expect this game to go on for a long
time with Fabiano trying everything uh
that's left in this position before
agreeing to a draw and some will have to
still find some precise defending moves
shall we check in with the other
remaining game and see if Andre
yassipango is making progress
let's do just that and Andre was up a
bishop and that's because Sergey
sacrificed that peace it's a sacrifice
that he will likely regret because the
way this position is going we talked
about E5 and I imagine the Fallout will
be Bishop to E4 but perhaps I'm taking
things for granted here because after E5
maybe black will play H4 or some kind of
move like this and after Bishop E4 I'm
curious now if there's something that
black can do because the threat is Rook
takes B2 and Rook takes A2 the
importance of the bishop being on e4 is
very clear it covers the promoting
square and the square The Rook would
like to go to right now
yeah I mean I really I'm not sure what
Sergey can do after
um after a five the bishop looks like it
cannot be stopped
looks yeah looks lost I mean just to
show the point that after Rook takes B2
Pawn takes B2 this would normally be
menacing aha well perhaps it is menacing
after all Rook takes A2 there's Rook
takes G2 because the bishop is
overloaded it can't take on G2 because
you promote so you have to be careful if
you're white here I guess taking on a B2
and then A2 too early will allow black
to survive
yeah so as always you cannot let your
guards down uh too soon okay how do we
avoid this then
um as white we still I guess want to
start with E5
and
this would be four
so Bishop before was was fine that
wasn't the issue right King G7 was just
a whatever move
oh maybe we just take the pawn Nate too
I'm like it's been a long day Robert
it's been an emotional day we've been
through a lot of emotional roller
coasters
yeah no this is just uh clear the Rooks
both hit the A2 Pawn The Rook on E2
Through The Rook on B2 and that's
something that actually I feel like I I
miss sometimes that like The Rook is
still attacking something through
another piece because it doesn't seem
that way but like The Rook I need to
protects A2 Through The Rook on B2 right
yes exactly and uh just as we say that
TSC panko has played the move E5 and I
think this game here will be over very
soon we can also see it from from Sega
is a body language
yeah he is probably extremely
frustrated with himself that he went
Rook E8 to B8 giving up the minor piece
and Andre just played a straightforward
finish to this game he brought his King
to the queen side he now is bringing his
Pawn up so his Bishop can go to E4 and
the A2 Pawn that one looks like a goner
and Sergey unfortunately the pawns look
like they are quite Advanced but there
is just nothing he can do he wishes
those pawns were at least connected but
this way I mean the bishop uh the lights
great Bishop is just keeping everything
under control controlling uh the pawn
energy to controlling the check on B1
and Sergey will have no no other choice
but to resign very shortly and oh
very shortly AKA now you spoke it into
existence Sergey karyakin resigns and
yeah he looks like somebody who's just I
mean disgusted with his play he was
worse all game he's they're talking
about it uh yes a panko he played a nice
one he had an advantage and
and yeah you could tell that character's
like how did I just miss all that
yeah and Uncle uncharacteristic uh
blunder from kariakin who we hail so
many times as at the Minister of Defense
as he's been dubbed by many people
before but today a very uncharacteristic
uh lapse by by Sergey kariakin
and the players just talking about the
game
I do like to see the players analyze at
the board I I think
we look to the engines as the solution
but for the process working through our
thoughts it's always nice to have a
discussion with your opponent because
you say I was thinking a move 18 about
this Choice and then they agree with you
and then you start going down these
variations and it's a lot of fun yes
indeed and it's good to see kariakin I
think it's a tough loss because you
never want to you never want to lose a
game of Jazz full stop of course but
especially not against the Next
Generation from your own country those
are always uh slightly particular
battles and wasn't it uh actually her
reacting that he hasi panko beaten one
of these very early upset games
um at some world rapid and Blitz where
yesi Pango took out some big names
yeah I mean yes sir panko despite his
young age he's been around for a little
while now we talk about his win over
Magnus but he's taken down karyakan
before it's not the first time it won't
be the last time unless they just don't
play each other uh that much but I it's
great to see this Young Generation
coming through
and for kayaking if we're being honest
he definitely cares about every event he
plays in but the big event is this
summer
absolutely when the candidates
tournament uh will be coming up karyakin
he has been a challenger to Magnus
Carlson before and he will be looking to
repeat uh that feeds Robert of course
the candidates tournament you will be
able to follow it on chess.com and here
we see six of the players that have
qualified so far
six out of eight the Grand Prix coming
up vidit Gujarati one of the players
taking part in the Grand Prix along with
hikara and Nakamura dingly ran many big
names it'll be interesting to see that
series of tournaments come to a close so
we know who rounds out those eight
players but Surrey kayakan I don't care
what his rating is at the end of the
event or going into the candidates he
always has a shot in in any event he
plays in he has a style that allows him
to go from tournament to tournament and
he can withstand punches he's not always
the most aggressive player and that's
been a point of criticism of his in the
past even in his match against Magnus
Carlson that he tied in classical chess
before losing in Rapid but he can really
roll with the punches he can take a
worse position and neutralize his
opponent's Advantage so when the Cannons
rolls around due to caruana farrugia
rajab of Nepal machine whoever else
joins them they all will be serious
contenders indeed there was some talk
about people being upset he has a panko
did not get one of the wild cards into
the Grand Prix but I am sure he will be
a contender at some point and we will be
seeing him in a candidates tournament in
the future
I agree I think we will see him compete
you never know because the candidates
are so difficult to qualify for in the
first place let alone win to play for
the world championship but here yes
panko he's showing good results and well
Fabiana carwana he will be playing in
the candidates that is the big event of
2022. this event there are the Olympiad
supposed to happen the grand chest
Horrors always so we are spoiled in
terms of events but this particular
event Fiona in round one carwana had
quite an advantage against karyakin
before letting it dissipate then in
round two against vidit he had no
difficulties with black and you have to
expect but the white pieces against Sam
Shanklin who's off to a bit of a slow
start that Fabiano wanted to win this
game the more I look at this position
the more I think that Sam shanklin's
holding without too much difficulty yes
because it is difficult to make things
happen I I guess as white without uh
opening up yourself too much because
there is a Pawn on B3 you can never drop
that if you play uh F4 at any moment
which is what you want to do to create a
past Pawn you will be opening up your
own King so maybe there's just no Safe
Way for Fabiano to really try and make
progress here
yeah I could see this game petering out
very shortly the last few movies just to
show them is the bishop went to C8
making sure that nice the Knight is safe
and sound Bishop to E5 and I like this
move Bishop E5 because if this Rook at
The Rook D2 say that Rook went somewhere
like this so I'm gonna try to figure out
a way to make that happen
um I don't know I don't want to make a
bad move though but let's say this Rook
went to A2 then there's this tactic with
Bishop takes C7 that's why you see the
the bar go up so high because Bishop C7
Knight C7 Knight D6 check is a nasty
Fork that's why the Rook staying on the
D file for black is so important
indeed and um well we see Fabiano in the
playing Hall we saw the the camera over
overview the playing hauler by now is
quite empty I was wondering who was
still walking around uh but of course
the challengers tournament for those of
you are not aware it's not just the 14
Masters playing here but also
and they're Challengers so there's still
a couple of games going on we see
Fabiano's sipping
um
sipping a cup of tea and our producer
Bigfoot wants to play a game what drink
is Sam Shanklin having
actually a game that I'm supposed to
play or yes Robert you're you're
currently invited
um what drink is Sam Shanklin I I think
the game is we're gonna zoom in little
by little
that looks like a tea bag
and it also looks like a bottle of water
but why is that bottle of water so small
also I'm not a fan of water bottles like
this in general because waste of plastic
and it's just bad for the environment
but that definitely looks like a bag of
tea
it does I think the bag of tea is
Fabiano's choice of drink while Sam
shankland is on the water so Robert you
are the winner of our game
congratulations what's what's my grand
prize Vic
close you get to keep the mouse and talk
us through the remainder of the game
very well done what an honor it is I
just want to thank everybody of course
everybody in chat because you know how
much you all mean to me and it would not
have been possible to win that game
without you also give yourself a Pat in
the back let's get some pogs and some
well what are other things that we need
to get here I don't know I actually I'm
also an absolute Boomer when it comes to
to uh to the memes but I'm sure we'll
find out in a second some Puck times I
see some lures I see some hearts I see
some claps uh
so yeah the full range this one I never
even know ah that is the Pug oh my
goodness showing my ignorance oh look
what I did as soon as I say it the chat
goes wild huh
players are still trying to figure out
if there's a way forward particularly
Fabiano his Pawn structure is better his
both of his minor pieces are extremely
active here but the Knight on E6 holds
the entire position together and if
you're not careful here's how mistakes
are made let's say white made this
really bad move Bishop to h8
and the problem wait it's not bad
somehow it's not bad I was thinking that
Knight F4 led to Checkmate because the
king is in a bad spot and yet rookie
seven check maybe the there's like some
kind of draw here wow
cannot Escape incredible
so here King to H7 and then Knight E3
okay there's oh there's no Perpetual the
night just comes back to defend there is
a fun one I think that this is a oh it's
not even a draw it's a win
and the discovery on C3 wow
Jess can be fun sometimes
you know what time it is
time to take a break
you are correct once again I think we've
ruined it
what do I win this time though I was
correct again I've won two games so I
think you you win uh you win do you have
any chocolate
some chocolate on your break
the chocolate that I already own that's
not winning something that's just eating
what's already in my business to eat it
now oh thank you for the permission
Fiona I really really appreciate it
Robert enjoy the chocolate we'll take a
quick break we'll be back in just a few
minutes with the Lancer reigning game
here Carolina again Franklin see you
soon
Bobby
yeah Robert
can you eat devaretsky's in-game manual
to us one more time yeah no we gotta get
up
[Applause]
it was either yeah
[Laughter]
um you ready let's put that away
thank you let's do it all right
you know what they say though what
happens in Salt Lake stays in Salt Lake
that's the exact same thing
cheers to my Super Jam friends it's been
good the world championship
on chess.com
let's do this
[Music]
chug the whole beer
yeah that was that was I was
oh yeah I'm great
round two
[Music]
can you read
you read endgame manual to us one more
time yeah
you guys have to go
do that
okay okay okay
I just actually didn't expect you to do
it that time it's funnier like I thought
you was a one-time yeah yeah please okay
okay I'm just trying to ad-lib with what
feels now yeah of course it feels
natural wait so we should expect that
next year okay just so I'm mentally
prepared yeah
okay
what is this
it's eggs
I want an omelette with Brie just
[ __ ] easy
you eat it
wasn't expecting that that wasn't either
we could turn a little bit on the
shoulder there
um the uh faster card and unibrow I just
want to thank my sponsors uh very much
for all they do to to promote chess
um I don't think a great future credit
card but faster card yeah wasn't it
faster hard
[Laughter]
it's a dead card
y'all are respecting the wood a little
too much
not faster hard Bobby oh boy I I can't
be with you two anymore okay
I mean I think it's I think it's
hilarious and don't you think people
would would buy this
I don't think anyone's gonna buy that
hey that's the stupidest I've ever seen
in my life
okay
I guess that's it
all right that's it that was great by
the way keep it rolling okay same thing
I love that stupid
yeah and we are Denny who is that guy
who's that
he didn't come in with you guys
no
we're gonna be right back
Bobby yes Robert
can you read deboretsky's in-game manual
to us one more time yeah yeah
I just can't
[Music]
that's so funny
cool when I predict the moves you're
gonna say because we all see things in
the same way and the same speed on this
show Isn't that cool when we do that
it doesn't make me very happy
and let's bring up the analysis board as
we do that so Yvonne can give us her
thoughts on the uh on the Pet Shop go
ahead ifun
uh well yeah actually that's a very good
question because I was firstly trying to
fubby yeah Danny
my throat's still dry
you're like you've already you've had
five glasses of water okay you remember
what happened last time
my throat's still dry
you've already had five glasses of water
and you remember what happened last time
it was an accident you peed your bed
you're looking fresh man all six of them
again dude your haircut just looks great
wait did we start the bit yeah
if Black's A6 Pawn was transported let's
say
goodnight guys
good night Dad
one more time
I said I said it should I not set it
I think it's funny if people say
goodnight Dad I mean poppy but we need
to be in sync
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
crazy game a fascinating game and let's
let's start at the beginning I know it's
a very sensible guy
who me you okay yes
all right why don't you Castle why do
you keep your King on E8
well that's more than just you know but
I was forced to keep miking on yet if I
would like I would love to Castle either
side short or long but um I didn't
really get a chance
um but now you know after I checked the
game I thought like I was pretty lost
and that's what my feeling was but now
when I checked the game with the weak
engine it said that I played all the
best moves so I'm like very happy with
about that yeah
um we will remember this game for a long
time because of the the winning uh uh
king walk I would say like have you ever
played a king walk like that before well
I think
um the King book was good but I don't
think that's the highlight of the game I
think the Highlight was that he played
first of all 93 which was a new idea and
then I did not react in the best way but
at some point I played this F5
completely opening up my king and then
E4 Knight C5 Rook f8 I think it's all
the only moves according to the weak
engine and also I'm very proud of this
move he played Rook B7 gave up a rook
and it looks pretty lost because he has
so many checks but I found this Rook F6
move which keeps the game going
and surprisingly it just says it's equal
and even after that then the king work
becomes the Highlight but I think
previous moves were much tougher the
king work was slightly easier
comparatively how would you rate this
game in your best games collection
um I'm a bit of a perfectionist so if I
played good moves if this king walk and
all this Rook F6 and then Rook D1 check
rookie five taking on B7 all these moves
if they were good then I would
definitely say it's one of my most
memorable games but if they are not good
then I'll pick something else
and for all the viewers out there who
might get inspired by uh by your game
can you just give like a rule of thumb
uh on case on Queen safety well I would
say castling is better for the heart
so try to do that
thank you thanks
[Music]
some Sound Advice there from Vivid
Roberts who is clearly delighted with
his win over dubov I think we will come
back to that game towards the end of our
broadcast
are we we have to there simply is no
choice but to do that but I also want a
t-shirt can did it make one and sends me
with his face on it saying you know
castling is good for the heart because I
would gladly wear that shirt
I'm completely seconding that maybe uh
I'm sure chess.com is watching and we
could do with some new uh we could get
some new video merge
um but no I mean what a game I also like
what he said about being a perfectionist
uh how he's yet to decide if this game
is going to be one of his memorable ones
once he has checked it with a non-week
engine
yeah I mean the engines that are on
relatively low depth if you just go to a
laptop and check very quickly it won't
give you the full scope of the game so
uh he'll definitely dive into that game
in much more detail probably not during
the tournament or at least not yet I I
think he needs to focus on the games
ahead but I think he was grounded he was
humble and he's hungry he wants to keep
going in this tournament and he's got
those Jitters from playing such an
adrenaline filled game but I really like
the way he played it was fantastic and
he is now the leader of Viking Zay
absolutely and what a day it has been
for him the pity of course we are in the
lockdown and in a pandemic I'm sure he
would love to to celebrate this victory
in some way but maybe tomorrow evening
there was a rest day coming up into two
days at the moment not too much to do
here in Vikings they get some dinner go
for a walk but kudos to visit and let's
take a look now at the last remaining
game Karana against shankland where
Fabiano has pushed F4 and now has this
uh G passer
yeah it was the only way to play for a
win and he put his Bishop back on E5
because the bishop was under attack from
the Knight and white if anyone is better
here it's probably white the game is
level at this point uh the bishop on E5
is better than the bishop on C8 because
the bishop attacks the C7 pawn it covers
the length of diagonals it just has more
squares to go to so Sam needs to be a
bit careful but with accurate play here
he should be able to hold the balance
without too much difficulty and they
both have plenty of time they're going
to be sitting and thinking and there's
numerous options Even In This Moment
here like if you sit and do nothing you
make a move like Bishop D7 you get a
little adventurous and try to bring your
knight to D4 at some point uh these
decisions are not easy I mean Knight D4
actually I think tactically is all right
for
so oh wait yes okay it's actually is
okay for black the you leave the C7 Pawn
but you open up an attack on the F5
Knight and if the Knight takes on uh D4
Pawn takes D4 Rook F3 check so I saw
this far and I was giving away the C7
Pawn I'm actually not sure where to
bring the king
um I'm not certain where but let's bring
it to the center and if I lose the pawn
I thought my d-pawn is so fast that it
makes up for the sacrifice of this Pawn
on C7
white could also take on B6 but I guess
that's a pawn you don't want to take
uh you might want to take it you just
might also regret capturing it although
it really needs to be worked out in
advance because if you just give up two
pawns and it's not holding which it
apparently is then you just gave away
material and will likely lose the game
so that's why the nice things about
taking on B6 is that it covers the
square on on G1 and so at least you
don't have that Discovery with Chuck to
promote the pawn
very true
I would not want to do this if I were
Shanklin so at night the move Knight to
D4 was not played instead he just moved
his King back to f8 because he has what
looks like a kind of Fortress at this
point so why should he do anything too
drastic although
nah it doesn't work I was like What if I
do I'm inspired by vid it's King March
so I'm like what what if this King
jumped to G6 then that King on f8 would
be in trouble but that's very far away
King H4 there's always Rook H1 check for
example
yeah so I I expect Fabiano to take a bit
of a some time here to figure out is
there a way forward if yes what is it
and maybe we can uh while Fabiano is
thinking uh look at the the interview
with Jordan van Forrest after his
victory over pragnananda
that's being classified by two double
pawns by your opponents
yeah
um he definitely didn't have a good Pawn
structure basically actually that's the
point of the line I'm playing that he
gets a pawn extra but he's always
playing with this um or this very bad
Pawn structure basically
um and uh it's it's a little bit better
or easier to play For What it's maybe
not all that much but definitely long
term white has a very good Prospect so
finally like taking all the pawns
um basically that's kind of what
happened I got coordinated and his
position became really unpleasant
um finally he played F3 to give back a
pawn for some activity but it was not
quite enough
uh but still it took you quite some time
to actually convert to the win
yeah uh uh um it probably my technique
was actually not so good like uh like in
The Rook end game I could have done
better but uh um the position was so
good I think it was probably never
really in doubt I hope at least and
um
yeah I mean yeah the position is just
too good but of course he's defending
tough and uh it was never easy
you said that like uh this Pawn
structure was like the point of the
whole line
um to me like you played three Bishop C4
In the Sicilian like how much of a
theory or Preparation do you have I've
been planning to play this live for a
long long time already but uh especially
in classical chess but I never got the
chance
um so well my my opponent he plays one
of the uh the the most critical lines so
then you basically get this uh Pawn
structure but of course there are a lot
of other uh variations I just mean in
general the position like after he took
only 4.95 and then uh how the game went
um your brother recently played Queen G4
against the Sicilian
um are you guys looking for like new new
ways
um like not not super theoretical lines
I don't think Queen G4S should be taken
as a should be considered a new way of
playing at least uh don't try it at home
I guess
um but yeah the theory is evolving
rapidly so you're trying to sometimes
catch your opponent off guard
um and um these days
um it seems people try to do the that as
soon as possible basically tomorrow you
go play your boss yeah yeah that's gonna
be an interesting game at least I hope
um uh we'll see how it goes it's the
first time I'm going to be playing with
black against him so extra extra hard of
course but it it's a challenge and I
like it's for me always very special to
play with him so I'm looking forward as
well yeah just to clarify you you will
play Magnus Carlson tomorrow
um do you guys have some kind of
agreement that like you cannot use the
prep against him
um I'm I'm
maybe there's some line of that but I
don't think uh that would be really
strange so I'm I think we'll find a way
to uh get a position uh we haven't
discussed basically gives him a big Edge
he can play whatever he wants and your
your restraint
I don't know I have to think about it I
haven't put any thought into the game
yet but I don't think anything gives him
a big Edge so it's just gonna be a a
game and we'll see I guess you're
defending your title it's a Magnus your
biggest competitor I think everyone is
my biggest competitor so
um yeah well I mean I'm hopefully just
playing well myself but definitely not
thinking of tournament's Victory right
now okay thank you okay thank you
Leonard
[Music]
all right
hit students there for Jordan and Robert
uh I guess Magnus Carlson against you're
an inventory is tomorrow is one of our
standard pairings
it certainly is he said he's playing his
boss but he's not too concerned because
everybody you know is trying to rest
that title from him it's going to be a
tough pairing I see that Fabiano gets a
second white in a row tomorrow he will
need to make use of that he's playing
Daniel dubov who probably is quite upset
and will have a rough night of sleep
after losing the game to videography and
speaking of bitter Gujarati he plays
Andrea sapenko two players who won games
today they should be thrilled and that
should be another good matchup tomorrow
absolutely once again
um I think every day anyway it's always
like oh this is a good matchup but I
mean let's not fool ourselves there's
going to be some great matchups here
every single day today we've been
treated to so much uh entertaining
decisive bloody chess and we have four
decisive results already Fabiano is
still trying to win here with the white
pieces against Samsung Shanklin but it
looks like Sam is doing a great
defensive job so far
Sam certainly is he's holding his hand
towards his head so it looks like he's
going for his Rook that's he's
stretching a bit that Rook is very far
away from the rest of his pieces
so he's probably going to move his Rook
Hey
at first I fought my my TV was bugging
oh and there's Fabiano in the middle of
it all
having some fun here in the fifth hour
of our play
yeah and Rook H1 play that is a
necessary move though by Shanklin
because the point of King to F2 is not
just bringing the king towards the
center but if you get Rook H3 and they
get to bring that Rook up to h8 or H7
black is in some big trouble so that's
why H1 was played Sam reaches across the
board grabs that Rook puts it in the
corner and now for Fabiano's what's the
next idea you
stop I'm not sure either
I'm wondering if there's a way to just
like sort of wait a turn and try to put
the opponents wrong but
I I don't think so there's always going
to be moves for black to just sit on the
position Bishop D7 back to C8 for
example so it's just trying to figure
out a way for white to create some
tricky it just seems very difficult to
create some possibilities if you cannot
activate
uh The King and I think uh the the black
piece is although the only tree pieces
remain they do a great job of working
together
to keep the king out
and this Rook on E3 it just doesn't have
anywhere to go H3 is covered it would
like to perhaps go to A3 but you can't
go through your pawn and if you Retreat
off the third rank then your Pawn on B3
is loose so you don't really have time
to just do whatever you want if you are
car one
yes absolutely and um well Fabiano is
thinking you know Fabiano very well
Robert what do you think his approach
here uh will be will he keep trying for
another hour too or if he understands
that Sam has defended perfectly and he
cannot find a way forward do you think
we might see a draw for
well he's not somebody who offers draws
early and this is not early this is
quite late into the round late into the
game and if he did offer drugs because
no progress can be made and that's
actually how the situation looks he will
try his best he's not going to do
anything wild he's not the type of
player who just sacrifices upon
speculatively he doesn't like
speculation he prefers to calculate
through and
um you know I think in general Fabiano
he looks at this tournament he knows
that every player he's going to face is
tough he wants to make the the most of
his first move Advantage when he has the
white pieces but at this stage of the
game there's only so much to be done
although Rook to D3 suggests that
there's a little something watch out for
your back rank I mean Bishop takes C7 is
a tactical threat so he has no risk he
should play on and that's what he'll do
absolutely I mean this is a threat in
the position uh here Bishop C7 and maybe
we can show that with a pass move
um maybe a rook move somewhere
that's it an interesting pass move there
Robert that's what you call a mouse slip
like I was trying to drag the rook and
it got stuck on F1 so uh let's bring it
to say C1 just say kind of random move
here then well I didn't want to move it
this way because Rook H3 also scares me
but Bishop takes C7 was the point and
then Rook d8 check and down goes the
bishop
so that is uh one threat in the position
and I think well as you also just uh
explained we don't really want to move
the work array from H1 or at least we
don't want to move it along the the
first rank because then Fabiano would be
pouncing on the opportunity to get his
own Rook to the age file
that's what
sorry you can ask the same question no
what what is the waiting move what's the
decision to be made here I was going to
ask you you're going to ask me but Sam
is about to answer it for us I think but
he was really searching for The Rook
which
um
surprises me he's reached back for his
head
maybe Rook H7 I mean it's a very
defensive move but at least it covers
the immediate threat
I mean I'm always
surprised that DeBarge just coolly says
and yeah he does go for work H7 zero
zeros I would not be feeling comfortable
defending this uh as black I have to say
but Sam Shanklin I guess he feels
reasonably comfortable at this stage
though I wonder if black can just wait
forever so say Rook D1 is played Now The
Rook has much more flexibility because
it can also go to the a file uh that
said this bishop can go to B7 at some
point so it's not like black has nothing
to do especially with the Rook on H7 it
covers the point of entry the D7 Square
so that means the bishop is free to go
to the long diagonal if Shanklin so
chooses
and I'm I was wondering
um
if Rook D1
uh can I try and get active by bringing
the Rook trade tree or is the tactic
with Bishops C7 still there
or does it matter that I'm attacking the
pawn on B3 what's going on
it matters for sure and you can see that
the engine says looks like a good move
you have to calculate it probably pretty
deeply because of your Bishop takes a C7
Rook takes B3 and you don't have to move
your knight it still covers the square
but even this position with the bishop
coming back to E5 and a rook coming to
D6 things like that or a knight to D6
get to be really careful at this stage
of the game so I think the players they
see the options but now it's about whose
evaluation function is operating better
as they've already been playing for five
hours also they prepared for the game uh
that's what time is it by you like seven
seven PM yeah yeah it's getting later
they haven't eaten in a while all we've
seen is the T and the water that they're
you know drinking so these things add up
and
also some played some very long games I
mean we remember his Marathon game
against vidit uh from the first round
and then yesterday Sam played the time I
think he played twice the the longest
game or the first day definitely but
yesterday his game against Niels uh was
maybe not the longest but also very
fighting so although it's only round
three this tournaments uh really take it
out of you
yeah he's three for three in terms of
long games and he's a player who he
fights and so far he's had to fight
because game one against vidit vid it
just had a better position and was
pressing here in the third round
Fabiano's been trying to make some
inroads but Sam is defending very well
and then yesterday Sam actually had some
great chances to win against Niels
grandilius and he was not able to do
that right around the time control
nearing move 40 was where Sam went wrong
and Niels was able to stabilize his
position and as we see Sam here he's
still thinking he's still working he's
calculating and he does not want to let
this game slip as we're 51 Moves In
it's uh quite late into the round here
to make a mistake he'll he will not do
that and he will not want to do that
that's for sure yeah and let's look at
the the time control uh again the
longest out of any tournaments we have
100 minutes for 40 moves then an extra
50 minutes for the next 20 then another
finally 15 minutes after move 60 with a
30 second increment from movement right
now the players are on move 51 so they
have nine more moves to make in their
allocated time and then they will get an
extra 15 minutes so Fabiano is still
thinking is it gonna be Rook D1 if not
Rook D1
what other options are there for Fabiano
I think the big question is where do the
pieces belong is the King on F2 is that
where you want to be or does the king
want to be on A3 and I think you have
the time to just walk your king over
unless black has some quick way to
punish that decision but this Rook on H7
needs to stay on the H file I think
that's pretty clear because if you offer
a trade with Rook 2 D7 or something like
that then this Rook slides to H3 and you
have some serious problems to deal with
revolving around Rook to h8 so I think
that black is in the perfect defensive
stance and then that leads me to wonder
okay so what can white do here black
kind of stuck but also very stable now
for white is there something I can
threaten by maneuvering a piece should
this Knight come back to E3 and maybe to
D5 try to go to F6 or attack the C7 pawn
something like that is certainly
available to carwana here
yeah and so a lot of things to consider
and I think the position
is definitely not as simple as I thought
at first sight or not as simply to to
keep equal for some who I think has done
a tremendous job so far pairing every
attempt
of Fabiano I see there's quite a lot of
discussion in the chat about Fabiano's
face mask actually that's the mask that
was handed out to the players here last
year at the Tata steel chess tournament
and I noticed actually Robert that it's
been a favorite of fabianos wherever
I've seen him for the for the past year
he was very often wearing this Tata mask
which the players were handed out plenty
from of course it's a cloth mask so you
can wash it anyway but I think last year
we were given about
15 of them or something
so maybe that specific one isn't his
favorite maybe it's one of his 15
favorites you know
that you know it was free 99 it came
with the Tournament entry so uh you know
he's happy to sport that mask and
oh gosh as someone who wears glasses I'm
pretty impressed that I haven't seen his
glasses fog up too much because I know
from experience that when you wear a
mask like my glasses are always fogging
so the piece has Clear Vision in this
game is
I've been thinking that I think this
mask maybe there is something special
about it maybe that's why he keeps
wearing that one because indeed we
haven't seen the glasses
fogging up so uh shout out to the Tata
steel mask makers
indeed and we see Fabiano Focus both
players trying to assess this position
and it's Fabiano on the clock there are
nine moves until the next time control
as you pointed out Fiona move 60 gives
the players more time and they have
plenty remaining in this segment as well
but I'm trying to really try to dive in
and see where Fabiano can even hope to
make inroads like what's the square
what's the piece where can we make
improvements I would like to threaten to
push my palm I know it's going to be
difficult the Knight on E6 is so good
but
that's what I want to accomplish if I
could push my opponent G5 safely now
black is in some serious danger with
that pawn advancing but G5 is not a good
move here
as we can see that the Knight
can't afford to take this Pawn I don't
think because there's a rook d8 check
getting the bishop but now the pawn has
gone quite far so
actually I'm not sure
like I said it was not a good move and
now I'm looking at like maybe it's not
that unreasonable and Fabiano has just
made his move it isn't G5 but King G3
okay which makes a lot of sense as well
yes it just covers many squares here on
the H file
um and sort of passes the Baton back to
Shanklin you come up with a move I just
found one at long last and
yeah I mean it's a more advanced Square
so you probably pretty happy about that
but I still let's say black plays Bishop
B7 right that kind of waiting move what
is white going to do where is the
winning attempt going to come from
I was wondering when we were looking at
the previous position can we ever put
the bishop our Bishop on the F6 so are
we giving up the defense of some squares
like even after like I like King G3 and
well you were saying what after Bishop
B7 can I go Bishop F6 there
I'll go back in the game so you were
saying Bishop B7 and I was wondering can
I put my Bishop there there might be
Rook H3 check
King takes and then Knight F4 and we
liquidate into a an ending of opposite
color Bishop still not the end of the
story because white has this Pawn that
black needs to deal with uh but it seems
at least by the bar not wavering that
black is doing well enough to survive
this position so G5 Bishop d8 comes to
mind as well but black has Knight C1
going after B3 so it looks like the
queen side pawns are gonna fall
yeah so okay we will see if uh Sam
is
um Sam is still still thinking after
book G3 I'll produce a Bigfoot is being
triggered by the open door uh in the
background of uh of the players here the
playing Hall it always looks so stunning
but in fact this is just a gymnasium a
Sports Hall which is every year in
January being transformed into the
beautiful blue playing Hall uh for a few
weeks
and the players you know they're always
treated very well in Vikings a it's a
fantastic event because the organization
is phenomenal and the atmosphere is
great and of course the competition is
also stellar and right now it's just
Fabiano it's and Sam Shanklin those two
players are duking it out you know that
Fabiano wants to win this game he could
offer a draw that would be accepted at
any moment so you know Fiona that he
really really really wants this one and
the move number 52 Shanklin has plenty
of time he's doing well on the clock but
you get that feeling that if this goes
into that third time control and then
both players are getting low on the
clock that's where those mistakes happen
and it looks like a position where white
can't go wrong and black has to be
careful here not to
make a mistake yeah and while we're
going to come back to this one we're
going to quickly uh go to a video and
hear what Magnus Carlson had to say
after his draw against Duda today
foreign
you continued your theoretical battle in
the anti-martial and very ever in
trouble in this game no I would I
wouldn't say I continued the um
the theoretical battle I kind of
conceded the theoretical battle by going
H6 instead of um instead of D5 and I
basically yeah just wanted to play um
uh some some relatively quiet position
and gradually equalize
um but um yeah I think he played it very
cleverly with Queen C2 and D4 which I'd
kind of underestimated I always thought
I could meet D4 with um with D5 and B5
but then as it happened I was not so
sure
um and he got a little more pressure
than
uh than I had hoped that he would but I
think maybe his only chance was to
refuse The Rook exchange with rupee II
uh go Quincy for instead I think after
he took the Rook which looks very
promising
um because he can sort of kick my Pieces
away after I can kind of um consolidate
and he has to reckon with um with night
jumps and also
um also these ideas of um C6 and F5 all
the time and I think I gradually
equalize or at least get in get the
position to something I can hold
comfortably
um is it surprising to you that your
opponents keep on playing the
anti-martial and not letting you playing
the martial attack itself
uh no
is it because the martial attack is dead
or is it like a death draw or no
if not a good a dead draw it's at least
a good opening that
has been thoroughly analyzed and it's
it's kind of hard to
um that's kind of hard to to get
something there
tomorrow you will play Jordan from
forest the title holder and also your
second in the for the recent match is it
uh special for you to play a second
yeah I can't wait to see what he's uh
got up his sleeve
I'm sure it's gonna be something crazy
okay good luck thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
conceding the theoretical battle to do
that today and he also said Robert he
cannot wait to see what Jordan has up
his sleeve tomorrow which should be a
great game but before we look at the the
pairings for tomorrow let's see what
happened here in round three today
yeah we have four decisive results thus
far 5-0 carwana trying to make it five
but Sam shanklin's saying no sir you're
not getting that Victory but anishikiri
mamajaro if they drew their game we
heard from Magnus Carl Cinema his draw
with Duda and then you see the results
the first wins for the players of the
black pieces report quickly followed by
Vida Gujarati and they beat grundelius
and dubo respectively and then of course
yessa Panko and Von Forest they won with
the white pieces so a very combative day
indeed and well before we come back to
Fabiano's uh fight his he's pressing
against them here are the pairings for
tomorrow we've talked a couple of times
already against about the clash between
Magnus Carlson and his second Jordan van
ferez but there's plenty more action to
look forward to Fabiano cabrana you will
be white against Danny luboff so he will
get another chance with the white pieces
regardless of what happens today we'll
see how Daniel recovers from a tough
loss to visit today and well speaking of
it he is the new tournament leader and
he will be playing against yesi panko
with the white pieces
should be a great day again tomorrow but
right now we just saw a pretty funny
repetition uh while we were away The
Rook went to age seven King G3 we saw
that and then look at this Rook D7
Rook D1
Rook H1 so and then Rook H7 so if if
this looks familiar it's because you
have in fact seen this position before
the king just went to G3 The Rook went
to D7 to D1 to H1 to H7 so we have seen
a repetition and that's clear that
Shanklin knows what he's doing he has
this defensive task in the bag and if
Fabiano is going to continue to try and
win this game to prolong it he needs to
do something new otherwise we'll have a
draw by repetition yeah and Fabiano
while he has 12 minutes remaining on the
clock but only five moves to go until
move 60 when they will get an additional
15 minutes so this attempt with King G3
has been uh I was gonna say dismantled
by by Sam but maybe that's not quite the
right word but here comes the new
attempt Rook D1 a move which we were
looking at just earlier Robert
and it came with a walk away he made the
move got up from the board and he'll
leave Sam to think about how he wants to
respond and I'm trying to figure out the
major differences here so now the king
is on F2 rather than G3 so if Rook to D7
which is what Sam went for before when
the King was on G3 and The Rook on D3
The Rook couldn't go through the white
king So Rook D7 will allow Rook to H1
and that is not what you want to see if
you're a Sam Shanklin right Rook D7 Rook
H1 and now the Rook infiltrates and you
see the evaluation bar go up in White's
favor so there have been small
differences that often go unnoticed but
not by players of this caliber they see
that Fabiano retreated The Rook he wants
to take over the H file I will not allow
him to do that
yeah and now with Sam once again he's
already uh found so many accurate moves
but once again what is the correct move
here he is I've been facing this passive
defensive task for pretty much the whole
game but he's had done his job
marvelously we saw him reach out and
then take the hand back and he's going
to give it another thought but I thought
he was reaching for the bishop
and Bishop B7 is an option
Bishop D7 also is an option though The
Rook being on D1 that is a bit of a
cause for concern here that Rook not
only could go to H1 but it could go to
A1 so you want to be really careful here
if you're Sam that Rook can enter the
game via A7 or A8 it's not like black
has much of a choice if Fabiano wants to
play Rook A1 there's nothing that Sam
can do to stop it uh so you need to
figure out where your pieces should be
for black
and we see Sam reaching again and Bishop
B7 it is so the the light squared Bishop
won this again back along the long
uh diagonal
oh no it doesn't work so I was gonna try
to be cheeky here and I was thinking if
I go Rook E1 how is black going to
respond to this because your knight is
in the same line as my rook and my idea
is if you play King F7 protecting the
Knight then I had Bishop takes C7 here I
believe because I have this Knight D6
check and I guess even getting this this
isn't that great for white but I did
steal a pawn in the
process Rook D7 will trap my knight so
not the ideal scenario it appears
not ideal but another example of of
tactics to look out for in this position
it's never too late I mean even with
such reduced material you always have to
be on the lookout especially when
there's an opponent a night nearby your
king
exactly and another variation rookie one
you know Rook H1 this is the type of
move that black wants to play to
exchange Rooks that might honestly just
be a good decision and white can try to
avoid the trade with Rook E3 and then I
think we're back to where we came from
the bishop can go back to C8 to protect
the Knight and we've been here before
yes uh indeed it seems like we keep
going around uh in circles here but uh
still Fabiano of course he is continuing
trying to find uh ways
to to create problems after Bishop B7
are there any squares that are loose
that the bishop was defending from C8 do
we have any new possibilities
D7 covered by The Rook which is why
Bishop B7 is possible is there a waiting
move like Rook to D2 but then the bishop
can probably just go back to C8
where is the chance and Rook A1 comes to
mind and funnily enough that question
just appeared in the chat by Anis
opteryx what about working one so let's
have a look at that
yeah Rook A1 very reasonable let's go on
to the open file
um and Rook A7 is annoying but the
Knight and the Rook both defend the pawn
so you're not even threatening anything
with Rook A7 if I move my Bishop I could
actually start moving my bishop and I'm
attacking your knight I'm running Bishop
C2 ideas that you need to be on the
lookout for so that's not the most
comfortable situation although if we
take this just one step further can I
almost TR uh sorry say oh King E3 and
you go Bishop C2 I'm wondering if I can
trap your Bishop like Bishop takes B3
and then King C3 and something like this
and rotation
now it's gonna block but now that I see
it you Knight D4 and you survive because
this Knight needs protection and it is
pinned and this Knight defends here uh
by the way uh just the pondering in the
chat to get back to your question about
would we please review Vivid versus
duboff if you want to see the review of
that game stay tuned until the end of
the stream because it will be our rapid
recap Game as soon as the Fabiano game
is over for now we see once again the
bird's eye view with only one live game
remaining four of them have ended
decisively if you want to replay uh any
of the games that have been played so
far you can head to chess.com
events at to play through all the games
and see all the results
yes we will be breaking down what
happened in that wonderful game between
dubov and bit it and Fabiana carwana he
doesn't care about that game he might
care later but right now all he is
thinking about is his moves his position
and Sam shanklin's stubborn defense and
you have to give Sam credit uh some
players would have been broken by now he
is just committing to the task at hand
and he's doing a wonderful job at that
indeed and Fabiano we saw there a slight
Shake of the the head it is a
frustrating a frustrating one for
Fabiano I think it's the story and very
often of the the Berlin end game your
opponent from the side says okay I'll
play in this super solid opening and
white uh tries you know white only has
these small small uh things to play for
but they are Aviano has been trying to
play for that small Edge for the whole
game them doing a perfect job of
Defending so far
so it can be frustrating but he keeps
trying and so he should the bishop has
just gone back to G3
and I'm trying to figure out why the
bishop is placed here it does cover the
H4 Square in case you want to go to a
new diagonal the Knight wants to jump
there it still covers H2 while putting
pressure on C7
what is I mean I don't really see the
huge benefit of the bishop there besides
putting in a new Square so there's no
repetition
can we have any
okay this is gonna be again my idea be
to play night
H4
and Knight although I don't know where
I'm going Robert
hey sometimes that's how you find the
right move is you just look and like
okay night night night oh Knight to E5
that looks right uh it's not entirely
clear where the pieces are going he is
opening up the e-file so maybe Rook E1
is a bit of a threat that black needs to
take into account
um
in fact if rookie one is to be played
that ask an uncomfortable question of
this night although maybe it will try to
go to D4 so
Robert yes Bigfoot wants to hear the
thoughts of our viewers on this
all-important topic of the open door can
we please get a pollen chat make our
producer big happy can we please hear
your thoughts should the door be open or
should it be closed
about
of course you would ask that question we
shouldn't close doors we should be open
to people we should be accepting
understanding empathetic so why are we
talking about closing doors it's not
bothering anybody I think we should
leave the door open
you should always leave leave the door
open and leave a light on
um Robert
is it time for a final
quick break what do you think uh for the
players
uh to reach move 60 and then we'll be
back with the final stages of this game
here
sure if you say so I'm not gonna say
otherwise I'm oh Bishop E4 was played
though the players have a different idea
in mind
hey he makes the move Bishop to E4 he's
trying to take that 9.5 who knows where
that will lead us but I will follow your
lead Fiona
we'll be back in just a few minutes so
don't go anywhere
I just want to say I know it's early
it's early for all of us but Bobby
you're looking fresh no thanks Danny
chat Chad likes it man looking good
all right guys let's go run a show back
here we go
and Fabi this video series was great by
the way and people love it
really do
by the way again dude you're
you're just looking fresh man I love
your new haircut
okay
[Music]
how's it going
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I don't even recognize myself
the whole new me
[Music]
hey Fabe Dan how's it going hey Robert
hey man
you know just trying out a few new
things here and there the day is
beautiful sun is out
cool
hey Danny yeah forgot to mention that
haircut's looking real fresh on you yeah
thanks man
cool appreciate it you [ __ ] serious
what does a guy got to do around you to
get noticed
what are you talking about
that seems a little out of line a little
uncalled for
you know you already can't spell chess
without what does he want
[Music]
[Music]
s
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
Fabiano Carolina Will he win his second
Tata steel chess tournament at the
moment he is still looking for his first
win in this year's event Robert but
today there were a lot of other players
who got what they were looking for which
was the full point
yeah really decisive day it doesn't look
like 500 car one is going to join those
ranks and actually with the last few
moves Sam Shanklin has turned this game
from one that he was holding to perhaps
if Fabiano's not careful that Sam can
even try to win the game I mean right
now we can see that the evaluation says
level but look at this it's so different
there's a night beautifully placed on D4
attacking this Pawn on B3 the last move
was F6 is that a pawn that's wandered
too far or is actually that going to be
a thorn in Black side so to go back to
where we came from Bishop E4 played Rook
to E1 forcing Black's hand here Bishop
takes it Knight Pawn takes Bishop the
Knight moved and then F6 so I think the
first thing that everyone is thinking
about is is that not just a free pawn
and it is a pawn that can be captured
white can immediately force a draw with
the move Rook to E7 because once the
trade of Rooks happens here and you are
two pawns for black white takes one
white takes two white takes three all in
a row it's uh like Pac-Man and you just
grab them all and it's just a draw so
that would end the game peacefully but
also I mean with the pawn and F6 perhaps
Fabiano can try to put his Bishop on E5
and use that pawn to uh try and promote
it's asking a lot and you could lose
because black now has extra pawns over
on the queen side and the Knight can
come to A5 and hit this other Pawn but
it also is a winning attempt
yeah so let's see
um if Fabiano tries to win from here so
if he doesn't go rohi 7
let's have a look at uh was it Bishop E5
you were suggesting
yeah and the Knight can come to A5 to
attack a pawn The Rook I think should
likely go up the board to defend it in a
situation like this where those pawns
are not moving just yet for black I get
that blacks up a pawn that the queen
side majority looks good but one Pawn is
more advanced than the rest and it's the
opponent F6 and how are you gonna make
progress you're gonna try and bring the
king forward
I would love to if you give me a few
free moves my king is going to walk not
that way up this way somewhere and try
to get all the way to G6 this Knight can
go right back into the game and yeah
there's no hope really for white to win
unless black does something ridiculous
because you're already situated right in
front of the pawn so it seems like black
can just bring the Knight back and
there's nothing I would try to force the
draw from Fabiano at this point I don't
really see
too much in the way of winning chances
I'm decided not to take the pawn on B3
3. instead playing Rook H6 attacking the
pawn on F6
okay so he wants that pawn which would
also defend the B6 Pawn which means that
the Knight would then be free to start
taking things but Bishop E5
I don't love The Rook on H6
it is a weird Square so Bishop E5 can I
still go and take on B3
um okay and then I was gonna try to
bring my Rook to an open oh Rook A1
which just traps The Rook it's been a
long day can't do that so I can play
Rook D1 but then you're probably just
gonna bring your knight back to D4 and
all right the game continues like this
king is walking up the board my Rook
nope still can't go to A1 after it
because there's a trick here
can try somewhere else nah this is
nothing this is just totally equal
there's no way to win for why I mean
honestly if anything black is the one
who's gonna have some winning chances so
Fabiano needs to be careful
yeah and well Fabiano is the one who's
thinking I work H6 by the way was move
60 so both players uh we don't see the
times being added yet because I think it
will be added uh once the the three
minutes and that Fabiano has remaining
are gone but they will get an extra 15
minutes now and that's the final uh time
control but I agree with you Robert I I
think we will see a share of the point
here
yeah it's uh you're taking mindset into
account when you've had a better
position for a while sometimes you don't
make that switch too oh I need to calm
down I need to actually just make sure I
have the draw immediately because if I
don't then I may never make that draw so
for Fabiano who was the one pressing now
he's the one that's probably on the
defensive so I think that he should if
he sees a way that just says game's done
let's do it let's make a draw for
example if Bishop takes C7 Brook takes
F6 is check the king just walks away
somewhere like G2 and if the Knight
takes on B3 at this point just go Rook
B1 you win this Pawn here and then
you're gonna take this one and just call
it a day that's what I would probably do
yeah I think Fabiano will do that if he
doesn't see any way to to press any
further which there doesn't seem to be
um I think he's never really the kind to
to overpress too often I think he is
very
what's the word I'm looking for
when you see things the way they are you
know
he's very practical yeah I think he's
very practical there's another word I'm
sure he'll come back to me but he's very
objective also about his evaluations of
the
of the position
so a player who's quite unlikely to to
over extend and um yeah I'm curious if
we're going to maybe even just see that
line that you just showed
pragmatic is another good word actually
yeah
we're playing the thesaurus game now I I
like that game can we do that one
um but he is going to drop the B3 pawn
and then he will have to prove that his
Bishop his Pawn here that that is worth
playing for because he could have just
taken on C7 and made the draw right away
he's choosing to play on his king would
love to get up somewhere like G5 or F5
but that's a ways away
wait he took on C7
Rook F6 is on the board and King G2 and
I think after Knight takes B3 for a
second I found what's going on but it
was a jadoop can you even say Hadoop if
you're wearing a face mask Robert what
if your car doesn't hear it
you know it's extremely important that
when it's just one player against
another that you say jadoob I adjust
however you say it in your native tongue
extremely loudly for everyone to hear
because if you clearly adjust the piece
but don't say it out loud the entire
internet is going to take you by storm
and be like how could you that's
cheating and then it's going to be the
Talk of the Town so I don't know that's
maybe just my opinion but I think that
uh both players will be okay whether or
not it's said out loud
and yeah I think well we looked at this
and indeed it looks like if anyone can
play now uh it is Sam seems to be the
only one because I think that line we
showed which Knight B3 book B1 would
just be an immediate draw
right because you give up B3 you get B6
once B6 Falls then C5 will fall and
white will lose C4 so it's just a mass
exchange of material and Sam might be
looking for something better if he could
play Rook C6 for example and kick the
bishop back then he would be able to win
that pawn on B3 without losing B6 so
this is a good moment for Shanklin to
really dive into the position and not
just accept that the result will be a
drawing there's Rook C6 exactly and uh
it's a it's an interesting moment
because throughout the holy game we felt
some would be take uh accepted draw for
at any time he was always the one
slightly on the back foot
but suddenly he gets the slightest of
chances and he is not happy any longer
to just shake hands and go home and
Fabiano is the one now who's going to to
have to find a few precise used to not
get and to not get into any trouble
yeah and where is this bishop keep it
going I think if it goes to d8 it's not
going to stay in contact with this Pawn
for very long because Bishop d8 after
the move Knight takes B3 even like let's
say we get this position The Rook comes
to B1 if the Knight were to move then B6
Falls but black has this great move King
to E8 you see the evaluation bar sinking
and it's because black is kicking this
bishop off of d8 if Rook takes B3 I take
the bishop I'm up a pawn and my king is
closer to where the action is taking
place and if your Bishop has to move
away somewhere then the Knight will just
move away and attack the C4 Pawn so this
would be a big problem for Fabiano if he
doesn't play with care
indeed and well let's very quickly uh
while we wait for Fabiana to make his
next move go back one more time to show
you the results of today because it's
been such an exciting game we had four
decisive uh four decisive games we had
our first black wins of the tournament
one for Richard to report against Nina's
granddadius and the other undoubtedly
the game of the day we shall come back
to that in our rapid recap of fitted
Gujarati winning an absolute phenomenal
game against Daniel duboff and then two
of our younger players Andrea supanco
took out kariakin and Jordan van Ferris
bouncing back to beat fragnananda the
main clash of the day Duda against
Magnus Carlsen was well fought but ended
peacefully
so many interesting games we are spoiled
of course tomorrow will be another great
day at the office and this day is not
done yet the players do not want to go
home no rest for the weary and for 5.0
in particular I mean he needs to be
careful he has spent the majority of
this game trying to nurse the tiniest of
edges and make it into a win and right
now he's the one who's worth Sam
Shanklin is probably sitting there
thinking all right if Fabiano makes one
inaccuracy now I can take advantage and
play for a win so Fabiano's sitting
there still pondering his turn and it's
not comfortable if you know we've been
there as players when we're better all
game and now we're worse to sit there
and just try to take it in stride we
often become self-critical
yeah it's a it's a weird one for Fabiano
because he just just a couple of moves
ago had the chance to to force the
drawer if we go back uh to that moment
after
um after was it after Knight D4
oh my imagining things you did he not
have
no it was a different variation where
um he if for example Knight takes B3 was
played then we were looking at correct
where it could be a forcing situation
but instead Sam wisely played Rook H6
and now Rook C6 and it's up to Fabiano
to find precise moves yeah maybe this
whole uh
pushing F6 do you think pushing F6 is
the moment that started giving some some
chances of where do you think the
turning point was
I think Fabiano might have overlooked
Bishop E4
uh right here
uh he went Bishop to G3 which was a
retreating move that we were kind of
wondering what the real purpose was and
then Bishop E4 happened and it's black
who's seizing the initiative this
capture we saw in the game otherwise the
bishop was coming to C2 to hit the rook
in the pawn and once we saw these trades
here the rest of the moves are kind of
forced in a sense and now we're at a
point where Fabiano is exercising
caution he will gain more time in the
clock once the player hits zero they go
under if you you know we zoom in the
clock we'll see his time
he is going to use much of his remaining
time to figure out how to play here I do
think that Bishop d8 will still maintain
the balance other moves like retreating
don't really look appetizing they don't
look appealing Knight takes B3 is there
I say appetizing because I'm hungry
would love some lunch eventually but it
really doesn't look appealing to retreat
and Bishop d8 he is just trying to
figure out this situation when Rook B1
is met by King de8
yeah and uh Rook
uh sorry after Bishop d8 Knight takes B3
the question is what do we do
unfortunately as you you said Rook B1
fails to to kenyate but what are the
Alternatives here
I think Rook E5 sacrifice your Bishop
take the last Pawn because rook and
Knight versus Rook is quite an easy
theoretical draw for players at this
level so if this Knight were to move you
say okay I'm about to go or even kind of
better looking is Knight D2 there's no
Rook E4 I'm going to take your Pawn C4
which white cannot afford he's just in
time to play Bishop takes B6 give up the
bishop take that final pawn and then
make a draw yes a night down but a draw
is a draw and what if I don't move my
knight away what if I
um
so yeah in this position what if I try
and bring my king let's say King F7
and I'll give you another turn what's
your next move
okay but yeah you're going to just kind
of bring yours but okay
you I'm trying to set some trips okay
King X7 I'll ask the move to you
okay I'm gonna keep giving you moves you
know Black's turn okay
um
okay
right the thing is this bishop and The
Rook okay you're cutting me off
everywhere exactly and as soon as you
move your knight then I will take the
pawn and then I'll get your last Pawn so
that's going to be a drawing mechanism
we just saw the move
Bishop F4 played by Fabiano so he
Retreats the bishop giving up this Pawn
on B3
hmm
I don't love this decision by him
so what's the what's the idea if some
takes on B3
that he's just gonna try and hold this
position down upon
Fiona we we've had a long day already
full of excitement this one might go a
whole lot longer
hey
thing though because Fabiano has to
prove that he's up to the challenge and
he perhaps can sit his Rook on e4 and
then as soon as the Rook for black moves
away go back to Bishop C7 and this Pawn
is a
permanent Target that you have to deal
with and the King will be cut off I
don't have a good feeling about this one
if you're a five minute carwana fan this
is not going in the direction that you
could be happy about
I still have faith in Fabiano I I don't
still see exactly how is black if I just
bring my king now is right to like C3
over to the the queen side
um but I agree with you of course I mean
for Fabiano this is not gonna be uh this
is not going to be any fun he was the
one pressing throughout the whole game
and all of the sudden he is the one
doing the defending
damn he could have just ended the game
at several moments he played Bishop E5
back to G3 and let Sam play Bishop E4 so
that's what's uncomfortable is he could
have concluded he could have offered a
draw Sam would have readily accepted now
Sam's up a pawn and if a draw were to be
offered Sam would obviously say no why
would you agree to a draw here even
though it's completely even he can play
it out for a while and make Fabiano
prove it
yeah and well there will be I know you
said it um broken of course there would
be no no uh draw offer here I think Sam
would maybe even find some some words of
choice
he would feel quite would you feel quite
disrespected here Robin if your opponent
offered you a drawers right
I mean just not
he's not polite to do that the
etiquette of Chess says the side that
has the advantage is the side that can
offer a draw I mean blacks up a pawn
it's not like white has an attack or
anything to speak of as compensation for
it it is still objectively a level game
but there's no reason why fabino should
ever offer a draw here it would actually
be a bit rude
and the clock situation does some
actually still have 26 minutes
you getting that 15 minutes at the time
control
okay so I didn't realize he still had so
much uh time left leading up to move 50
so I think one of the things that
Fabiano is going to have to be very
mindful about is not to take down uh too
long on the clock because Fabiana only
has 11 minutes at this position we think
should be a draw but you don't want to
be defending it with only a minute on
the clock
now and the 30 second increment will
always come in handy so if you make a
couple quick moves you can gain a minute
or two but here Rook F6 played very
clear please play King to F3 why don't
you play King nef3 that's how you lose
games in the spot the bishop is pinned
so Knight D2 check that you see the bar
go down and it's going to stay down
you can't take the Knight it's Bishop is
pinned to the king so that would allow
black to win the game obviously Fabiano
not going to make that move he can
simply as king G3 and he's gonna walk
his King up the board if you know
something you advocated for a long time
ago and he's going to just hold the
balance by being extremely active and
thus limiting black from getting
everything that he wants going after the
C4 Pawn because Black's King while it's
tucked away in the last rank if the
white king goes up to G5 and even into
G6 then there could be a kind of mating
yet
yeah and it's one of the problems for
some in this position that the king is
cut off on the file you would love to
bring your king uh over
uh over to the queen side maybe via A6
A5 B4 infiltrate uh the white camp but
uh Fabiano isn't gonna let you do that
so easily
certainly not and if you trade Rooks
then white immediately trades and plays
Bishop C7 takes takes so that's another
issue that black needs to deal with is
that if the Rooks get traded this Knight
needs to be somewhere where it defends
the B6 pawn and then you're in a passive
position anyway and not going for
White's remaining Pawn on C4 and on the
back camera there we see the two
Arbiters in the background who are also
waiting for the final day uh final game
of the day to conclude in the Challenger
section everything is over so this is uh
these are the last two players in the
playing Hall there we see one more time
their results of the day with of course
the Magnificent fitted Victory uran
vanfur is beating pregnant report
beating Grand Alias and yesi panko
deciding at the Russian clash in his
favor the other two games were drawn and
we see the two Arbiters also with the
clock it is
1959 here in the Netherlands so in just
a minute we will hit six hours of play
uh Robert which is quite a long game
it's only six
it feels like it's been 26. wow it's uh
been a fun day but also these players
they must be really tired uh chess when
you're going through all the variations
in your head you're calculating
assessing starting all over again with
every single move it's a really tiring
uh adventure and so for Sam Shanklin he
after five plus hours now has the edge
so he's gonna try to maximize that but
there really isn't anything he can do to
get a win here the position is balanced
and Fabian or knows it and he plays King
in G4 and if there's ever a rook trade
as mentioned we swap we play Bishop C7
thank you very much I get your pawns so
if I'm Sam I maybe move Knight to A5 to
start with just try to figure out a way
to
get after White's pawns the bishop can
go back to C7 at any moment
yes indeed and well you Robert you
talked about how grueling determent is
maybe we can take a quick look at the
tournament schedule see when is the
first Wednesday coming up I think the
players will be looking forward to it
eagerly so we have one more game
tomorrow tomorrow is round four
um and after that on January the 19th we
have our first rest day after that there
will be another four rounds so I think
the this first stretch of the first
eight rounds uh is quite intense but
after that there was another rest day
on January 24th then only two games
before the third and final rest day on
January 27th and then the final weekend
of the tournament where everything will
be decided so a long tournament and so
important we haven't talked about it so
much but I think it's so important for
the players to arrive here in good
physical shape
certainly because when you're sitting at
the board for this long and working
through the complexities of the game
that takes a lot out of you so if you're
not in your best physical shape you're
not going to be able to play your best
chess and that's been talked about much
more recently than it was in the past
and I think we've seen exercise and uh
physical well-being that has become
increasingly important whereas you know
back in the day it used to be like a
kind of a running joke players were
smoking at the board and drinking at the
board and doing all that kind of stuff
of course some players smoke some
players drink but they also put more of
an emphasis on the physical aspects of
their entire being indeed and I think
here in Vegas well it's such a a small
town but very often if you are in the
village either in the mornings before
the round or in the evenings uh you will
bump quite a lot into the players who
are going for Works uh it is a small
village so there are no gyms there are
no gyms at the hotels there are no
swimming pools so you will see
um the players going for for long walks
it is very Scenic for for that though
with some some green fields at the
beaches of course right here
so that's how the the players try and
balance the many hours spent at the
board
and Sam he is still in the tank trying
to figure out how he can potentially
make progress but it looks like Fabiano
has found a good defensive setup
he certainly has because his king is up
the board which all which means that
black can't bring his King up too much
more either so we sit here we think what
can we do what trades do we want
honestly black doesn't really want to
trade but if black doesn't trade
anything then there's no way to make
progress and that's why this game
remains even despite the extra material
for black
and Robert I think we're gonna go on
another a short break as uh Sam has just
given a check but we'll come back to
this game in just a couple of minutes
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
first time was 2015 I was playing the B
section I had a fantastic result I made
plus five but way you was an absolute
Terminator
I played him with white in round one and
it was a draw and it was just I never
had a chance again if I had known that
he was going to go nuts maybe I would
have uh pushed a little harder
I remember at first it was chorus chess
before it was taught us deal and I
always remembered this was like the the
most important Tournament of the year
the biggest the best one
you know they call it the Wimbledon of
trust and I think they've earned that
name uh it's just the best tournament in
the world
obviously you know with Magnus in the
field and I'm in the bottom half uh the
odds are against me but you know if the
best player always won chess would be a
very boring game I'm just gonna play my
best and if the points come that way
they will
so I use technology for opening
preparation for sure but that's more or
less the only thing I use it for I think
I'm more scared in terms of the future
of trust of computers just processing
faster and then if they've become a
little bit stronger I worry that one day
chess can be weakly solved
luckily I still think that day is very
very far away and I think it will be
after I'm retired many many years in the
future
it was a very memorable tournament for
me both with positive and negative
attributes last time but I'm really
looking forward to playing again this
year
[Music]
and good to hear from Sam dare who has
good memories from vicenzie today while
we see him a deeply focused
so trying to see if there is any way
here to break Fabiano's defenses Fabiano
who may be overpriced just a little bit
and now has to defend a pawn down but
Robert we think he found a good setup
he certainly did he just put his Bishop
on G5 to block the check against his
king and a pin piece can still protect
the square so Rook E7 check that Bishop
still defends the E7 Square he'll try to
push the king back and then this Rook
can perhaps go to B7 the king's gonna
try to infiltrate via F5 black is trying
to win it really doesn't look like he's
going to be able to because of White's
activity and well-placed pieces
and sometimes you even have to be
careful again to not suddenly overpress
as black here you don't want uh suddenly
the white king to come in the uh the
white Rook to appear on E7 to being
pushed back so I think we will see a
draw here but I don't think it will be
immediate
no yeah although it's kind of funny
because if you look at the Players
Fabiano looks kind of
I'm ready for this game to be done and
Sam looked a little distressed even
though for the most part he was the one
who had the slightly worse position now
he's like I really want to find
something anyway to go for a win there
just isn't anything happening here The
Rook coming E7 if Knight to D4 although
this and he just made a move and what is
it Knight to A5
but I was going to say that had he
chosen Knight to D4 and white played
Rook 2 E7 check that you have to be
careful because now Rook takes G5 is a
threat removing the guard of this rook
and if the Rook moves away somewhere you
have to watch out for 96 type of ideas
you're fortunate in a position like this
that's after Rook to B7 Knight E6
there's King F5 hitting the rook and if
the Rook takes the bishop then you lose
your knight so white
gets into a pin a bit of a pickle but
King F5 would solve all the problems yes
so very nice for Fabiana I'm sure you
had seen this from a distance but a very
nice resource King F5 with the double
attack against the black and rookie
Knight so Knight E4 wasn't played
instead the same is trying Knight A5 so
putting some pressure on the pawn on C4
and I wonder can we bring our King
closer
uh the move I'm looking at is King F5
Rook E7 of course is also tempting what
do you think
yeah if King F5 perhaps this Knight will
come back to C6 which covers the E7
square and then Knight D4 check in the
future uh the Knight could have been on
D4 right away I think that Rook E7 check
the King has to go back and then maybe
Rook D7 uh is possible I understand I'm
giving away a second pawn and some of
you may be nervous about that or think
I'm just blundering I did it
intentionally it may end up being bad
but I'm trying to do something here by
going King F5 we talked about how the
mating Nets can be a bit scary uh here I
don't think that white is in any danger
of losing because even in the event of a
rook trade the white king is so close
and the bishop will sacrifice itself at
the very least for these two pawns here
so there's no real risk in this position
for Fabiano that's why the bar just
remains around zero it's why Fabio
doesn't seem bothered by anything that's
going on even in the event he's on two
full pawns he'll be able to hold the
ensued end game
yes but Fabiano down to seven minutes
so
um one thing maybe the only thing to to
keep an eye out for he's gonna have
another sip oh no it's water by now the
tea is a gun
and yeah I I like what you demonstrated
that even losing another Pawn which look
would look very scary uh to most of us
if the pieces are active it should all
be good for Fabiano do you think he's
gonna go over Q7
I think he's going to spend a couple
more minutes here although he is getting
pretty low on the clock and the position
is simplified in a way that there aren't
too many pieces remaining but the
decisions aren't that simple so he needs
to be careful here there is the 30
second increment but there's no more
time to be had except for that increment
and you don't want to be on your waning
seconds and then have a critical moment
we saw what happened yesterday right
with report against Von Forest where
Jordan actually blundered in time
trouble I actually you know regret even
calling it a blunder it was a very
tricky ending but he made a losing move
with his Knight Retreat because he
thought that if the knights got traded
he would lose the king and pawn end game
so
um it's these moments that can be the
difference between a half point and a
loss and for Fabiano he's getting lower
and lower on the clock
yes but he is so hugely experienced I
wonder what about my move King F5 I
still want to to bring the king closer
is that also an option or am I
running into into any trouble here
no it's a fine move the night will come
back to C6 just to stop your check maybe
I'll bring my knight to D4 uh with check
if I can make it work and my Rook is now
free so the move itself is fine I think
many of the moves that we'll see are
going to be about equivalent or just
totally fine what's more so about how
the trajectory of the game is going to
go because if you allow Black's King you
made this point earlier which is a great
point that King can somehow work its way
to the queen side then you have to be
really concerned and so if that Rook
were to move from E4 and the King was
able to start walking that's when people
start fretting about different
variations and right now everything is
under control did he play rookie seven
no it's my analysis I'm still waiting to
see what Fabiano does five minutes on
the clock at which point do you start
getting nervous
if it were yourself
probably move one but uh besides besides
that uh five minutes is plenty of time
here I I would think because it doesn't
seem like there's a losing move that
will happen that quickly even if the C4
Pawn is taken which you don't want to
happen I still think that it is closer
for a to a white draw than it is a white
shark a draw it draws between both
players then a win for black and we see
the close up there onto the clock and so
just under six minutes for Fabiano 17
minutes and 20 seconds for some
shankland as Fabiano has gone for
working seven-track kicking back the
king to f8 and then putting his Rook
onto D7
and it's a line we were talking about
just before you give up this C4 pawn and
then you bring your king in and either
the black king gets in trouble if you
leave the Rooks on the board or if you
trade the Rooks let's say Knight C4 King
F5 Rook D6 we swap Brooks The King can
go into the E6 square and then this
bishop is going to quickly attack these
pawns the white king is also around to
start attacking them and this is just
still a draw so two pawns ahead not
enough material to work with to win this
game and I think we're getting closer to
the conclusion of the game because uh if
you're a Sam Shanklin then you've done
all this work bringing the Knight to the
room 285 just to attack the pawn on C4
if you're not gonna take it what is the
there is not really any other way to to
make a progress I believe can you try
king8
King 8 is Rook d8 check so I can just
kick your king back to F7 I think you
have to take the pawn but it's very
clear that Fabiano has no issues with
that resulting position and he shouldn't
uh the king for white is just so much
more active than the black king
yes and uh well Sam
I think he is taking his time now
um
not laughing at him you know he really
is trying to win this game so you have
to give him credit he's a really hard
worker and he's working hard at the
board right now but it is kind of funny
you know he just seemed stressed like I
need to find something there just isn't
anything to find this dress followed by
not like this I'm the first to start the
not like this is in the chat and yeah
Samuel he had a frustrating draw against
Nils yesterday
um and today I think again both players
likely to walk away uh feeling not
completely happy with the draw if it
happens
well we know what happens in bitter
schemes when he does the not like this
so I think Sam's just trying to take one
out of his book he's like that guy's
winning his games
making these uh motions I'm gonna do the
same but no he should be happy with the
draw he's played a good game he was
solid throughout and he's playing
against Fabiano caruana so drawing him
with black is a good result and the play
was good
he ended uh a great game by Sam who
I think we'll soon
um
give up his attempts to to win this game
as Fabiano
after maybe pressing a slightly uh
slightly too much finding himself a pawn
down he didn't lose his school he
regrouped and found this nice active
defense here he can go two pawns down
but as you said the king is just simply
too close and the black pawns will drop
eventually
I'm just wondering which move Sam will
play like will he played Knight takes C4
and then we'll see the king come down
five or will he do something else
because there's actually a force draw
sequence that we were talking about Rook
D6 and the reason I was mentioning uh
the move Rook to D6 here
rather than anything else because if
Rook C6 is played Rook d8 Rook D7 is a
draw on the spot like you just can't do
it nowhere to hide
that's it right the King on F5 is taking
away these forward squares the bishop
and The Rook do the rest and the King
will just have to go to the back Rank
and then back to a square like F7 so
that's why Rook D6 uh was my
recommendation and Bishop E7 check the
king comes to E8 this is also going to
be a draw because that's a rook takes D6
if you take the bishop takes I don't
even think about Bishop E7 initially but
now that we're here we can make a draw
in a bunch of different ways and I guess
that is really why Sam is thinking
because Rook D6 allows Bishop E7 check
which means there's nothing else to
consider after that and
the game is a force drop
yeah I think he will
have to eventually
admit that there isn't any anything else
of course we can only commend him for
trying uh he is such a fighting player
but there he goes the close-up just in
time of the night capturing upon on C4
and there goes Fabiano's King to F5 and
Sam there it is the driver he looks at
him the hands they Shake him and that is
that Fiona round three officially in the
books that was a really long round
incredible and we see them getting up
there very fast from the board uh he's
probably not happy with how the game
concluded in the end but I think
very often that's the case right after
the game but then if you go back to the
hotel and and you look at the game as a
whole I think all in all Sam did great
and of course uh a draw against Fabiano
with the black pieces especially when
you were on the back foot for for 90 of
the game is a great result and um and
yeah what around it has been Robert
indeed and we are not done just yet
first of all here are the complete
results of round three we had three
draws between Duda Carlson between Gary
and Mahmoud and the one we just saw
between Carolina and Samsung but Robert
we also had four decisive results
we most certainly did you know Shanklin
he tried so hard he got so far in the
end it didn't even matter the game
concluded as the draw we thought it
would be but four other games did end
decisively we see report yes a Panko
vidit and Jordan Von forest all taking
down their opponents so we had a very
exciting day
I mean I loved it
yes I mean uh we were really treated to
to one of the early candidates for game
of the year which in case you have
missed it don't go anywhere because we
are going to go on a final quick break
of the day to get set up and we'll be
back with the rapid recap of the day in
which we'll be looking of course at the
game between Daniel duboff and visit
Gujarati so don't go anywhere and we'll
see you in a sec
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it was a brilliant day in Vikings day
and without further Ado we bring you the
round three rapid recap Fiona we could
make no other choice than a game between
Daniel dubov and Vida Gujarati indeed an
early front runner for Game of the Year
not just game of the tournament and
let's see it started off quietly with an
Italian game Daniel dubov he can play
anything he will play anything but he
soon sprung the first surprise
right here he played Bishop G5 which is
not the most common move instead of
castling for white or other variations
but instead Bishop G5 and after H6 he
Retreats his bishop and Fiona right
around here Knight A3 what an odd choice
and Vida talked about it after the game
Knight A3 was the first real surprise of
the game for him after some thought he
decided to take the Knight on A3 always
a double-edged decision
yes white gets the bishop here but also
a ruined Pawn structure here on the
queen side but the game started heating
up where vidit he was a bit
self-critical about the move Knight to
B8 but it worked out in his favor as he
rewrites the Knight to D7 and here Fiona
this is where it gets spicy and the G5
kicking back the white bishop and visit
now deciding to take the pawn on e4
which is going to of course open up all
the lines in front of that on Castle
King on E8
as Vivid said this is modern chess for
you he takes this Pawn on e4 it attacks
the bishop it attacks the pawn on C3 so
dubal plays Queen C2 we see another
brilliant Choice Pawn to F5 if my King's
going to be in Danger let's put in all
the danger it can handle and after de5
we saw a trade Rook to E1 Knight takes
Bishop Pawn takes E4 and Fiona we saw G4
things are heating up and how did Vida
handle this with it handled things
incredibly well he was already the time
was taking then but Village just started
playing perfect chess he now just
ignored this G4 G for push jumped with
the Knight into C5 and do what doing the
same ringing his own night forward via
D4 and Rook f8 admitting I'm never going
to Castle kingside that was off the
table for a while already but that work
on f8 Robert soon played it started
playing a very important role because
what was zubrov about one cork here it
was a heroic piece indeed we saw GFI
Bishop F5 and now this was the first
humongous shot of the game Rook takes B7
the point being that after Knight takes
B7 Bishop B5 is check to the miserable
King if you go King to d8 you walk into
a fork Knight C6 check is a problem you
lose your queen if the bishop returns to
D7 Rook takes E4 guess what white wins
your queen again that leaves you with
one other option King F7 white snaps off
his Bishop on F5 hits the queen hits E4
the bishop can come back to C4 H6 is
under attack E4 as mentioned is
threatened this would have been a bad
news for vidit so Fiona instead of
capturing a rook we don't have to
immediately recapture Pieces Just
because they took hours what a move did
it played here he took some time we were
incredibly worried you don't want to
find yourself in this position against
danilov who's just sacrificed a piece
but a village Gujarati he played the
incredibly calm and cool work F6 which
turns out to be the only move in the
position I wish I could give that like
three exclamation points and as we were
just seeing in the previous variation
that when this bishop came to B5 with
check the king got in the rook's path
but with the Rook here now Knight takes
B7 is in fact a threat and duboff said
threat what are you talking about let's
play Queen to B1 the Knight took the
Rook the queen swooped into B7 and
here's where everything broke loose Rook
d8 Knight F5 Rook F5 and Fiona from a
distance perhaps dubop didn't see vid at
saving grace here indeed it looks like
the black king is in a lot of trouble
all the pieces are swooping in uh we are
screwing the queen and the King rookie
five the move you want to play
immediately it doesn't work Robert
no it does not you'll see that
evaluation bar go Sky High because Queen
C6 check ends the story here if the king
were to go to f8 Queen takes H6 with
check the queen can go to h8 with check
pick up a rook in the center of the
board he had the Rook blocked on D7
Queen G6 check if King f8 we just told
you what it would happen Queen H6 Queen
h8 actually Queen G8 is mating one what
am I talking about I can't see the
obvious but instead King d8 the point is
Queen G8 check Queen blocks no we don't
trade Queens we do it on our own terms
because the bishop defends the queen on
G8 we stole a rook in the center that
means white would have been a piece of
head and maybe the move that fitted
played and that do both might have
missed from a distance the Saving Grace
Rook D1 check freeing up that
all-important d8 square for the king and
dubov here stepped out of the check and
now rookie five is a different story
completely different story as you
mentioned the d8 square is vacated king
f8 would have run to the same exact
problem with the check and queen h8
winning this rook in the center so king
d8 and the fireworks just really started
continuing Queen a check King to D7
Bishop B5 check that King goes up to E6
we'll give it another check why don't we
the king steps to F6 and now after Queen
AJ check it's not losing because of the
move King to F5 Fiona
incredible stuff what a king run uh by
vidit Gujarati and here is it the moment
where Daniel Duba finally took the wrong
step Robert
it was he made the move F3 which I can
understand because Rook takes E5 Queen
takes E5 is a check to the king the
check to the queen that would force the
queen trade and black is up a rook for a
bishop so instead of these moves the
only move was Queen C8 check I can
forgive Daniel for missing this because
King takes E4 is not possible Queen G4
check you see the bar go up King to D5
it is not Queen takes Rook that's the
move that we were all thinking no it is
Queen C4 check the King has only one
square and this is sort of a smothered
mate the rook and the queen they block
the king's access to free squares that
is check and mate on the board so that
is what Daniel dubov missed and vidit
was missing nothing after that was not
played yeah F3 Daniel dubov taking uh a
wrong step and visit was just clinical
from here on out with the King that has
been all over the board already now
running for his Safe Haven all the way
in the white Camp it's heading for C1
that's why Daniel he didn't try to give
another check because the king would go
to D1 and finally 2c1 when there is no
more checks in the position and so
instead Daniel tried Bishop C6 but now
all that was left to do a forward it was
to put the finishing touches on this
position
and he made it look easy he pushes his
Pawn to G4 one last check King D2 and
that is where the game concludes because
Queen F2 check even Queen E2 forcing the
Queens off the board because the White
Queen is pinned to the king that would
end any debate because black is up that
Rook for the bishop and we're going to
end our game here that was your round
three rapid recap
and absolutely stunning game we hope you
all enjoyed this recap and not only did
Vivid win this brilliant game it also
proposed him to the lead of the
tournament he is now in the Seoul lead
on Two and a Half out of three followed
by a pack of five players on two out of
three among them uh world champion
Magnus Carlson World Cup winner Ian
Kershaw Duda the Fantastic
Hungarian attacking player Richard
report Andrea cipenko who beat his
fellow countrymen
um Sergey kariakin today and of course
the defending Champion Jordan van for
race who will be playing against his
boss Magnus Carlson tomorrow Robert
yeah he's gonna say tomorrow you're not
the boss of me that was a one-time deal
only for the world championship but
Jordan said it's always a pleasure to
play against the world champion I'm sure
they did some sparring some training
games as part of the preparation for the
match against Jana pomonishi but there
are six other games that look equally
fascinating Fiona I in particular vidit
Gujarati white pieces he's the
tournament leader he takes on Andre
yesapenko who now has two out of three
after beating his compatriot Sergey
kriyakin indeed both of them will be
coming fresh off a win and they will be
eager to keep the Run going and I think
tomorrow is also an interesting day
because it is the last day before the
rest day which is coming up in just two
days so it's always curious to see how
much are the players willing at two risk
so a lot of new storylines to follow
tomorrow we will be back same place same
time it starts at 2 p.m Central European
Time That's 5 A.M them Pacific Robert
what a day it has been thank you so much
to you thank you so much to the chat
thank you for watching us uh and Robert
I'll leave you the final words
well it felt like three days in one and
there were four decisive games so we had
a treat Vikings they brings out the best
in many players and it's just such a fun
term and filled with the who's who of
chess the top rated players in the world
some youngsters like prognanda it was
not his day today but tomorrow the sun
still shines he gets to come back to the
board and try his and best and try to
get another win or Not Another he hasn't
had one yet but another in his
illustrious career already at just 16.
so Fiona thank you so much for joining
me I know it's been a long long day but
day four should just be even better than
the great day three we just had I'm
certainly looking forward to it I'll see
you then I'll see you all in the chat
tomorrow have a good one we'll see you
then take care bye bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]